[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella that my
friends is a chess legacy
[Music]
passion for chess
continues to thrive in madrid
for the first time in 30 years spain's
capital plays host to the candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
oh and look at ding i mean he knows it's
over ding never quite felt comfortable
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess
the world chess championship
[Music]
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess yet still
chasing unfinished business
and a little sympathy you know what that
means satisfied he's got a draw in his
pocket
and others from the next wave of stars
with little patience for yielding to
those before them
miss amigos
the next challenger to the world
champion of chess must come through
madrid
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
[Music]
miss amigos we see friends of chess
coming to the palacio de centonia every
single day hikaru nakamura young tristab
duda they sign autographs take photos
there's jan napoli with his fans team
over java smiling with signing
autographs having a good old time with
chess lovers and speaking of chess
lovers this is where the chess.com
spanish team does their commentatory
people will trickle in here sit down
listen to these great commentators the
players they have not made their way to
the playing hall just yet but they still
have a little bit of time before round
13 commences
we had a rest day yesterday but i want
to remind everybody if they've already
forgotten international master elmira
kripchenko grand master daniel naradiski
i'm grand master robert hess almira how
did you enjoy your rest day yesterday
well i spent well some of my first day
at home like and then i played a few
blitz games you know you've transformed
me guys been some bad influence on me
uh-oh and i'm gonna blame donya for that
because he's a blitz machine and you
were playing some blitz chest yourself
yesterday i was well in the first half
of the day i toured the beautiful city
of segovia
and then on my way back i found out that
a certain someone was playing blitz in
the parque el retiro so i knew i wasn't
going back to the hotel i missed that
certain summon by a couple of minutes
but i still got to play anna kremling
and got to hang out in the park and then
that evening i still got to see magnus
carlsen and anish and i had a great
great time yesterday and most
importantly i got a lot of sleep wow and
of course dennis skips up the dinner he
had with me last night so the least
important part of his day and i my
invitation got lost in the mail but
somebody who needs no invitation to win
his second consecutive candidates is yon
napomshi amira eight and a half points
for him he's two points ahead of the
people trillium and they're only two
rounds to go there are two rounds to go
and yandy pomnesh is only half a point
away from the tournament victory so he
needs a drawer today but let's have a
look at the standings uh hikaru nakamura
and jingleren are tied for the second
place with six and a half points
dimurajaba and fabiana caruana have six
points richard japort and young sister
of duda have five points and uh
theoretically all of these players are
can finish second in this tournament
only elira zafuza who is on the clear
last place can no longer win the
tournament or be second so every player
is within the striking distance of the
second place that's absolutely true and
uh daniel how strange it in a way to see
team over jabba finally getting his way
into the top half of the field it's
crazy and it still doesn't add up that
teamwork one with black and 20 moves in
the last round
i i'll talk about this more when we
discuss today's match up but i feel like
timor has been consistently
underestimated the factor of experience
has been underestimated by most chess
fans this is a guy who beat gary
kasparov in 2003
with black that's 20 years ago timor is
impervious to nerves he's been centered
he's been playing well and i think he's
thrilled to be where he is in the
tournament standing he's fighting for
second place well team over jabba he may
be overestimated by some and overlooked
by others but he certainly is not
because by us because he was the
spotlight of our round 12 recap
timor rajab surprised dingleroon with
the unusual but effective knight to a6
right out of the opening ding tried to
press for an advantage avoiding drawing
lines and castling and accepting
significant risk to do so
rajib found multiple subtle but
effective moves to increase the pressure
he himself particularly liked rook to b6
um but in my opinion i don't know after
the best move from me i think was rook
b6
because rook b6 at least gives some kind
of tricks and also
his time was going down and so on and
those pressure is on him not on me so
yeah it seems that i'm playing uh better
in this tournament against the players
who are leading
after ding played the weakening pawn
move f3 rajab targeted the extremely
soft e3 pawn and broke through just a
few moves later with the brilliant rook
takes e3
and what else is a very powerful force
is rook takes e3 which is on the board
no hesitation
taking rajabov's rook would have led to
a killing king hunt beautiful checkmates
loomed king f1 bishop c5 king upon rook
takes f3 and you have a bowden's mate on
top of everything else this would be
made without the rook the queen and the
knight
ding declined the rook sacrifice and
tried to fight on a pawn down but his
king was too weak and his pieces too
scattered he was forced to resign just
five moves later
amira we heard from timur job he says
he's at his best when playing some of
the tournament leaders
well first of all he emerged victorious
from this clash of the titans but let's
be honest no one was betting on him
especially with black against dingler
and that was a very important victory
and he is back in the race he certainly
is and donya he beat hikaru nakamura a
few rounds before that so the second
half has been very kind to team over job
off yeah both of his wins have been very
impressive his draws have been very
solid his opening preparation has been
stellar really whichever way you look at
it tomorrow jabba's performance in the
second half the tournament has been a
tour de force
it certainly has been and he is trying
to force himself into the conversation
for second place but we had timor in the
studio we asked him his thoughts and he
was very matter-of-fact about whether or
not magnus carlsen would be playing in
the next world championship
i'm sure that he will play the match i
don't know why
everybody is still stressing out about
this i think it's not the first time
that he's saying this um
all the world champions all the world
champions i guess and the the people who
reached the uh peak in their career they
are probably from time to time thinking
that maybe i can do something else i'm
not sure that he will not be playing the
world championship
because it should be motivating and um i
don't know for him once again to show
that he's the best in the world
otherwise why to play the normal
tournaments
and almira we know he team rajab said
maybe magnus is doing other things he's
playing in the world series of poker in
just a week oh really so
i thought that he was hustling some
players yesterday in the park you know
chess hustlers have like these are new
gangsters
the new chess hustlers
so uh well first of all i think we we
know how difficult the situation is for
the players now and this is actually a
historic situation because for the first
time the history of chess the players
are playing the candidates and they
actually don't know if they're playing
like for the first and end the second
place so i really hope that this
situation is going to be clarified very
soon it's a good point this has not
happened before we're going to
candidates usually it's a fight for
first place now there could be something
left said for second place and danya
some of the players with different
mindsets but we heard from teamwork of
he says very strongly that magnus
carlsen will play so do you think that
will impact the way timor looks at his
next game
yeah i mean
i think the silver lining to the fact
that the players don't know whether
magnus is serious is that you get to see
a bunch of different tournament
strategies
we'll talk about fabiano caruana in a
bit but he chose the strategy of taking
maximal risk and kind of assuming
um as cicaro told us in his interview
two days ago that
magnus carlsen was just trolling
somebody like two more might be trying
to hedge his bets despite what he told
us in the interview and he might be
trying to take a little bit of less risk
but now he's got to start fighting for a
second because he's got six points
uh he's not in second place so he has to
play for a win especially because he's
got the white pieces fabiana caron is
struggling this is his chance okay well
we're talking about the matchups let's
bring them on screen for everybody
almira yon napomshi gets the white piece
in his rich report jan can lock up the
term with the draw but rich report he
seems to be down for a fight so what do
you make of this one well i think that
jan has studied almost every opening
preparing for this game uh but for all
the fans of the games the game of
thrones here like i wanted to say that
richard could be like as well a
character
from this series i wanted to say that
what is dead may never die you know but
rises even stronger and harder so i
think that richard is ready to fight
okay fans at home would be very excited
about that as we see yonder palm she
already as chair we'll get back to
nakamura dude in a second but danya
already is a farouza in last place
mathematically eliminated for the fight
for even second he gets the white piece
against a dingley wren who had won three
games in a row but lost that
heartbreaker against him with java well
we like to toss around the phrase
nothing to lose but so far laresa has
had something to lose today and tomorrow
he actually has nothing to lose that is
it this is not going to be a tournament
that will be uh that will occupy a
central place in his memoirs
20 years later and he's been the world
champion for 15 years
this tournament is a wash and maybe
that'll help him maybe that will finally
free him from the shackles that have
prevented him to play from playing the
kind of chess that everybody was
expecting him to play this tournament
he's kept playing for a win his fighting
spirit has been admirable but some of
his mistakes have been
simply uncharacteristic and unfathomable
i am really really hoping that we will
see aliraz's best chess in the last two
rounds of the tournament maybe his youth
will help him avoid the fatigue that has
plagued some of the other participants
well with nothing to lose that makes him
a dangerous dangerous man so dingley
wren will have his work cut out for him
but almira timor java gets the white
pieces against a player five on a car
one who struggled in the second half and
a player that timor himself struggles
against well first of all fabiana had a
very difficult second half of the
tournament but on the other hand i had a
closer look at their games and their
life score
fabiana has never won a game with black
against nimura jabba who is a very tough
and solid opponent so it will be well
how do you say it's a tough road to hoe
for fabiano but and we know that he
needs to take a lot of risks today
well when you risk with the black pieces
that can cause you trouble all the
players have said that much in this
tournament including hikaru nakamura who
gets the white pieces today against
yanchez stuff dude
yes he does and
you know as we expected as we predicted
ikaro got a fair amount of flack on
social media for playing the berlin
against janupamnishi i think completely
unjustifiably so but
today he has to take all of the risk in
the world because hikaru's got the white
pieces he'd shown excellent preparation
this tournament and yachsha stuff duda
what has his bad form consisted of i
think it's consistent largely of bad
calculation we saw that in his last game
against ali raza forza a lot of
uncharacteristic calculation errors
blunders
you know stuff miss on move three or
four of certain variations and we know
that car does not let that fly so hikaru
has to try to display good preparation
he's got to get a complex middle game
and this is his chance to strike and
solidify his bid for second place he
just heard it that he needs to take the
most of his chances and we caught up
with hikaru nakamura in the studio where
he talked about how he might indeed be
fighting for second
fabiano has been playing every game
taking huge risks so it's very clear
that fabiano does not believe for a
second that second place is in play it's
very clearly thinks magnus is full full
of bologna
let's put it that way um and i generally
have the same attitude as well but
it's i still want to have a chance where
maybe there's that back door option
where i can get to second place so yeah
i mean if i'm if i have a chance we'll
we'll see what happens um you know the
situation obviously determines a lot but
realistically i don't think it's there
but it's still something where if
there's a chance you want to have that
that possibility
so you're saying there's a chance for
hikaru nakamura there certainly is a
chance because as we remind everybody of
the standings yana pamshi of course in
the lead for those of you who are just
joining us we'll remind you that yonder
pompey just needs a draw today to clinch
first place but the fight for second is
not over and ikara nakamura sits in a
tie for second place so he would like to
make the most of his chances his draw
against yonder palm she allowed him to
tie dingley wren in second and it's the
time of the show where i have to make my
predictions i'm i've been wrong every
single day but let's start with the
matchup between yonder palm sheet and
rich report fans at home really really
hoping that richard plays something
dangerous play something exciting but i
think that yana pomshi he's going to
make a draw a solid one we could even
see a berlin draw i wouldn't be happy
about that but regardless i'm clicking
on a draw here this game is going to be
peaceful next game takara nakamura
against yanchez of duda i think dania
summed this up very well that against
hikaru nakamura your calculation has to
be as close to perfect as it can get
yeah has not shown precise calculation
and especially in his last game that's
already frugia i'm going with the car
with the white pieces as are most of the
people voting ali raza against stingley
wren this is a dangerous game because
dingley wren he needs to rebound from a
loss already raised a ferruja he's been
playing enterprising chess but going a
little bit too far i think he oversteps
once again so i'm picking the number one
player from china to win this game and
keep a tie with the car nakamura and
last but certainly not least we have the
resurgent team over job up he hadn't won
a class on games in 2019 before this
event five under carwana looked like he
was going to be in a two-player race
with yonda pomshi he has struggled the
second half i am going to go with
neither of them i'm clicking to draw
because i think as almer point out five
minutes never won with the black pieces
against for java and our java he's been
playing very solidly so i'm gonna click
on the draw and for those of you who
also want to make your predictions you
have until move ten we see a virtual
report on screen here but first place
the top guesser gets a cool one thousand
dollars you could see your potential
prize on screen in front of you all the
way down to 10th place with a one-year
diamond membership so until move 10 you
can make your votes but we have rich
report on screen and that is a man that
everyone wants to get into the mindset
of amira will he play
for more than just a draw well actually
richard plays so many interesting lines
in the opening so you were talking about
the berlin defense but i i was looking
at the very rare line in the chigwarin
and they already played once uh
this line i think against each other
with nyani pomona she had white
so
who knows they played french they played
the scandinavian anything is possible
today well the fans at home will be
happy about that they want richard
report to be a loose cannon and yonder
palm shiedanya he's been so stable
throughout the event but somebody who
hasn't been is already is a farouza
they've been on opposite sides of the
spectrum here and that's why john is in
first and all raises and less yeah what
i wanted to point out about yan
and i'm fully expecting one e4 because
my coach used to tell me that
when you think about playing for a draw
you might be inclined to play something
like the london system or one d4 because
that sounds more solid but 184 is a lot
more forcing so there are very drawish
lines against most things that you can
throw at one e4 and the things against
which there aren't drawing lines are
incredibly dubious you're talking about
one e4 g6 or 184 d5 and we can't blame
richard report if he's unwilling to take
a ridiculous amount of risk and
basically risk getting a lost position
out of the opening i mean he'd rather
draw than lose but ali reza ferrugia you
know his problem hasn't been playing too
solidly it's been the opposite problem
and we're seeing here ikar nakamura
against yom tristaf duda once again the
camera pans to the iranian youngster
with a pensive expression on his face
with the producers playing with me every
time i say a name the camera goes to the
other player i think they try to stop
talking young trista
well they can do whatever they like but
there we go yeah see
this is the queue so younches of duda he
is the black pieces he probably is
disappointed in his round 12 result
because he did have a great position
against alireza fruija but elmira hikaru
nakamura has shown excellent preparation
with the white pieces that may be a long
day ahead for jkd perfect i actually had
the question for you you've played many
games
against hikaru i think is he ever
nervous
do you think that he's nervous right now
it's a great question hicaro himself has
said that he used to feel very nervous
that when he played in his only previous
time the candidates he felt the pressure
the weight of expectations now because
he's a successful streaming career he
feels like you know if i don't do so
well in the tournament and of course he
is trying his best he's doing very well
but if that doesn't work out he still
has something to fall back on whereas
other players in the field fabiano
carwana maybe chief amongst them you
know this is their dream this is their
livelihood this is their ambition in
life is to fight for a world chess
championship and we can't forget that in
2018 if one single move had been
different fabiano caruana could have
become champion speaking of champions
judith polgar we we love to see jude
here it's honestly an honor every time
uh judith i don't know she's qualified
to meet the first one i don't know if
she knows
that is former world top 10 the best
female chess player of all time and
somebody who just beat magnus carlsen
yesterday in a blitz game at el rotaro
park so judith i know she can't hear us
because she's in the playing hall and
nobody in the playing all can hear us
but it is really an honor to have her
here making the first move and let's
remind our audience that juju actually
played at the final stages of the world
championship that at the time it was a
tournament as the candidates right now
there were eight players uh competing
for the title in 2005. right and judy
she sort of transcends chess every kind
of psychology book and uh you know all
these studies anthropological studies
are jude and her sisters and you know
her father parents were probably they
have been written about many many times
but what has not been written is the end
of the 2022 fide candidates that story
remains to be told and jan de palmasi
he's hoping that this is the last game
that matters to him he would like to
just make a draw so for yon he did in
fact play e4 i love this you love this
yes he's actually gotten up from the
chair
no but richard is still thinking that's
right
well
i i kind of wonder for richard report
people were very hard on him when he
didn't take the draw against yon and
they felt like he almost handed yon the
tournament victory it wasn't by
agreement it was richard mistaking his
opening preparation upset about it
feeling like he should continue i said
the time every organizer should invite
him and i still stand by that but do you
think he feels a burden because he lost
that game that for the rest of the field
he should fight
well
he certainly feels a lot of pressure but
they think that he's fighting in every
game and uh also like his combative
spirit was shown also during their first
encounter when he declined the draw and
i think that uh you might argue that
certain players do not put up the same
level of the resistance that they did
for example in the first half of the
tournament but this this is certainly
not true in richard's case and we have a
sicilian so we don't have to worry about
another quick berlin draw vision report
he spent some time he plays a sicilian
we'll see what lines he has in store for
yon napalmashi yan himself is a sicilian
player so it could be a live by the
sword die by the sword moment yeah and
let's not forget that report did play
the sicilian once before in this
tournament he played the sveshnikov for
the very first time in his life against
ikaro he could play it for the second
time right now
and
to be completely honest it's not too
hard to make a draw against the
sebastinikov there are maybe two or
three items on the menu that are
virtually guaranteed to lead to
a highly judged position richard looking
up at his opponent
and is he thinking again trying to
decide which line of the sicilian to
play this time yeah he could be i mean
he might just be
those you forgot this crazy thai man
yeah oh yeah
i was thinking if he's going uh for the
same line that uh he chose against
fabiano
yeah but when you repeat a line
oftentimes your opponent they look at
that and they say i found a way to make
a draw let's uh do that one but i'm
looking all across the boards here
because in the bottom left we see
already ferruja with the white piece
against dingley wren he played a four
night scotch and he's saying i don't
want to lose this game that's for sure
so let me play something extremely safe
ferruccio doesn't have to be too
concerned about how the opening is gone
because this is as solid of an opening
as they come and then i'm also looking
of course at nakamura duda that's still
early but the knight retreated back to
f3 in a night or he played it against
ferruja and in the bottom right we know
based on uh amero telling us that karwan
has never beaten rajaba with black he
has taken a pawn on c4 in the catalan
and we'll see if he tries to keep that
pawn because sometimes players when they
need to win a game they take all the
risk in the world and they try to cling
on to that extra pawn even if it's a
positional nightmare
is it a language yeah
cling on is two words but when you put
them together yes stop clinging on those
words
yeah but the catalan i think is one of
those quote unquote new openings which
are on the one hand very solid and
positionally sound but on the other hand
are very good weapons legitimate weapons
uh for playing for a win so i really
like this choice by timur
uh if you know if he wanted
a quick draw then he could have
transposed into a queen's indian uh
queen's game or rather with four knight
c3 or or something as solid as four e3 i
think this signals to us that he wants
to at least get some sort of unbalanced
position and caruana responding with not
the main line which is now bishop e7 and
castles that's what everybody is doing
but taking the punt early right and as
you said instead of a5 we can show a
little bit of analysis here that bishop
to e7 is such a common move because now
the claim is the bishop on d2 is
misplaced and knight could often want to
come there to attack this pawn on c4 so
the bishop is invited here just because
it occupies a square that another piece
should go to but a5 so i have some
experience on the black side of this
line i also played some very bad games
on the black side of this line because
you are able let's say white castles in
this position so black can do the same
but there are positions where after move
like queen to c2 black can try to play
this move b5 so you do successfully keep
this pawn on c4 for the time being after
a4 c6 normally you're unable to play in
this manner because there's a problem
with this rook on a8 but in the current
moment uh you see the evaluation go up
because the bishop can take the bishop
so it's the problem along the a file not
in the diagonal but if after a takes b5
you don't just take back you take this
bishop on d2 this knight now can take on
d2 and this is where problems start to
arise so don't just play b5 and assume
that's going to work out somehow this is
still
been played a couple times it appears
in our database it doesn't look very
good for black but there are positions
where you can play this b5 move to
defend c4 but you need to be careful as
you just so showed in those variations
yeah and and one of the problems of this
line is that not only do you have to
figure out if you're trying to cling to
the pawn
but if you've decided that you don't
want to cling to the pawn the question
is how do you give it away because you
basically have two tempe right white's
gonna play queen c2 and queen takes c4
and one of black's chief problems here
is that french like bishop on c8 now you
don't have to play b5 you can play b6 as
queen c2 is on the board but playing b6
has one of the same problems that b5
does which is that it as you're showing
opens up the long diagonals so there's a
lot of moving parts here and for black
you have to be very very careful not to
fall into an overly passive position
that's i think one of the reasons why
the catalan is so annoying because if
black just develops in a pedestrian
fashion it has bishop d7 knight c6
you're going to get a position where
your control of the center is inferior
and your development is inferior and
that is no fun against someone like
timor java
pedestrian fashion this is the new
terminology of tv
but they truly agree with this analysis
this quantum analysis you might say so
which will give probably some
evaluation
or assessment of the position as a
slightly better
for white
i've played this line a few times as
well with black and
with different results
but i think it
gives it offers some chances so for a
dynamic play
for black certainly fabiano himself has
played this move b6 that dania had
mentioned against daniel duboff and we
know how creative dubov is and fabinho
he drew that game
in the uh rapid chess championship
several weeks ago so b6 you can play
this with a3 that way when this bishop
takes you can take with your knight so
you develop and then this knight comes
and attacks this pawn because if you
take with the queen on c4 that allows
moves like bishop to a6 so the bishop
doesn't just have to fianchetto it can
go all the way out to be very annoying
to the queen
kind of preventing white from castling
so easily and black often wants to make
this move c5 so that's
where the catalan often boils down to is
can black successfully get this move c5
and otherwise you're gonna face pressure
down the c file for pretty much the
entire game yeah and the funny thing is
now that you've moved the bishop away
from c8 after you play c5 um white's
knight jumping to e5 is like me going to
the park y'all retire after magnus has
already left like there's no fun left on
that diagonal just goes rook 87
congratulations you have control you
know you've arrived to the park but it's
it's 7 p.m
um and uh
this is a very modern interesting way of
playing where rather than combating
control of a certain square or set of
squares directly with trying to get the
bishop to be seven you're actually just
moving all of the pieces to other
squares you're taking the party
elsewhere to you know
to avoid the problems
but on the other hand what i wanted also
to point out is that if black will be
able to solve its like opening problems
successfully then this queen on c2 might
as well be a target because there is
there is no perfect square
sometimes if you're on b3 then the
knight comes to c5 on c2 then the rook
comes to the c file uh
it's i would say it's a very interesting
uh opening line and fabiano he castled
and he got up from the board so let's go
back to our four board scene as we leave
timor and five and figure this out and
with
the matchups today we know hikaru
probably should take some chances
against the ancestor of duda and dinglar
with the black pieces well he'll look to
stabilize but i'm wondering
we keep talking about this fight for
second place if fabiano he doesn't want
to take risk with black because he knows
dingley wren and ikaro play each other
in the final round so even if ding and
um
and hikaru are halfway ahead of fabiano
they play each other and they might make
a draw and fabiano can win that last
round to catch up because fabiano he
gets the white pieces in round 14 so if
he is trying to rely on others for
specific results and then rely on
himself to win that 14th and final round
that could allow him to end up in a tie
for a second well you just illustrated
how difficult this situation moves like
are you taking this into account like on
every move that you make
i mean you you can't rely on others but
uh if we look at the game in the bottom
left and all the razor froze against
dingley wren i think you can count on
this game becoming a draw so we saw that
yonder pomschi did the same exact thing
against dingley ren he is quite
predictable when he has the black pieces
in particular he plays very solid lines
he's an e4 e5 player and we got here
through a four night scotch and if this
position looks familiar it's because it
it is very similar to how jan played so
i can start from one the opening isn't
too important because uh this theory now
is very well developed
but white just develops this move
castling is very interesting because it
does allow white to take this pawn to c6
but you get in trouble because black
develops so rapidly so instead of taking
on c6 white just castles to make sure
the king is safe and then we see this
very well known that every single kid in
the united states plays
every single kid who just has started
playing chess they're taught this
opening i wanted to show a very funny
line in this opening i think lately
the move h3 was played at the very high
level instead of queen of three
then black plays rogue b8 and then you
go for queen f3 and here there is a very
tricky move uh h6 of course you could
you can transpose and like obvious lines
after bishop f6 but what if bishop h6
you know if g takes h6 we have uh queen
g3 and then queen b this actually was
considered to be completely unclear by
the computer at some point you know when
i was analyzing it so yeah even here
it's like you know this is only minus
one and black's still in the game so
that's it looks like a blunder right it
just looks like a terrible blunder and
yet because of uh i guess black's
positioning a piece is okay but in this
one h3 wasn't played others went for the
direct queen f3 and i think we all
once we saw how the game was going we
could tell alareza he's just playing to
not lose and it looks like he's going to
succeed on that front because he took
care of his only weakness put his pawn
to b3 then brought his knight to e3 and
now he swaps off his knife the white
square bishop so
they're
still following two different dingly ren
games and that is just how consistent
dingley ren is yeah and i mean
one could
having that information in mind what one
can think well isn't it possible that
eli reza has prepared an improvement
uh and the reason i'd be very skeptical
about that is just the nature of this
position it's so uh devoid of life and
the fact they're obstacle bishops
uh you know
no
crazy computer line could change the
nature of this position and the nature
of this position is that black's
excellent peace activity compensates for
the slight deficiency in the pawn
structure and the deficiency in the pawn
structure is purely cosmetic because
white really can't attack any of the
kingside pawns the c6 pawn is on a light
square yes but it could move to c5 at a
moment's notice and perhaps the most
important thing is that black has
excellent control over the e-files so
this game is going to end in a draw and
the only question is when
well but there is made a very
interesting move bishop g4 i wanted to
explain a few ideas in this position
even though like with the opposite color
bishops you think that it's an easy draw
but if you will not be careful and i
will be able to play bishop before
bishop c3
then a5 a4 it's so it's like it's very
important to play a4 here with uh with
uh
with white
because if i will be able to limit your
pc's activity here then actually
black can even get a little bit better
yeah we certainly have seen games where
that happens where especially if this
king eventually goes to the queen side
there are squares to infiltrate so
that's important but it does seem very
far away i mean amir of course is
talking how white needs to
be on the lookout not just assume that
there's no issues because if you play
by making assumptions that's often how
you lose games that should be unlosable
but at this point i think that it's so
stable for white that it um
seems seems so hard to lose this you
know and then with dingle already having
played this opening twice this exact
position twice um i think he knows that
he's in equal territory so but if i play
just simple move rook e8 here you well
you have to play rook g1 or what do you
want yes because you're saying you
definitely don't want to take on e5 and
you can actually take with the pawn here
because bishop d7 while it does fork the
pieces that once this rook moves and you
take on c6 over here i can just play
rook c8 and temporarily wiped up two
pawns now let's make it one but with the
presence of opposite colored bishops
with this pawn on a2 under attack you
can move your pawn to a2 and once black
plays bishop c5 you're never making
progress it's a very nasty situation and
actually whenever i talked about white
getting in trouble if you want to get in
trouble this is the way to do it yeah
because black is going to start pushing
f5 e4 and you're totally paralyzed here
white has to navigate this very
carefully already to
preserve the equality so rugby 8 is one
option
another option that i like here for
black is rook uh rook before
and the point is not to hope that aliera
has a blunders his bishop i mean this is
an hyperbola game after all and he
doesn't even blunder them in hyper
bullet but after bishop f3
you do something that might seem weird
at the outset you seed control of the e
file you trade on e1 but then you go
rook d4
and the point is that you're threatening
to infiltrate to d2 rookie 2 would be a
great move with the small problem that a
blunders checkmate so i don't really see
an alternative there
other than rook d1 and then vlad grabs
the rokin
you know the opponents exchange glances
and sign the piece of chords but that's
a nice line because
black does have a worse pawn structure
on both sides of the board so if you can
force that equality that's something
that dingley ring will look for so rook
b4 is a good move and let's say this
bishop doesn't leave and you play h3 you
could still play this idea with rook to
d4 now the difference
but you know it's would seem but playing
h3 is no more background check made but
let's not forget the bishop on d6 stares
at the h2 square so if we do the same
exact thing that dania had just
mentioned with rook to d4 you still
can't play rookie too you want to keep
the rooks on the board so you can play
for a slight advantage but rookie two
walks right into the same checkmate
because the bishop covers the square so
it does it just feels like a position
where
inevitably black is gonna be able to
trade off the rooks and then it's a
result that won't take too long to
be signed into the tournament standings
yeah i think that there's a 95 to 99
certainty about how this game is going
bishop g4 does seem like a quote-unquote
improvement or quote-unquote novelty but
you know that everything here is within
the confines of a dead draw so i think
ding with two hours on this clock is
going to have no trouble at all
uh figuring out the path to
equality but a wholly different kind of
game
is is unfolding in nepo against rapport
i think much to the joy and pleasure and
cheers
of chess fans across the world be they
report or nepo fans yeah and report
we've been talking about this he's the
type player who doesn't want to just
give the tournament to somebody he wants
to make them earn it and he likely does
it for the sake of the other players in
the competition and as we see in the top
left we'll bring it on screen for you
here and analyze it a bit that we have a
sicilian and it's a position where white
has committed the king over here on the
queen side we'll analyze how we got here
just to show you the opening moves
because we did see
knight c6 on move two and then
yeah the rouser exactly with d4 knight
f6
we got d6
bishop g5 now these types of positions
can get so sharp after e6 queen d2
black just pushed the a pawn as is
typical of many sicilians and what's
generally important is that in a
situation like this i think a lot of
people are tempted to rush to move like
f4 because they feel like they need to
attack but if you play this move f4
you're kind of giving black something in
return because in the game the pawn is
on f3 making sure the e4 pawn is safe
and sound when you play f4 now you have
to be word is b5 and b4 coming white
objectively is doing just fine but it
just changes the dynamic of the game and
i believe that yondu pomshi if this were
round one of some other tournament he'd
like let's do this you know let's fight
but in round 13 of this feat of
candidates when all he needs to draw
there's no reason to they overextend
your pawn structure and give black a
target well especially after f4 very
often in this line you would get a very
unbalanced position after b5 bishop f6 g
takes f6 you are going for this type of
position with
black in order to create uh
all chaos on the board that's right
because there's this position it's not
like white can force anything there's no
way to just make a quick draw no this
would be a long game and a game where
black has a bishop pair white has the
better pawn structure and a bit more
development so yonder palm shield he
came in today saying none of that let's
after knight c6 bishop fix let's just
play f3 let's just be calm and f3 is a
flexible move because oftentimes white
plays g4 and expands on the king set
anyway daniel
yeah and uh
you can talk about playing more solidly
even if the position is tactical right
the position is certainly tactical there
will be opposite side castling or black
will keep this king in the center for
the time being but black
is probably not going to castle queen
side which by the way does happen in the
f4 variation believe it or not but in
the f3 line not as much
uh but it you know it's clear that jan
is trying to play a solid line a line
that he's looked at before
and white's going to keep improving with
king b1 and at some point white's going
to set his kingside pawns in motion h4
g4 black is going to do the same b7 and
b5 and and b4 so you're going to get
opposite side attacking
but there's also a lot going on in the
center so it's a very very interesting
position
i think that it's it's fair to say that
yan part of yan is disappointed that
report didn't play the berlin
because
i think it's also fair to assume that
jan is at least a little bit nervous
it's like one of those situations where
you're playing billiards
and you've hit seven balls into the
pocket your opponent's at zero but
there's always that black ball right
there's always that chance that jan
loses two games and then hikara wins two
games and then it was the tie breaker so
jan is aware of that possibility
and he certainly wants this game to end
as quickly as possible he wants to make
the straw and pop that champagne bottle
that's gathering dust in his freezer but
he is not allowed to offer a draw that
is until after
move 40. black's 40th move can be
accompanied by a drawfur but jan can't
just say richard my buddy my pal let's
just call it a day and make a draw
now
yeah great question by virgil 85. so
thank you for asking that it's good uh
clarity for everybody who's wondering
the very same thing so uh this is
interesting so right now let's let's
talk about options for black
yes that's what i wanted to tell you
that especially for our audience that
after
a very simple move bishop b7 it might
seem that you could take bishop f6 and
for example after bishop f6 take the
pawn on d6 but this position is actually
much better for black
that's right that's a very important
important element uh to understand in
this position and for two reasons you
could actually trade queens and still be
better just piping upon down but look at
this queen a5 comes in bishop takes c3
is a threat rook to d8 is about to
happen because the bishop defends that
square so this is a very good example
thank you elmira for mentioning this
that uh you may think i win a pawn i'm
really happy but your position falls
apart immediately
yeah very instructive line and
you know this is why the rouser
is well it's often underestimated but
it's a
very
very intricate opening a lot of ideas
for both sides that you have to be
fluent in you know if you don't want
your position to fall apart again with
either color there's equivalent ideas
that black has to
be fully
fully aware of yeah such as
you know when you play h6 when do you
push her and sometimes black can even
play h5
in response to white playing g4 or even
h4
so there's a lot of levers and pulleys
that
uh that really dictate
this position give it a lot of life and
you mentioned levers and pulleys i'm
gonna mention a hook this move h6 the
reason you need to be so careful about
this is because h6 let's say i just
retreat my bishop and black does the
very standing bishop e7 white plays king
to b1 and you castle not only can i
already consider sacrificing my bishop
for your pawn i won't do that but the
pawn h6
is on a square that is more approachable
to white's pawn so you use this pawn as
a hook to blast open the king side so i
can start with g4 or i can start with h4
but the point is that i am let's say
play b5 i'm going to play this move g4
and now g5 comes with a really
devastating threat i'm going to make
just a random move that looks useful but
after g5 either you move your knight
away and i just take this pawn on h6
that's a huge problem or you take me
which is even worse because after i take
back now the h file is open so you're
opening a file for white's pieces and
that will cause devastation
yeah you fit an iceberg here and the
ship is sinking and queen h2 is coming
it's kind of like the equivalent of
white playing a3 and then black can kind
of do the same thing and play a5 and b4
so you can trace a lot of parallels
in both sides
uh respective respective attacks that's
that's yeah that's really good point
because with kings going to opposite
sides you don't typically want to push
your pawns
you want to create left for your king so
you get background checkmated but if
there's a pawn storm happening you don't
want your pawns to be in contact with
another pawn
well and especially in this line after
f3 i think that black would uh eagerly
go for the
uh breakthrough in the center and play
d5 i think if you play h6 then you
should always uh try and play d5 for
sure because you just want to
expand you open up your bishop on its
starting diagonal so that does feel good
and then we turn into a french type of
position where white plays e5 you move
your knight back and then white plays f4
and says this bishop isn't on c8 but
it's still a bad bishop because this
knight will end up on d4 knight e2
knight to d4 often and it's not like
black's position is bad of course not
it's much worse when your bishop is on
c8 but with the bishop one c6 it's still
kind of a big pawn and white has nothing
to worry about with the castle king as
mentioned a knight come at d4 to
blockade the pawn and maybe an eventual
attack if you're feeling eager
dana what do you think about this
structure if i play bishop c5 is it a
little bit better for white or
yeah i've never liked this from from the
black side i'm i'm sort of old school in
the sense that i don't like giving up
control of the d4 square yeah that
maneuver is really annoying but a lot of
french players they they swear by
black's queen side attack and they just
ignore the d4 square you know rugby 8
queen b6 french players are used to just
being worse right yeah right
people play the french defense not
almiros kripchenko and those who play
for the french federation right
let's see let's let's be very clear
about who we're referring to how about
french players who play the french
that's the worst it's a it's a very
important um
thing to understand that you used to be
worse you know like sometimes when you
only play the sicilian you get a french
type deposition and you think oh my god
what is this horror but actually you're
just slightly worse
and
well you might as well win in the
endgame
sure and that's a really important point
about people's styles because some
people can be passive and worse and
they're totally okay with it they they
say you're create a threat i stopped
your threat i don't have to go for
checkmate myself i'm okay with stopping
your plans and then later in the game i
will try to take over other people say
no i don't want to be without a plan i
need to be ambitious i need to have
tactical possibilities so that stylistic
choice is important i think uh of all
players richard report
we know he's creative but he also
doesn't mind having
positions that are quite neutral that
allow him to play for something later in
the game so he's all top players are
universal but i feel like richard he's
known for his flair
but we know that in the games he's
playing this tournament he doesn't mind
trading off queens early and then trying
to outplay his opponent what type of
player are you am i a player who doesn't
play so i'm retired
you're a noted opening expert i have two
things to say yeah the first is the fact
that report has played h6 and i think a
lot of players are
that their instinct is to play bishop h4
to keep the pin
but i mentioned all of the you know sort
of vocabulary of the rouser that you
have to be aware of one of them is the
danger of the bishop on h4 it's
undefended and black has this very
well-known tactic that occurs across
many types of sicilians knight f6 takes
b4 simultaneously hitting the queen on
d2 and the complications work out for
black white can keep material equality
but not with this line if you take the
knight black takes the bishop if you
move the bishop on d8 the knight can
take the bishop on f1 now you can play
knight take c4 and knight takes d6 check
but we've already established that
taking the d6 pawn is not as big of a
deal as it might seem black can just
play queen e7 or even rook d8 and
you know at the very least black is not
worse and has solved all of his opening
problems and this is a type of position
where if you saw vladimir kramnik who
just played yesterday in the rapid chess
championship you gave him the black side
this you're like he's going to outplay
me you might as well resign white
seriously and black is a bit better you
have great flexibility of pawn structure
on the king side and with the f3 g2
setup if i can even push through the g4
i have an easier nut to crack over on
the king side whereas black's queen side
here is very stable box rooks are
already connected so the four on three
towards the king side in the center
that's where black can say that he is
better so yeah you don't want any part
of this and
after h6 i'm sure we'll see the bishop
retreat but as we go to the four board
setup ooh duda he's the black piece
against speaking of knight takes c4 yeah
speaking of knight 64 and the d6 pawn
that's a different story that's a very
very different story and well they're an
endgame by the way with dingley wren and
perugia but as we look at this game here
it may seem that knight takes e4 is
possible but after knight takes e4
um the knight on h4 is loose so after
knight takes e4 bishop takes h4 over
here this would not be good because
knight takes d6 comes with check but
daniel said taking pawn on d6 that's
such a big deal this is why we don't
just listen to something that someone
says and assume it applies to every
position you need to calculate this
would obviously be terrible for black as
your king remains in the center you're
going to lose your b7 pawn your position
falls apart now there is something here
because after knight takes e4 we
understand that bishop takes h4 will
drop the d6 pawn but can't black plays
with d5 which is really interesting as
both knights are now under attack
a very interesting that's not an easy
move to see because your your brain
automatically tells you that you have to
take on h4 this is actually quite a
pretty intermezzo
and how does white
save the pawn i guess white should play
g3
the point being if black if you play
knight f3 instead then i take on e4 with
tempo and i simultaneously attack your
knight on f3
the good thing about playing g3 is that
if you play d take c4 i take on e6 and i
can triple your pawns and it gets even
worse if you take back on e6 because of
the check on h5 so you would have to try
to trade your queens there but even the
end game doesn't seem too fun the g6
square can be used as an outpost for
white tonight first of all you'll play
queen e2 so we filled the e file but no
in all seriousness this is i mean
even if the peter says you're okay no
human player would ever accept this but
this is also possible in the other line
if you play knight f3 it takes c4 bishop
v6 is also possible there so you can get
the same but there are completely takes
f3 no one structure yeah dania was happy
to start gobbling
pieces over here so uh bishop bishop d5
yes i have g2 and then gh1 and g3 h i
zero g is such an awkward move because
you know you even look at bishop takes
h4 i think you have to take it but
something else that i was just
considering is like can i make this move
here queen h5 because you certainly
can't take this 94 as after bishop takes
e6 uh there's darn chess.com bugs not
letting me take
danny you can't take because the pawn is
pinned and now you're
threatened to be checkmated and if you
take this knight on h4 instead when
white castles queen side this looks like
a lot of fun i don't know who's having
more fun but with all sorts of threats
across the board
it's like a very
rich position
and
i mean maybe a car wanted something like
this yeah i think this is exactly what
he wants and i
it might even be possible that hikaru
and looking at the time he was remaining
on his clock he probably didn't look at
this position for too long just
concluded that it's very complex and
let's not forget that duda you know when
you make a bunch of calculation mistakes
in a tournament it starts getting to and
you start
you know you start putting less faith
into your ability to evaluate
complicated positions so judah is
definitely aware of knight take c4 and
t5 but because he's made all these
calculation mistakes he might be less
inclined to go for a position where he
doesn't know what the evaluation is
because those types of positions
obviously engender more calculation
mistakes and duda might want to prefer
something simpler but if you don't take
on e4 then you allow the possibility of
white's knight from h4 jumping to f5 and
you might say well that's not a big deal
at all i can take that knight but then
you give up complete control over the
lights the computer usually says these
positions are equal i personally have
never as a knight or player i've never
liked them with uh for black and i'm
guessing one part is this hook again g4
g5 if white is going to castle queenside
can be very useful to break it open and
the control the default scroll mirror
that's never fun for black
well i also wanted to point out that
from the psychological uh perspective
this is also very important you are
calculating 94 and you you
you will probably do this probably going
to spend like
uh well
quite serious amount of time on this but
then he decides not to go for this
variation then we'll get a slightly
worse position and he will be well
behind on the clock
that's a really good point because
that's the worst possible outcome you
spend a lot of time and then you make
this move and you're worse over the
board and you feel uncomfortable and you
burn so much necessary cost fallacy
applied to chess yeah
and i guess amira you know as we're
talking it's not good to be down the
clock but to dania's point hikaru
nakamura has been very well prepared in
this tournament so knight takes e4 this
feels like the move that you have to be
considering and calculating but it's not
like these positions are clear we see
that d5 is a very reasonable move the
evaluation bar is just at zeros so of
course it's completely even but then you
have to worry about this g3 move that
donny mentioned queen h5 to my eyes
looks very sharp and i'm guessing that
dude is thinking about this and he's
like okay i kind of trust hikaru because
he wouldn't play this for no reason but
i still need to calculate for myself
but it does feel like it's a position
where you know it's so
tactical
so many chances to unleash a vicious
attack that he might not want this and
he'll eventually back down and just
castle well and everyone saw the game
between fabiano caruana against
yanipongashi it was a petrov i agree but
we had this knight on h4 bishop b7 and
then the best move in the position was
to play g3 and allow
you know this terrible pawn structure
and white has a clear edge after this
line yeah you can learn from your fellow
competitors and g3 as possible i just
it seems hard for me to believe that he
would accept this type of position it's
very much up a car nakamura's alley due
to he himself is a great tactician but
the way he's thinking here
we talked about you know body language
and saying we can't read too much into
it often but just the fact that he spent
already seven and a half plus minutes in
this move it's only move 11 and the
position is only going to get more
difficult to solve
yeah i mean to me there are essentially
two candidate moves castle's a knight
takes c4 so you're spending longer than
three minutes it's quite obvious that
you're spending most of your time on
knight takes e4 and
you can see here that you know it's a
skill to force your opponent to make
difficult decisions there's nothing that
fatigues you
and frustrates you more during a chess
game than a situation in which you have
two candidate moves both of them have
their pluses and minuses and you just
have no clue which one you should choose
you know that the computer probably
evaluates them equally but whichever one
you choose you feel like you're going to
regret not choosing the other one and
one more thing to mention is that after
castle there's also knight g6 that you
have to consider right because this pawn
on f7 is overloaded to if you take this
way your bishop on e6 is lost so uh it's
a moment where yon just off he knows he
you know wants to do something but he
probably feels frozen and then you want
to play the best move you always want to
be objective and then as you've been
saying that you second guess yourself
because your previous days and you
question your form so he needs to just
pretend like this is round one he needs
to calculate because i could see this
getting out of hand
quickly if he continues to spend time
and then enter a position with murky
waters
well and if you play a simple move like
we there are a few move like candidates
can do this move so let's say you play
rook c8 then you can simply take on this
six and then play
knight g6 here and no more castling for
black so you have to react
it's not that you can allow yourself to
make a move like rook c8 yeah you can't
pass and of course the you know eval bar
says oh it's always slightly better for
white but no human really wants to be in
a position the rook is doing nothing the
king can't castle so with the
understanding that knight g6 is coming
and even if black does castle i was
mentioning that knight of f oh instead
of rook c excuse me uh castling is
possible knight g6 is also available
because you can take on b3 and then you
have to not calculate but sort of uh
visualize this position and see is d5
solving all my problems the answer
apparently is yes but you know we have
the benefit of the engine off the side
of the screen whereas the players they
don't know with a hundred percent
certainty uh but though if you get d5
and you're also often very happy as a
neighbor player well you have the
benefit i don't see anything
yeah well by the way jing i think is
going to play for a win ding is going to
play for a win all right let's go look
at that yeah that that
game has gone haywire
oh my goodness wait how many is that the
same game that we started with black is
down a pawn though okay yeah so black
has given up on ding's given a pawn but
it's kind of what we were talking about
before in that position where the rook
was in the second rank white could be up
a pawn but can't make progress with it
dingley wren it almost looks like he's
up a pawn well he's going to bring his
king
to the center king of six king g5 he can
play c5 d4
this is a very dangerous position of
course computer assesses it as
equal
but
only black can play here he can also
play f4 immediately
and the problem
that white faces if he does that
is that the thread is f3 i mean you
don't want to allow that and you don't
really want to play f3 yourself because
then you have a protected passport and
you don't want to take on f4 because
then your h2 pawn becomes incredible not
even here i thought in the previous move
same thing the h2 pawn becomes really
weak black has
you know a clear post for the rook
how did this happen
um let's go back in time to figure that
out so we left off around rookie f5
bishop g4 h5 okay so this move gives up
a pawn because of exactly what happened
in the game yeah i saw that but i
thought earlier reza would never i
thought others would play bishop f3 so
it was a very astute psychological ploy
from ding to to give alireza this
temptation to unbalance the position
because you know holy reza wants to win
a game another game so
he certainly doesn't bishop f3 i guess
h4 could have been the reply and just
trying to take up some space yeah king
side but yeah this
just looks really nice for black even
though white is the one up a pawn so as
we see bishop e2 hasn't played f4 is not
yet uh dingley ren's choice but f4 does
look very good and
all right on the flip side though white
is up a pawn so if white
can
withstand the pressure that's about to
be built
that's an outside past pawn that can be
annoying to deal with uh maybe not even
just for promoting purposes but as a
decoy just making sure that black's
pieces are keeping an eye on the h-pawn
while white goes to the other side of
the board
however it's uh it's not so difficult to
stop it especially with the opposite
color bishops and the rooks on the board
yes it's very true so it's a long long
long story
for that pawn to be relevant uh and as
the f4 very natural move uh that can be
played it just feels like this pawn
could be in trouble sooner rather than
later so
let's remind everybody about who dingley
ren is the number one player from china
it took some good fortune but dingley
ren arrives at the candidates with some
very legitimate reasons to think he can
secure a bid to challenge for the world
title for the very first time
a visa issue originally kept ding out of
the last opportunity to qualify but when
a spot opened ding was next man up based
upon his hot streak of late
the timing couldn't be better for ding
an entertaining and unpredictable player
ding enters the candidates rated higher
than any player in the field the chat
went nuts they love their man dingley
ren we said this is an engine move
humans don't find it and he found king
of one i am absolutely stunned once
again this is such a difficult move
the strongest player in china's history
ding is the only player from that
country to earn a 2800 rating
launched by an undefeated streak across
100 straight classical games ding has
sat amongst the world's top 5 for the
past 5 years
once out of the tournament completely
ding now aims to bring china into a
world chess championship match for the
first time in his native land's history
much has been said about dingley wren's
absence from over-the-board play during
the pandemic he got off to a slow start
here in the 2022 feeder cans he lost in
the first round but elmer we've seen a
new dingley run in the second half he
won three games in a row before
what might be the worst game in canada's
history potentially against team over
dravoff
well we've seen a very inspired zinc
clearing we've seen also very tired in
lyrang at the beginning of the
tournament i think this is just the
way the tournament goes so he still has
his chances he has a shot at the second
place and um
well he's definitely doing everything
you know in this tournament what is what
is well everything that is possible and
dania we we're just talking about this
end game here it definitely seems to fit
dingly wren style how he's been playing
throughout this event he won an end game
against yanchustav duda that was a very
long game uh the game against richard
report ended up in an end game where he
understood that he could give up in
exchange for an outside pass pawn and
then against five on a carwana it also
happened to be an end game so it feels
like dingley wren feels very much at
home in these long grinded out battles
yeah and
the other thing we should remember is
that elireza was not expecting a
combative end game when he played the
four night scotch he was expecting let's
be real it was expecting a risk-free
position where he would
you know make a few token attempts to
play for a win and then take the draw i
i think that's what it is and all of a
sudden you have an unbalanced position
in which you actually you know you have
to use your brain i still think the
likeliest result by far is a draw i
think it's very hard for either side to
make progress
you're going to get a fortress one way
or another
resume play f4 here and prevent further
progress of black's king
but nonetheless i think ding is doing
everything he can within the framework
of the opening line that alireza chose
and uh he's got the most chances that he
could possibly dream of to actually win
this game right
you were saying that every kid in
america knows this line and actually
consider this is something like not to
do at home because how important is to
have at least a little bit of counter
play in your position here there is none
so uh i think that
even though i completely agree with
dania uh there are enough of defensive
resources here for white uh but it will
be a very long game for earlier
yeah i think that it's probably a bit of
a surprise in fact that you're up a pawn
but you're the one defending that seems
like it shouldn't be the case but
otherwise that he's trying to figure out
how to properly respond to king of six
and this king march but somebody who is
not just going to make a quick draw did
not come to split the half point today
is fabiano caruana we see in the bottom
right he has up 20 minutes on the clock
and he's currently down two pawns with a
third pawn on the table so uh wow a
solid opening by team over java girl has
become anything but saw this is
immensely complicated so fabiano carwana
is it a bluff is it some real
preparation that he you know has looked
at 25 moves deep because he has bluffed
in this tournament against jana pomeshi
in game two he plays his knight g4 move
which he himself said it's not very good
if you know what to do and right now
we're wiped up two pawns but down all
sorts of development this is a critical
moment
yeah i mean i think it's very very
obvious that fabio is playing for a win
and to play for a win with two more
against
you know
something like the catalan you need
something extraordinary and fabi has
produced
something extraordinary we're being told
that this is not technically a new
position there have been two
relatively unknown games still in the
database i wonder if i took on b6 in
either of them and i think that is the
question that we should answer first
what happens if white accepts that third
pawn because it might seem to some
people that a queen trade is inevitable
in that case and then
fabby's entire concept totally collapses
but in fact uh a queen trade is not
inevitable if white takes on b6 but i
think you might want to explore
something earlier in the game i just
want to show how we got here okay
because people were like wait you guys
are talking about this solid approach
how did you use the first one how did
the first one was
he lost four of them so b6 was played
bishop takes b4 there's number one
bishop a6 throwing intermezzo hitting
the queen and but here is number one the
queen simply retreats
that's the first pawn c5 2 is the second
pawn and after knight c6 here comes
option number three so queen takes b6
has not been played in the predecessors
i doubt it was preparation in those
games but queen d2 retreating saying i'm
just going to run away from the queen
side because after queen takes b6 this
queen can move over to say c8 and
immediately we see a threat if you
castle not only is your e2 pawn hanging
but rook b8 traps the queen can't go to
a5 because the knight can't go to a7
because the knight is well and all the
other squares are controlled by black's
rook and queen
that's
a pretty incredible concept so you'd
have to go queen b3 instead of castling
but that queen's very vulnerable and
black could play e5 here
trying to push the knight off of f3 in
order to pave the way for knight d4 and
the
very important thing to point out is
that just because white castles doesn't
mean he's out of the woods at all so
let's say white castle's here he might
say well the king is safe what else is
there to talk about a lot e4 knight
moves somewhere and then knight g5 or
knight d2 knight d4
e2 is hanging with check c2 is
accessible to the knight
c5 is hanging and white's pieces are
passive so this is completely contrary
to her job of style i am fully expecting
him to decline the pawn
so you might ask well what's he thinking
about then but there are multiple ways
to decline the pawn you go queen d2 you
could go queen h4
and uh i think those are actually the
main canada moves to which rajab is
investing his time amira i think that
top players they tend not to like having
three pawns extra if it means that
they're not castling anytime soon
well i agree with this completely and
once again fabi goes for a ver for a
very rare line
uh i'm thinking about his game in the
previous candidates where this strategy
backfired he sacrificed a few pounds
against the dingleran actually and he
lost with black but it was
such an interesting and tense battle you
know like dink could never castle by the
way in that game but finally he
navigated through the
uh well through this game and managed to
beat fabi uh
here i think the main strategy is to um
push at a more job of uh
to like
at every position he needs to calculate
another very concrete line so he wants
him to be well in a time travel very
soon
and eventually make a mistake
because in this game uh
every mistake would be fatal yes one
mistake could end the game on the spot
and actually gary casparov he did an
interview with the st louis chess club
that i watch and he was talking about
how interesting the opening preparation
has been and i think that fabiana
carwana despite some of his struggles in
the second half he's had the most
creative opening repertoire uh where he
put his knight on g7 against dingley
wren he lost that game but you don't see
that very often and just the way he
plays against jonda palm she brings his
knight out to g4 he's played adventurous
chess and this game is just another one
of those games in that style and
generally it really is a difficult
choice because he may be looking at this
queen takes b6 and just dropping the
queen back and saying i have three
saliva might be trickling from his mouth
that is a lot of three extra pawns so
even if you win my night for another
pawn then i'll have four pawns for the
night and just to show uh sample bring
up the analysis board because um maybe
there is a variation where after queen
c8 the queen has to go back as we're
saying so it doesn't get trapped with
rook to b8 and after e5 like maybe
there's a situation where i if i give up
my knight on f3 it's not actually easy
to figure out a way to do so but if i
pretend the e2 pawn isn't hanging for a
second and you take here and i just
simply take back with my knight or even
actually with the queen
maybe this is possible yeah because you
can't really move the knight
white has four pawns for a piece
not easy to evaluate this position
because sure black can defend the night
and the game goes on
but that material imbalance four pawns
is worth more points than a minor piece
but with so many pieces on the board
those minor pieces can team up together
very nicely so maybe timor is just
trying to figure out a future like this
where instead of running back he'll just
grab all the pawns he can get and then
give something back in return and how
many variations he and positions he has
to assess
between
well he's
thought now i think it will take him
another 20 minutes
uh what do you think he is he going to
play quincy two here
and try to trade queens
i i think he might be attracted by queen
h4
because
because in a opening preparation that
has been very interesting i i think
because um the queen is very safe here
and it's not safe anywhere on the queen
side and after bc
he might want to go knight c3
and then
castle essentially by hooker by crook
regardless of what black does knight d4
castles rugby a castles
and
he waited for me to say that and then he
dropped the queen back to dc but at
least i was right in that he was just i
think deciding between those two
candidate moves and just to prove you
wrong just just to prove me wrong i just
didn't have played it before i said that
just to conclude the point is five it
does take on c5 we just see his hand
reaching get back to your charity timor
castling isn't going to be always easy
with the e2 pawn being loose and it
feels almost like a benko gambit where
black gives up a pawn on the queen side
and then starts just causing problems
for white down these files so if you
trade on d8 and i just take back with my
rook here i could put maybe this rook on
b8 and this knight can come to b4 or
maybe to d4 so we acknowledge that white
is up a pawn and with
precise pinpoint precision
completely accurate play white can claim
an advantage it's really difficult to be
perfectly accurate in these types of
positions where it's dynamic play for
black and white first warding off the
threats and then trying to come up with
more active ideas of zone
i'm a skeptic though generally i'm very
amenable to these types of ideas and i
think this would be great in a rapid
game but first of all java doesn't have
to take on d8 yet you can castle
and then you might say well black can
actually restore material equality take
on d2 take on e2 but that's the problem
with sacrificing so many puns is like it
takes a while to take all of them back
and in doing so you're giving your
opponent a lot of tempe so as you're
pointing out i think it wouldn't be in
the spirit of the position trade queen
queen b6 would be likely but after
something like knight c3 white can push
that b-pawn up to b3 whenever he wants
and i just don't really see black having
quite enough for the pawn here i just
don't see it yeah i mean i'm not a bank
of gaming player myself it just feels
like that type of position where uh
you're
claiming that you have sufficient
compensation for the pawn even though
the engine always fights against you to
the very end they're like nope you're
it's plus one for what's point five yeah
at least right plus one plus point five
you're never getting full equality but
fabiano he did this for a reason he must
believe in the position and the depth
that these super grand masters with
their super computers look at these
positions is just way more than us
analyzing uh with the engine on here and
i think that's something that sometimes
fans don't recognize is they say well
this opening is bad why why did you use
this yeah i knew it was pointless why
would he give away a pawn and it'd be
worse for him but just the i mean they
have super computers that help them out
and they have a different evaluation
than the ones that we have and the
surprise factor can really
play a big role in these games so team
over java as he
fiddles with that pawn i think it's a
pawn could be a more valuable piece but
he's usually filling the pawn as many
chess players do
we're going to look at wow the hikaru
nakamura game because
oh my goodness duda in the top right
over here he let the knight into g6
and put his rook on g8 so
hikaru seems confused
i'm confused amira are you surprised
that dude allowed this
well is he going for 97 queen e7 and
then g5 at some point
that would make a lot of sense that this
knight moves out the way
this is a very peculiar line i must
admit knight e5 bishop b6 f6 and
knight
because that wasn't the move that we
were looking at at all
no but maybe he wanted this position
right he forced it
i don't think it's that as much as he
was worried about the position after
night off five because the point of 985
i think is that it's primarily aimed
against knight f5 and if white had
played knight five here just really
quickly bishop f5 knight v3 and then
black pushes the pawn on d5 so net a5 is
a prophylactic measure against d5 he
disliked that position so much
that he's willing to allow the position
that's on the board which i'm going to
be very clear i don't like for black one
bit and i feel like white has in store
the move f2 f4 it's going to blast open
the center i don't see where the black
king is going to go in the long run
because if lex king ends up on f7 he
doesn't have easy access to the king
side you're gonna have to move the rook
one more time to f8 to complete the
castling by hand and you might simply
not have time for that if white's
already rearing to go therefore this is
zika types opposite hikaru's type of
position
i wouldn't overstate it you know i think
black is okay but judo will have to be
very precise uh in this early middle
game
and
a lot of this can come down to some kind
of d5 break at some point you can't do
that easily with knight on g6 because
don't forget the pieces move backwards
and knight c4
is going to be a nuisance but if white
starts with queen d3 let's note that his
bishop can't move anywhere so we
shouldn't rush to capture it we can
capture the next move maybe queen to d3
black might play b5 or rook c8 to get
this knight to c4 but i'm going to start
putting pieces on the d-file and perhaps
this king is going to have to take on e7
just to keep d6 protected but then it's
going to be a wild one but on the other
hand uh it's a very interesting
positional decision allowing bishop b6
fp66 also brings this very important
bond to the center and
well you no longer have the control over
the d5 square
that's right and as we're saying black
might also try to play d5 but very
important amira saying the knight
doesn't get the d5 square so you feel
better about that
elmira whose style do you think this
position better suits
uh do this yeah okay
tanya you agree
i'm gonna have to go with ikaro
i'm gonna have to just because i don't
know just to be contrarian yeah we all
we have to have three different opinions
otherwise it's not interesting wow no i
mean so almer let's unpack that a little
bit so what is it about this position
that you think suits due to style so
well
um first of all i think that even though
that today has been quite solid uh
during this tournament i think that
there are
no concrete targets in this position for
black only well i can think about the
pawn on d6 but other than that
then there is
no longer a visible attack so you will
have to switch well hikaru would have to
switch and into something very
positional as i've said queen g3 maybe a
long castle and maneuver his pieces uh
well into better squares especially the
knight on c3
yeah well
this is an
excellent point i mean you're right
there are no concrete targets and for
duda he actually can play some concrete
ideas in response so the evaluation bar
like zakaru hikaru i'm not sure if he
likes his position he seems a little
stressed in the beginning
his car definitely likes oh i hope he
does we all hope that everyone likes
themselves but hikaru's gonna have us to
figure this one out and we'll leave him
to figure it out because it is time for
our first break of the day here in the
round 13 of the feed a candidates but
while this event is coming to its
conclusion in just a few days i want to
remind everyone of an event on thursday
july 7th the i am not a gm speeches
championship finals are set the razor
sharp feeder master james kane the third
takes on the always tricky ever
resourceful international master heir
rosen in what will undoubtedly be a
thriller so tune in on thursday july 7th
at 10 30 in pacific right here on
chess.com
so as we see the players
they are
thinking hard trying to figure out
what's to do in their positions we are
going to head on over to break so please
don't go anywhere as you see the spanish
commentators we will be right back for
more from round 13 of the 2022 fide
candidates
chess kid is fun
chess is great for the brain but it's
also fun to play and chess kid makes it
easy to have fun whether your child is a
total beginner or a prodigy they can hop
on and find a well-matched opponent from
around the world at any time chess kid
is the safe parent approved way for your
child to play chess online
chess kid is educational to kids it
feels just like playing but chess is a
great way to learn patience strategy and
critical thinking
chess kid features a comprehensive
training program that guides kids to
level up on their way to mastery this
curriculum is designed to work with
common core standards and global
educational guidelines there are more
than 50 000 chess puzzles and a whole
library of entertaining videos that
teach strategies tactics openings and
end games specifically for kids
chess kid is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds chess kit helps you organize
your students and monitor their progress
each child receives a weekly report card
that shows how many lessons puzzles and
games were completed you can also
organize kids into clubs and send them
messages
chess kit is the online home of
scholastic chess for thousands of kids
parents schools and coaches signing up
is free and easy so what are you waiting
for
[Music]
is back at the candidates affecting his
second straight bid to challenge for the
world chess championship
one of the more experienced players nepo
brings to madrid an aggressive style
that is both challenging to face and
entertaining to watch
two years ago nepo made the most of his
debut in the candidates with a round to
spare he won the event in convincing
fashion
that's all he needed yon napomashi is
the 2021 world chess championship
challenger
that victory led nepo to a world
championship match with carlson and also
secured his return to the candidates in
madrid this year
despite being one of only two players in
the field to have won the candidates the
expectations for nepo were not
particularly high this time around
however his confidence from having won
here before in addition to his years of
competitive experience may offer him a
shot to turn some heads
if nepo should pull a major upset and
face magnus carlson again the two know
each other well
nepo has competed against carlson for
decades ever since the two prodigies
were 12 years old
so we're here today at the candidates
we're in the media room with dingleren's
notoriously large chair and farm master
mike is having a battle of his own to
become food master mike we're gonna see
how he's getting on
lydia don't make me anymore
this is like a pizza simul please be
done
at least get some water or something
it's terrible here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a
[Music]
[Music]
oh
is
[Music]
[Music]
hello
[Music]
many brilliant moves have you played
when do you play your best chess
how many games have you won by castling
in the end game
how many opponents have you played from
new zealand and most importantly of all
how many botes gambits has alexandra
botez played
find the answers to all of these
questions and many many more at
chess.com
insights
our new tool that lets you dive deep
into all of the fun and instructive data
behind your chest try it today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we see all four games on the screen
here
three players
just hanging out away from their boards
their chairs
very tall
the only dingly wren has what i consider
a normal sized chair it's been one of
the biggest talking points of the event
and we just remind everybody that in
studio in madrid international master
elmira kripchenko grand master daniel
naradiski i'm grand master robert hess
and one hour and change into the round
we have some really exciting battles and
no games have been decided yet
of course and this is
i think
incredibly exciting you know they're
i'm looking at the board between uh at
the game between yandeep nishi and uh
richard report it's extremely complex so
no draw for you today
no and richard actually just made a move
after a very long think in that one and
you know he's playing he didn't just
make a berlin draw with the black pieces
and this has been a position that was
incredibly popular about
two maybe three decades ago and reports
spent a lot of time thinking
yes indeed
in 1974.
if we go to bring up the analysis board
that after h6 the bishop actually
retreated to the f4 square putting
pressure on the d6 pawn so and there's
that t again there's the t must be happy
and d5 queen slides to e1 exploiting a
pin down the d file a potential pin down
the e file as well and bishop b4 helps
solve the issue by creating a pin in
return so if e takes d5 knight takes d5
you can't
you would love to take on d5 with your
knight but you lose your queen so that's
not available and but this is such an
interesting positional decision you
develop your bishop you well you give up
your prayer bishops and long you finish
your development
so
what do you think about this but i don't
think he did it willingly i think jan
is just a
a demon because the move a3 is so tricky
if you play bishop a5 instead
uh i think
that might be a blunder now i'm not sure
about the move order so don't quote me
on this but you can start with the point
is you start with b4 let's say bishop b6
now you take on d5 and you might think
no big deal knight d5 knight d5 bishop
d5 black has
sufficient number of defenders despite
the epon being pinned but c4 and all of
a sudden despite the white king being
weakened i don't think you can save your
bishop rook c8
uh you can just play king b1
now it turns out that this is not the
end of the story it's more complicated
than that i think after
b4
uh
black bishop b6 e.d black can actually
take with the bishop 25 but anyways
richard reports spent a while
calculating this he didn't like it and i
think as a consequence of that he
decided to take on c3 but i think this
is music to jon's ears i just want to
point out that bishop c7 fails because
of this pin down the e file because if
we count it looks like we have three
pieces defending it but we only in fact
have two because the e6 pawn cannot
legally capture so just to show that
quickly here that the trade happens the
rook takes and that rook is immune from
capture because the pawn is pinned white
would win a piece so what we're getting
at is that white was threatening to win
material in many different ways if this
bishop retreated to a5 now as you
pointed out down here to show that of
the e take d5 you'd have to make quite a
counter-intuitive move with bishop takes
d5 we typically don't enjoy losing our
bishop for a knight but here that saves
material because where knight takes d5
knight takes d5 and c4 which tries to
exploit the pin there's this from queen
to f6 at the end threatening queen a1
check threatening queen takes f4 so
black would be able to survive but
if we continue this version bishop b5
this is actually why you won the knight
on d5 if you had a bishop here you
wouldn't have bishop e3 check oh now the
knight defends e3
yes so it's just a long tactical
sequence where the knight protects the
bishop you have to take with your queen
and then we see a position i skip the
move because you take this and you take
this and black
could take the knight on d1 and give up
some more pawns or just take this and we
get a messy position that apparently is
completely level
yeah and so on the basis of these simple
lines
took on c3 now after queen c3 castles
the good news for jan
is that i think he has to move bishop e5
which might forcibly lead to a trade
down
the long diagonal this should be five
then pre-move bishop takes f6 but
there's one little trick i can move my
knight because the g7 pawn might not be
hanging yeah you can play knight e8 but
what can you play knight
oh you
you you
mr g7 queen g5
sorry friend i'm not gonna be so
friendly in this tactical line because
the bishop is lost on g7
if i miss one of one more of those
tactics just like magnus i might retiro
from chess
no that didn't it the pun was better
when i
applied it to magnus but can you play a
simple move rook c8 here after bishop v5
then i didn't take an f6
and i look pleadingly on my opponent
please allow me to win the candidates
so you're just saying that the queen
should take because the g pawn takes
king is undoubtedly in trouble and after
this it's not that black is worse it's
just that black can't really play for a
win at this point white uh is but i
think this would be incongruent with
jan's overall strategy which is to play
for a draw by playing for a win so jan
might play g2 g4 and just decide that
hey guess what richard you don't want to
play berlin i'm going to wipe you off
the board white's got two bishops
well-placed queen hook on h6
i would prefer white here
but
as long as there's opposite side
castling and black wants to go rook a8
to c and bishop a4
you know
your heart is going to be beating pretty
fast here as long as the queens are on
the board and we should remind everybody
why we are talking about this game and
the way we are the report playing for a
win yan being happy for a draw because
yonda palmishi has eight and a half
points with this game and tomorrow's
game to go so
jan just needs one draw today and he has
made his way through
to qualify for a world championship
match so jan
he's sipping his tea he's trying to make
sure that he's fully focused and almira
do you think he's happy with the
position that he's obtained after 14
moves
i think that he's a bit nervous
especially that when you see his result
eight and a half points even out of 14
would be sufficient to win the
tournament for the moment that's still
not sufficient like out of 12 and he's
going even for an historic score if he
makes two draws for example he can uh
win a tournament with the score which
which we have never seen before
but uh
but i can certainly feel tension here
tanya i mean we see yon on screen here
he's also spending
35 minutes for 14 moves we know how
quick he plays in the opening
well i think he's been a zen master this
tournament in terms of his emotions but
he's also human he's i think he's
obviously nervous i don't even think
that's up for debate
i think it's also important to point out
that even if let's say young loses and
let's say that ding and hikaru both
draws draw he's not going to be happy he
doesn't want to win the candidates the
whimper right he doesn't want to win on
the strength of other players holding
hikaru and people in second place back
he wants to win by getting a point and a
half out of the last two games and he
wants to win with a chestnut comp pin on
his jacket because i just saw him move
and that that looks like a chest like
i'm pinning happy yeah
i don't have one of those
danny i know you're watching the show uh
i don't own a chess.com pin so
i guess yan is you know he he deserves
it and we don't here uh oh he didn't
really not really achieving anything is
he like singing to
himself
it felt like he was vibing to some kind
of music and now he's going back to
calculating it's actually one of the
questions that i still have for young or
for richard's reported like
what kind of music they listen to while
they're preparing for their games i'm
just listening to them whatsoever but
okay
it's my spot to find okay and there was
a long stuck in my head and
okay during game i just
took myself down i you'll listen to some
music some uh johannes
where's my voice coming from
wolfgang i would have suppose what am i
saying oh johan sebastian bach
i got my composers confused i hope yon
doesn't have his candidate moves
confused here because this is a very
complex position
it is no it really is a tough one and
jan doesn't look very familiar with the
position either so richard report spent
a bunch of time in his last two moves
jan doing the same nerves are
undoubtedly playing a part but if we
talk strictly about what's happening on
the chess board
and this isn't an easy position to
figure out because
right now white has the bishop pair but
the d5 e4 tension is very important i
can push that pawn to e5 but then that
allows black free play on the queen side
where only white's king is so jan he may
be nervous he may still be stoic he did
talk to us about his mentality so let's
remind everybody about what he said
general overlooking at all your games
here in uh at the candidates in madrid
what do you think so far has been the
reason of your success
i don't know i'm just trying to keep you
know my head calm and
not
you know
let you know
any emotions uh drive me so
trying to do my job more or less and
this could be the difference with the
players who like play their first
candidates the tournament is nothing
like over yes so it's
still i have two games which could be
like extremely tense
and uh
i mean
so far once again so far it's so good
but i mean it's
it's true you know to give some promises
i feel like when young says that they're
two games left very tense i think he's
reminding himself
because one of the biggest story lines
of yonda palmachi before the previous
candidates in 2020 slash 2021 was that
he is impulsive he plays too quickly
even when he has good positions he
hasn't slowed down to calculate so i
feel like as he said when he joins the
studio that the kent's candidate
tournaments are different for him the
level of preparation is higher he feels
like he's in the zone and i think he
keeps himself in a narrow line and he
only walks that line without venturing
out and that's why he's trying to keep
his composure and keep his emotions in
check and chess is also it's a very
strange game compared to the other
sports where you can express your
emotions freely while during the chess
tournament like you observe almost a
religious silence during the games then
you go and prepare like for the next
game and i'm pretty sure that maybe
after winning the game jan you know
young soul is jumping like a unicorn
inside you know but you do not allow
yourself even to feel that until the
tournament is over
yeah it's a must remaining objective at
all times and jan napoli has done a
masterful job of that throughout this
event right now in this position it's
not looking very easy he's been thinking
for a while but as we get to the other
boards in the bottom left-hand side of
the screen dingley wren against alireza
farouja alariz has the white pieces up a
pawn but look at those pawns for black
c6 all the way to e4 it feels like
dingley run he's trying to figure out if
he can play for more and as i say that i
look at the top right and the car
nakamura he may have played the best
move of the tournament with pawn to h4
danya against yanchez of duda he plays
d4 once again h4 excuse me once again a
very interesting unorthodox decision but
the intention of that decision is
crystal clear he does not want
uh jan schistov to move that knight off
of g6 he is going to bring that pawn up
to h5
the pawn will be supported by the queen
the pawn itself supports the knight
now that is obviously a very time
consuming plan and it allows due to
several tempi to improve his
coordination so king f7 is a very
helpful move for black okay we'll
analyze this with king coming to f7
right with scare a lot of our viewers
but king of seven makes a lot of sense
and then after h5
uh
black wants to play a move like queen c7
or maybe even rook g8 to e8 to prepare
kg8 and the reason i'm a little bit iffy
on hikaru's strategy is because he has
given that duda a chance
uh to either coordinate his rooks or to
castle by him and if duda makes his king
safe and i think almira's earlier point
will be very pertinent black has great
control over the center let's not forget
that the knight on c3
it's restricted by black's pawns the
knight on c4 is a very good one so from
the perspective of the non
knight on g6 pieces
one could make the case that black has
better control over the position as a
whole
so a very double-edged decision by
nakamura i won't pass judgment on it yet
let's see how the next three or four
moves go
and i think that the logical
continuation after h4h5 would be for
white to
support it by plane f4 but in this
position i'm not sure you want to do
this because you give up the e5 square
like potentially the g5 and the b2 pawn
is a problem too exactly yeah just to
put that here rookie 8 f4 it looks like
a very natural
move because the king's in f7 but you
see the evaluation bar say this is
really bad stuff after bishop takes f4
the pawn on b2 is lost the pawn on b2
might be lost anyway tactically speaking
because if you take with say the rook on
f4 i can still take your pawn on b2 in
some positions with queen b6 check to
follow and grabbing the bishop down here
on b2 so you have to be very very
careful here for white and even if i
just make a comma move just to get out
of the pin with king jade black's
position is fundamentally more sound
than whites isolated upon here over
extended pawn there problem on b2 you
can't really move because the c3 knight
is loose so this is how people with the
white pieces play a little bit too
ambitiously and then lose quite quickly
because they can't protect all their
pieces uh just to come back what i said
previously that's what i was thinking
why this position suits uh jean-claude a
young young sister do you think he's
french now
jean-cristo very good
better because even though that he has a
very solid opening repair to her he's
striving for the dynamic play very much
he's a very dynamic player
right and he can you know obtain those
dynamics without
doing anything
wild right he can just make king f7
rookie eight and already the position
calls for it from white's perspective so
after king f7 h5 let's say rookie are
there any other ways white can play
besides f4 we know that a car would
likely looking to play for a win
but hikaru tends to be quite objective
in his plans right against timor java he
regretted how adventurous his opening
was and the consequence of it but is
there a way he can play maybe more
solidly but still have hope that he can
outplay yanchestov
well b3
is my initial inclination to get rid of
black's strongest piece but that is an
obvious downside after knight b6
actually two downsides the first is that
knight on c3 hangs the second is the
black
and consequently the pawn on e4 as
you're showing but the possibility of d6
d5 especially after black plays queen c7
first to protect e5 is now a distinct
possibility and once black's pawn
phalanx in the center starts rolling
there might be hell to pay for white so
queen f3 is probably called for here
queen f3 queen c7
you're experiencing problems on the c
file the knight the pawn on c2
this is not a picari's alley and i think
we can only be talking about a black
advantage here
yeah this isn't good this is yucky no
and you know the knight wants to take
this bishop at some point you have to
actually put pressure on d6 but you're
so far away from doing so and black at
some point can look to play d5 so this
queen often goes to c6 to maximize the
defense of the dp you don't even have to
go d5 that's just an idea but you can
play without it and this is actually one
of those positions for white where i
might say i don't know what to do
yeah i don't know what is my plan
and i would say i also don't know so i
don't know how to help you
i think time pressure might play a
serious role in this game it doesn't
seem that way right now because it's
already moved 16 both players well over
an hour but i could easily see both
players spending
10 15 minutes per move like the next
four or five moves and i think if time
pressure becomes a factor you know we
kind of know who that favors between
garu and youngsters that would full due
respect to the polish players
blitz skill which is nothing to sneeze
at at all but amir i could send some
pushback from you well i said well young
sisters almost won the world blitz uh
championship last year he lost against
mvl on tiebreaks he
won uh
the super bed warsaw rapid and blitz
tournament uh which well finished almost
before the candidates so i'm not sure
who is the favorite in this match he
also eliminated magus carlson the world
cup i would say that ultimately you know
if you had to put some kind of winning
percentages hit car has to have more
than 50 percent but you're right that
young chistop duda i mean he's right
there uh amongst the best players
slightly behind hikaru i agree that yan
schuster might have chances in the times
but i wouldn't super bet on it oh
goodness on that note we're gonna
go to our four game
view that way i have more things to
distract me from daniel's mistimed puns
so we do see yonder probably play your
move bishop e5 so that's uh probably
just him continuing to make good moves
uh solid moves and rich reports on the
clock but i'm looking at the bottom
right hand side of the screen team over
java look at the clock situation against
five minute carwana where fabiano has
spent very little time where java is
down 50 minutes at this point and we
have that kind of banco gamut
compensation where black is just
targeting the queen side pawns and white
may not be worse in fact maybe the
pawns just get traded off
somehow it's equal
but
that would be a success for caruana in
many ways the black pieces no real
stress in this game that feels like a
good result as he tries to buy for
second place
that's a very successful uh opening um
preparation i think
and
the more we look at this position uh we
understand that there is no easy way to
castle for life now
what are you going to do with your a2
pawn there's the yes if your castle i
can always take bishop b2 knight a2 then
rook b3
and maybe at the end we will come down
to
rook and game 3 versus 4. yes yeah no
java certainly doesn't want that there's
actually a very tilting line okay for
white which is if you castle here you
say okay i'm gonna give up e2 and a2 but
i'll take c5 and it'll be a draw this is
what almira is saying rookie one right
okay
after bishop f3 bishop f3 knight a2 your
rook was defending b3 and rook c5 rogue
b3 is white's worst nightmare come true
like
you want to avoid this kind of end game
like the plague
if you're timor and i think the way you
do that is you start by eliminating the
pawn on c5 now this is very scary
because black has this weird move rook
b5
if robert can ever manage to take the
pawn
then after rook takes b5 it's checkmate
knight c2 and rook d1 oh my goodness i
mean out of nowhere
just distracting the rook off the c file
leading to a background checkmate only
move 91 rook takes c1 is mate yikes so
that means after rook b5 you have to
move the rook and stay on the seafoam
but
where do you move it
um
i would go probably go rook c3 i think
all other squares are bad for various
reasons and after knight takes a2
now you can move the rook off of the c
fall you move to e3 but black is knight
c1
castles
knight takes b3 and sign the piece of
chords i think we're going to see
something
along those lines
wow
yeah it's not that exact line it does
seem very likely that even if black wins
those two pawns on the queen side white
will grab c5 and
if white doesn't lose his e2 pawn as
well then that should be a quite
straightforward but that's what
timor java was thinking about he is
trying to figure out how do i trade my a
and b pawns for black sea pawn without
also losing my e2 pawn and being able to
castle and that often is easier said
than done so he is trying to be
really accurate here he can
play rook takes e5 as you're indicating
but he's probably a little bit nervous
about that because of some of the
tactical sequences yes but let's analyze
those tactical sequences because after
rook c5 maybe i can take knight a2 okay
if i'm not losing a piece after rook a5
then this line works for black
yeah no rook 85 you can bring your
knight back to b4 if you're worried but
knight c3 is even stronger because
speaking of checkmate there's one there
this pawn now is under attack twice and
this is what teamwork clearly doesn't
want
because all the threats are
against even if by some engine
method he's still fine like knight d2
but because rook takes b3 yeah no no
take my ball beautiful check
you have to take my rook gorgeous moves
and then
what
rook do you want me right
i think this is like one one of my
favorite moments of the commentary when
i hear a dinosaur
i reserve it for for these kind of
special moments
that would be
quite an ending so yeah it's not easy
for java to even defend any of the pawns
because of the tactics against the king
that's why we typically don't like
having the king in the center and
do you like coffee do you like timor oh
my oh
oh my a man asked for my own heart yes
seriously someone banned this person
from chat please
that is a genius fun
that that chatter is not getting a
diamond membership i see my producer
that might be one of the best i've ever
heard i think that deserves a platinum
gold diamond membership whatever name
the precious metal i think a membership
tier should be named after this person
and is this like a joke on poison berry
like is that what's happening with their
username everything this guy says is a
pun
yeah um
that was that hurt that really hurt to
read out loud i regret it immensely
let's be honest roger's performance and
quite impressive in this tournament says
save nature47
yeah it has i think amir you were
mentioning this that the expectations
for java were zero like everyone thought
he might just get last he might lose a
lot of games but her job wasn't playing
excellent chess actually before the
tournament started he was one of the
underdogs
yeah
no i i i just think players
chess is this weird thing
where players are often influenced by
the fact they know a player more
so what do i mean by that
farouza he was in everybody on
everybody's mind right for for like the
months leading up to the tournament and
his climb to 2800 and yes there were
high expectations
attached to him and for very good reason
rajab might have been a little bit less
on people's minds he played less but
that doesn't mean he's less strong he's
27.50 for goodness sake you don't hit
that rating coincidentally and as i say
that
knight f3 to d2 is his choice closing
down the d-file
what do we make of this
well i think you just take the pawn in
a2
and
uh feels like
it's just a trade and he's protecting b3
with the knight it's gonna be a draw
yeah i think he's stabilizing and that
way he can make a draw but
mujaba as he is tied for fourth place
right now with the player he's facing
five under carwana he still has a chance
at second place and he shared his
thoughts about what should happen if
there is indeed a tie for a second
well the tie breaks are good in general
i think it's the right way and uh also
for the world championship format um i
think also carlson
uh was proposing this i think the world
cup format is a good thing like all this
you know knockout matches and so on it's
a very good thing i think in my opinion
so you would prefer knockout matches for
the candidates rather than a double
round robin
you said knockout or naca
can be true
so uh the knockouts i think are a good
thing also for the people like watching
it's it's fun all the time because i
mean until the very end i mean it goes
like you know
uh in the candidates for example if you
started badly and then you have to play
for 14 i mean 14 rounds and you're like
minus four and there's no chance to win
the tournament or something like this
it's like uh
useless tournaments everybody is trying
to beat you and so on so it's a bit uh
tricky thing i think but for the world
championship i think you can i mean can
be used the knockout system in general
it's also a lot of fun and um it's like
it's normalizing i think it's a good
so one thing about timor is he of course
has been a streamer himself but he
really pays attention to the broader
gaming atmosphere and he said that he
feels the knockout format is more
exciting for fans and also will make it
so that people who are having bad
tournaments they're eliminated right if
you play a bad term in a knockout you're
gone so almira what do you think what's
your take on knockout tournaments well
that's an interesting point because uh
and if you come back to our discussion
before what i said that you wouldn't see
you would not see the players uh putting
up like less resistance in this case so
knock knock on tournaments are very
interesting and it happens that like for
the first time in many years i accepted
to play this year in the french
championship well the french federation
has changed the format completely and we
are going to witness for the first time
in knockout tournament
so i want i really wanted to try it and
i find that it's also uh it's a
tournament which is very interesting to
watch for spectators yeah and danya on
the downside the closing ceremony has
just two players there and everyone else
has gone home but on the upside one
player's result can't hurt somebody in a
different match right if uh richard
reporting this tournament his game with
gianna palmer the first time around that
loss hurt everybody in the field to the
point that he apologized to fabiano who
at the time was right behind yondu palm
she so that seems to be another benefit
yeah you could argue the knockout format
is a lot more pure precisely for that
reason another downside though
is that people watch tournaments for
different reasons some watch them for
the sporting element but others watch
them because they're fans of a certain
player and if that player gets
eliminated then certain people might be
less inclined to watch the rest
of the tournament
but i would counter that by saying that
there are a lot more fans of the game of
chess there are a lot more people who
might be disappointed if let's say
you're a fan of ollie reza and he's
limited from the tournament but those
people are going to keep watching
because
knockout tournaments are super
compelling and if let's be real if
you're a chess fan you're going to watch
this tournament if 10 other super gms
are playing so i'm a big fan of the
knockout format i think it needs to be
thought through
very carefully but i definitely think
that it's part of the future of chess
and it's also part of the past because
the fedex candidates used to be
knockouts when timothy jabov played in
2011
there were knockout event where there
are eight players
trying to make their way through and you
have to win three matches not easy
against this level of competition but i
think that
teamwork he has a good sense of what
fans want because he not only streams
himself he watches the streams he told
us he
watches hikara's recap videos
yeah that was awesome oh he's not
missing any bit of information
yeah from a sporting
aspect that could be smart just because
you can hear a car's thoughts about his
openings and how he played uh but it
just is clear that
timor he
said just to us that he believes that
knockout is the better format and
some of the other players have voiced
similar thoughts and i do believe that
uh ooh that it could be good and we see
first of all this person is all about
elimination formats because their name
is illuminator and then the little
symbol is a loo and yeah what about
double illume
what about double a loom so it's a good
question double elimination that's a
pretty illuminating question
those formats are being used more and
pretty exciting they're using other
esports for sure in other gaming so
amira what do you think can we people
get two chances
well i have only tried this format when
i played in poker tournaments uh this is
completely different so i'm not really
sure that they have so much experience
or at least at least expertise to talk
about this subject i was thinking maybe
gone are the days where the candidates
were playing 28 rounds in order not to
qualify for the match so um
talking about
the
purity element i'm not sure that uh this
one is uh
was suits chess best okay daniel the
recent american cup had double
elimination format five minute caruana
won that event what did you make of it i
liked it i think it's promising i did i
mean i'm not going to be talking about
the same
caliber tournament as the candidates but
i did play the bullet chess championship
chess.com bullet championship was a
double elim format
and i liked it a lot because it took a
little bit of the pressure off of the
initial matches because i knew that i
would still have a chance
uh if i lost and i think it eliminates
the sort of role of coincidence because
if
in the world cup this becomes a problem
sometimes you make one little blunder
and because it's just a two game match
uh you know you're already eliminated
and one might argue that that's on you
and you know blunders are a part of the
game so
i think there's a place for a deep
philosophical discussion on you know
what
uh caters to the purity of chess more
double elim should certainly play a
central role in that discussion for sure
yeah more elimination events could be
fun the world cup is so popular it only
happens once every couple years but a
lot of spectators have voiced everything
approved all years yeah exactly every
couple of years didn't actually make a
pun we see hikaru nakamura who doesn't
try to become a meme but he often does
when he looks at other people's games he
makes his one of his faces he's like
what's going on in this one but with
this game being so level i don't think
that he has too much looking
and we're going to take a step back
we're going to look at our four game
view as all four games are in session
richard report trying to figure out his
end game as we see in the top left but
yonda pomshi is undoubtedly thrilled no
risk for him with the white pieces uh he
can probably lock this turn up without
too much effort and report he's trying
to
solve his problems but
hikaru nakamura he brought his queen out
to have three in the top right i
like dingley wren still trying to fight
for an advantage
which game should we go to i know that's
usually my job but i wanted someone else
to pick
giving you all a choice too
you're putting us on the spot
i mean elemira well i wanted to have a
look at this
very interesting end game although it's
still
very equal uh but
against ferocious
ferugi against zingliwan
okay so we'll bring that one up here
because dingley ren tied with akara
nakamura for second place entering the
round and amir we have the end game
white still up a pawn but black with
great pieces and uh what they wanted to
point out is that uh alireza came uh
well he found a very active one so he
wants to play h3 and g4
and then if you allow him he will play
g5 and then h4 and h5 and those phones
actually will become very dangerous
uh-oh that does seem like a bit of a
problem and
right that's what ding's move was aimed
against bishop e7 okay so oh so you
played g4 you're saying he'll put his
bishop on h4 but then
the bishop could get locked in here
there's no way to trap it
yeah but it's like it's in a prison but
it's got you know high-speed wi-fi and
you know
endlessly refilling cookie jar and
white cannot get to this bishop and you
mentioned something much earlier robert
that i think some people might have
rolled their eyes out and it's never
going to happen the black king i'm
talking to the black king getting to c3
it's become a lot more of a reality now
because the king is only a few steps
away from it
and let's not forget about the
possibility of a well-timed bishop
sacrifice on g5 because black has quite
the phalanx of pawns in the center
and
this is a very complicated position it's
a three result position all zeros by the
computer
because if both sides play precisely
you know a situation
where neither side can make progress
should arise but there's a high
probability of an inaccuracy from from
either side here so
it's this has gotten a lot spicier than
i've expected and almira alireza must be
pretty happy because you're pointing out
this plan that even once you get here
you have a past pawn a protected pass
pawn so already probably feels like
instead of just waiting to see what
dingle red's gonna do he now has chances
to play for a win himself
i'm not too sure about this
have a look at this bishop on h4 it is
certainly trapped
but in the long term
it can also attack the pawn on f4 if you
trade rooks and it takes so many squares
away from white species you can no
longer play king f2 king e3 if you want
your rook cannot transfer well anywhere
yeah no it seems like white is very much
locked up here it's so strange to put a
bishop on h4s because if you just gave
white a knight this king would go over
here and then and the knight would try
to come to g2 and take the piece but
with opposite colored bishops and no
rook able to go to a square like g4
because the pawn the bishop is very very
safe here so what are your moves here
rook do you want rook f1 yeah
i think i think only black can really
try i mean if you play c4 god forbid oh
yeah
dc4 d4
i just to show you this is so black's
king can chill on c5 and i want to make
one
more quick point to piggyback off of
what elmira said about the bishop
visually we think only the bishop is
trapped but in a sense the white king is
also trapped because the moment it moves
the bishop can jump to g3 so we don't
think of the king as being tied down or
trapped but really it is because in
order to keep the bishop trapped the
king is also essentially confined to one
little space
yeah if you try to push the pawn to g6
you'll have to make a move let's say
king d6 they can move like bishop h5 but
that's a very really oh
g5 already oh okay let's move my king
first but that's a good point by donya
bishop takes g5 as possible actually
this gets very dicey oh with bishop f7
donna's point was that after pawn takes
rook takes black gets this bishop right
back and has an extra pawn and wins the
game but after bishop f7 which is
fortunate that white has that and you
get this situation
i see that it says even oh
it's not sure but it says even but this
looks very scary for both sides because
there's past pawns here pass pawns there
and
to assess this is very challenging
yeah and
varetsky would probably give this in one
of his books like a one star difficulty
problem
yeah vlad kramnik didn't get this right
and told him he had no future in chess
in any case complex position
still draws the most likely bishop e7
such a classy move by ding
such good prophylaxis not panicking at
the prospect of g4
understanding that the flying the
ointment is that it weakens the h4
square
and uh i'll erase it deep in thought
here and we can just show elmira's point
right like if you don't play bishop e7
let's say i make bishop c7 and then g4
happens and i just go back thinking
there's no big deal you already see the
difference your bishop is locked out
king g3 pawn h4 pawn h5 at some point i
can't play kg3 too early because i
dropped my pawn but that's what the h4
move is for i'll start with h4 bring my
king up and i can even play h5 and so on
and
how you stop my pawns
danny i was also wondering uh if dink
played bishop b7 with the intention of
playing bishop h4 if you will not play g
quite likely to force white to play g4
oh that's annoying so if i move my rook
somewhere random bishop h4
your pawn is pinned you have to play the
move g4 otherwise you lose and now we're
and now king d6 yeah with the same exact
territory as before so likely g5 and
white is frozen yeah and and
c3 is a move that you might look at the
engine and say oh why should you just
play c3 and stop black skin from getting
to c5 but the danger of just parodying
the computer
is that you fail to appreciate the
the difficulty of playing certain moves
look at this from another perspective
this makes it very possible for black to
play c5 and d4 and the moment black
establishes a pawn on d4 the game could
end in like three moves right so as easy
it is as it is to just say that white ah
why you just stopped king b4 because the
engine says so there's human
difficulties associated with all of
these moves yeah i just want to show the
difference or by playing c3 you allow
black to create a past pawn whereas the
pawn on c2 if black ever play the move
d4 let's just go back over here and make
his move d4 then you're not actually
going to get it past pawn because white
has the square under control so
there's a lot here to work out for both
these two players but the point is the
bishop comes to h4
and black is
holding off white's past pawns
so
yeah this is a position that already has
a lot to work through if he intends to
play for a win so let's uh have a quick
look
at the hall there oh look at that
familiar oh that is this nathan anand
the former world chess championship
champion the five-time world chess
champion he is talking commentating in
spanish so go on over to twitch.tv slash
chesscom e s to hear vichy's thoughts on
these candidates as he speaks to our
spanish commentators on site that is
such a treat for all the viewers look
how many people are sitting there in the
audience mesmerized by the legend who
also happens to be a polyglot you know
but we should lived in spain for so many
years so he's so fluent in spanish and
of course uh this is such a present to
the spanish audience yeah dania who
speaks spanish maybe you're gonna go on
a break and go listen to the i would
love to
yeah you can take over i don't think
anymore speak
yeah no it is really a treat and we've
commented with vishy before anytime you
can hear us such a luminaries thoughts
uh you should check that out so again
twitch.tv
e chess.com for the commentary by the
chesacam spanish speaking team and
the former world champion vishwanathan
anand so
these players still
trying to make their way through the
round richard report doesn't look very
entertained by his game in the top left
it's an endgame black's pawn structure
but compromise
white with an extra pawn on the queen
side over there so report he's probably
just saying maybe i should call it a day
somebody should try to make a draw
nepo's tasting that glass of champagne
that he might be having tonight
and uh
i mean i don't see
too many universes in which black wins
this game i would caution
against assuming the white is much
better because of his improved pawn
structure the thing is if you look at
black's f and e pawns they're quite
mobile if the king gets to f6 which is
what richard is trying to do with his
last move
e5 e4 becomes a serious possibility so
there is still life in this end game
nepo has to be careful
but if you told him that you would get a
slightly better end game after 21 moves
and you need to draw to win the
candidates i mean
he would accept that with open arms
well we
have established that we have a
multiverse pattern in our commentary
first i wanted to ask daniel well in
those uh universes like how many
dimensions do you
have if only and how does a chess game
look like in those
universes sadly i'm not a science
fiction fan just that question already
makes my brain explode
well i'm looking towards like uh
well at 10 dimensional chisels tandem
wow chests weren't complicated enough 10
dimensional chess game
oh my goodness and i think yonder palm
she's happy that
it's not to that point because
the way he's playing chess as the game
currently exists it's good enough and
it's fantastic quality and he's
seemingly just
a little while away from locking up his
second consecutive can sermon poor some
of his poor non-existent
i've never seen any liquid actually come
out of that thermos like ever so you're
accusing jan of lying to us
i think he might be and then and then to
complete the act it's that that careful
sipping as if there's like hot liquid in
there
maybe say something actually i like very
much this move king g7 first of all he's
bringing his king on f6 then he's going
to play rook g8
is he going to force jan to play g3 but
then you have this potential uh play
associated with h5h4
and you can even bring back your rook to
a rocket shade play h5h4 second row on
g8
yeah that's true but i guess like let's
say
white makes some random move b3 and you
play king of six i think why can't we
bring that rook over to h4 just to
be a nuisance over here you're gonna
have to uh what okay can you fly
yeah and then i move my rook back
somewhere this way
i don't know
yeah but if we start trading rooks i
think white is
happy
can i start with h5 here aha so amira is
trying to get this pawn going get a rook
to g8 put pressure down on g2
yeah this is the start of something
right this has the look of a position
where black can try and play for wins
you shouldn't stop watching the game is
far from over yeah it's a three result
position am i i'm not out of line if i
say that no it's interesting because i
think that you know we want to just
chalk it up yan win the tournament and
then you start realizing with these
double pawns inherits having double
pawns is an open file so
this g2 pawn can become a target and jan
needs to play accurately that said maybe
jan's accuracy has to be on the queen
side because he can start pushing pawns
of his own so he is up a pawn on the a
through c files so let's look to push
those pawns there and
can black get e5 that really weakens the
f5 pawn it also opens up the sixth rank
for the white rook so it is a bit of a
mixed bag right now and for yonda
pamashi he doesn't want to take risks
here so maybe he'll find
some move that eliminates the option to
play king of six and rook g8 and another
thing we shouldn't forget about the fact
that jan has the additional onus of
constantly trying to find lines that
lead to simplification in the draw
and that's an additional burden on its
clock that's an additional burden on a
psyche i remember when i i needed to
draw for my second gm norm which was
basically as good of an achievement as
winning the candidates you know
comparable
but i had a similar situation where i
had like a slightly better end game with
black
but all i could think about all i could
look for were lines that led to trades
and ultimately that you know desire to
simplify was so overpowering that i just
like forgot i was better and
traded into a three on four rook end
game which i had to defend for another
60 moves i eventually made the draw
but it was crazy how much that influence
distorted
my my thinking and richard doesn't have
that i mean he's just playing this like
an oral land games he's got nothing to
lose
that's a good point right the pressure
is entirely
squarely on yonder palm she's shoulders
and uh he may
see what richard's up to almira's plan
bringing the rook to g8 and king to f6
and he may say i need to stop that but
when you only look to stop potential
winning ideas for your opponent you may
stop also looking for your own ideas so
jan has to remain what does he keep
looking behind he's like looks at that
direction a thousand times well
hopefully it's not people distracting
him because you know even a small
footstep oh it's ikaro's position
because remember hikaru and ding both
have to win their games
in order to make yan's result meaningful
oh that's true because if ding and hikar
draw their games that doesn't matter how
yonder palms does he is the champion of
the 2022 fita candid so that's a good
point but you don't really want to be
glancing at other people's games too
much actually such a powerful image it
means and it proves how nervous he is
yes
because he you know he's not strictly
focusing on his own game
and this affects him great for him yeah
no he
he clearly is looking around and um
maybe he felt hikaru making a face so he
just you know he was ready to make a
face of his own both these
players uh they wear their emotions on
their sleeves and on their face but for
yonda palmishi uh i i think you know one
move that i'm considering because we
keep talking about black tie to take
over the g file is this move rook to h4
like that way you can't play king of six
you i don't think you can easily play
king g6 because then i push my pawn to
g4 to exploit a pin on your king
so rook h4 feels like a really annoying
move for black people with
but this is such a strange move to make
on the other hand
because it looks completely artificial
let's say if i would be black i would
start with rook d8
then i will try to take control over d
file you will probably play bishop e2
absolutely if we are looking uh for the
for the lines which allow you to trade a
few pieces and uh
to reach a drawing end game but here um
here now that your bishop is on e2 maybe
you can play king g6
right
and i guess i'll happily trade
and
did he just play bishop e2 first okay so
he's opening up the d file uh but yeah i
was just looking at a position like this
and like all right come beat me show me
what you got and if you bring your king
up i can just put my pawn on g3 and
defend my rook and i just
one of those ideas like i was saying
where you're just stopping your
opponent's plan but it could get you in
trouble because it does feel very um
artificial as a way of dealing with the
pushes on the king's eye but of course
this is by no means a better position
for black but we have a game right
for sure we have a game and i think gian
has moved bishop to e2
laying claim to the d file so no rook d8
for you and maybe he could play g4 yeah
he doesn't want to deal with his pawn on
g2 being a weakness and if he starts
trading off pawns even though it's a
double pawn he may feel like his
position becomes easier to play or g3 to
once and for all
or at least for the foreseeable future
fix the problem of the open g file
rendering
rook g8 ineffective it takes some time
it's a little passive but
we also have to realize that the movie
e65 comes with a hefty price tag it
weakens the f-pawn
it weakens the sixth rank the rook could
uh you know metamorphose into into a
monster
and uh
you know it's likely that richard plays
this move at some point but he's got to
choose that time
very well
yeah and then as
we've been looking at some point white
can push forward but i don't think that
jan feels any need to as a draw suits
him just fine and richard still
calculating trying to work his way
through this position let's get on back
to our bird's eye view because dingley
wren in the bottom left-hand side of the
screen he has planted his bishop on age
four and that seems to stop
almost all of alirez's chances to throw
his pawns forward and then i'm just
looking at that top right game between
hikar nakamura and yanchez of duda
because the king on f7 is it safe is it
you know going to be attacked is black's
foundation so strong that white
is going to be worse if he doesn't find
some sort of initiative those are the
big questions that hikaru and yanchez
have to ask each other
actually so i am so impressed uh by
hikaru's flame because he grasped the
essence of the position he understood
that he
the knight on c3 is very well is badly
placed so he played knight z1 probably
in 93.
right the knight on c3 was just in the
pawns path and couldn't move if you
allowed black to line up on the c file
so the knight e3 does in fact
protect this pawn on c2 it also aims the
d5 square and maybe
it goes over to g4 because if you're not
careful we could already see certain
sacrifices on the king side like that
could be very scary for black to deal
with yeah and duda almost immediately
responded with knight d7
solidifying the knight on f6 i think
that he still
is prioritizing the manual castling of
the rookie and king chi but i i think
the car has made a lot more progress
than jkd i'm already looking at c4 yeah
binding the center and b3 bishop a3
let's let's not forget that why doesn't
sacrifice anything igar wasn't under an
obligation to go for mate he could go
for
central pressure you know attacking the
d6 pawn maybe attacking the e6 pawn if
the king moves from f7 to g8 so
it seems to me that nakamura just has a
better as almira saying a better grasp
on the position
than jan schistov and it's hard for me
to pinpoint a single move where that has
manifested itself but just taking a
snapshot of the position five moves ago
in the position now it feels like
yukaru's making moves and he's literally
making moves as he plays your move c2 c4
and if we bring up some analysis board
here we'll
soon get back
and look how we got to this point but if
we analyze the current position after c4
it may look like white can get in some
trouble so
after c4
this knight can come to c5 and put
pressure on this e4 pawn and it doesn't
look easy for white to defend it so
we'll dive into this position here
knight to c5
right that attacks his pawn on e4
and
well with this pawn on e4 under attack
how do you defend it right because there
are two pieces covering it and i guess
you just don't defend it
you give it away
wow you give it away yeah so how are you
gonna give you one rookie one and after
knight takes e4 oh
i must have some
maybe actually i don't have any tactics
here i was thinking i g4
oh and then bishop takes h6 maybe that's
the idea i was mentioning before that
could be like a knight takes
tactic and and i think it's important to
remember again that duda didn't go for
that knight take c4 line early in the
game
uh
presumably because the position looked
too scary
i feel like car's doing a great job of
using
jan's
uh anxiety about his form against him
and there we see it jan didn't put any
thought into knight c5 instead
preferring to go after that knight on g6
it could be just great understanding by
john chistop let's get his knight out of
there he certainly is 97 b4 right this
is a really uncomfortable position for
black you can take with the king just to
get out of the pin and as you're saying
b4 is possible b3 is not bad at all just
to bring this bishop over here but b4
just to extend your pawns and watch out
because a move like c5 can shatter black
structure and i'm talking a lot about
psychology but and the last thing i'll
say on that topic is that
jan is going to get more nervous the
more
he uh john chistop's position declines
and he's got to be very careful not to
let that affect him not to get tilted
and start asking why can't yanchez stop
just play one good game you know
he's got to put that out of his mind and
focus on his own game
and what did your car do it looked like
the
thing
moved his way back
no way
it looks like he just didn't take the
bishop but isn't there knight h7 and
knight g5 uh oh my lane yes
wow wait how does white stop that
because if you move the knight from e3
to open up the bishop let's not forget
that c4 is going to hang right this
knight
now is doing an important task of
protecting the pawn here
why did he rush that
because now knight g5 not just forces
the queen away from the f3 score it's
pinning it also puts pressure on e4 so
maybe he wants to play knight g4 here
it's like dancing with the knights
but rock takes c4 knight
ah no i cannot sacrifice and bishop
takes h6 has lost a lot of its luster
now that all of your pieces are confined
to the king side and you could even take
it right because while you get this
rook on jade here black has all these
pieces near the king this knight is
under attack black has two minor pieces
for rook and just one pawn so it's a
material advantage for black whose
knight is coming to g5 next move and e4
might fall as well so that's
um a retreating move to keep more pieces
on the board but it could cost hikaru
nakamura
badly because he's entered the round in
a tie with dingley wren so as we see yan
chistop duda he's trying to figure out
what to do here knight h7 does look very
reasonable this camera shaking is making
me nauseous so hopefully the you know
the camera is nervous yeah the camera's
nervous for the players as well right uh
but either way
we're going to leave the players to do
their thinking as young napalmashes rook
went to h4 in the top left and we're
more or less in expected territory
across the four boards so we're going to
take a break but before we do we want to
remind you of an event taking place on
chess.com after the cans concludes it is
blitzchamps which is coming your way
july 9th and 10th at 1pm pacific time so
watch your favorite stars including hall
of famer larry fitzgerald the all-pro
linebacker michael parsons the new
cleveland browns receiver amari cooper
and top five draft pick and new new
yorker k von thibodeaux they're going to
duke it out over the chessboard rather
than on the gridiron coming your way
july 9th to 10th at 1 p.m pacific and as
you see the four
four boards here
not all players they're chairs but all
players thinking hard here at the 2022
feeder candidates chess.com coverage
will return in just a few minutes
you can watch chess events right on your
phone
you don't even need to download an app
just open any mobile browser and head to
chess.com events
you can see what's happening right now
check out top games
see results
and so much more try it for yourself at
chess.com events
apparently this is the horse she rode in
on literally queen isabella herself on a
night a noble steed you know changed the
world forever it's why
everyone in madrid
knows the game of chess
they know that the candidates is here
they know that uh that this is
one of the capital cities of our great
game and it's all because of that lady
right there on that noble steed now
that's a night thank god for queen
isabella changing the rules right and
giving the queen her powers
i know that in the filming we're really
running with this but in my head it was
the queen of france so that begs the
question who is the chess.com historian
and can i fire them
well you'd have to fire yourself i think
yeah that's a good point
that's uh call that's an out take i
believe they call it in the day i'll
take so mike's gonna say was the queen
of spain next time he knows yeah he
knows yeah we gotta find more about this
lady
and find more about what the people know
here
[Music]
you guys excited for the candidates
hey can we talk for a second about this
here we go
to the plaza we go
which way is the plaza
you guys play chess yeah yeah there you
go
are you excited for the candidates yeah
yeah
yeah
you don't know what it is
okay what is it we've watched the
queen's game oh you watched the queen's
game of it me too okay you guys actually
play chess like on your phone
what are you playing chess.com yeah
you're about 1300 unleashes yeah so it
means you'd be like 900 on chess.com
actually yeah give me your username i'll
give you a diamond membership no way not
kidding he's going to be a contender in
like three years
he's up and coming so i'll give you a
premium membership and then you won't
have an excuse then you can use that
i'll go back to it yeah all right man
you're an am that's me man
yeah so this tournament decides who
plays magnus carlson
so the next challenger comes out of this
tournament all right guys enjoy thank
you so much have fun
trip guys there you go no drinking no
drinking
still no drinking that's true you guys
are connected now yeah we're buddies on
we're going to send each other some
ticks do you think they already talked
and then we'll we'll we'll talk about it
is that your phone buzzing they are
there they already yeah they're already
hitting me up for my digits okay yep
maybe wearing a pager wasn't the
smartest idea to fit in with them
[Music]
[Music]
want to play chess online or learn how
to improve join us at the number one
chess destination in the world chess.com
with thousands of people playing at any
moment you'll quickly find a game with
someone at your level whether you're a
beginner or a grandmaster chess.com
makes learning fun and easy sharpen your
tactics with puzzles and enhance your
strategy with our lessons by top masters
learn from your own games with our easy
to use analysis tool chess.com has
everything you need to take your game to
the next level signing up is free and
easy join chess.com today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
that my friends is a chess legacy
[Music]
passion for chess continues to thrive in
madrid
for the first time in 30 years spain's
capital plays host to the candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
oh and look at ding i mean he knows it's
over ding never quite felt comfortable
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess
the world chess championship
[Music]
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess yet still
chasing unfinished business
and a little sympathy you know what that
means satisfied he's got a draw in his
pocket and others from the next wave of
stars with little patience for yielding
to those before them
the next challenger to the world
champion of chess must come through
madrid
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
spam those rich report emotes i know you
loved his rendition of miss amigos i'm
here with with my friends we have
international master el niro scripchenko
grand master daniel nirmicki i'm grand
master robert hess and we are in the
midst of round 13 of the 2022 feed a
cabinet rich report you know he gives
the fans what they want he was on the
staircase he did kind of look like the
joker there so what did he use as a
token of negotiation you know to make
him do this
i had nothing to do with it i didn't
even know about it until today okay what
did you do to make him do that oh gosh
well that sounds really bad
okay come on don
get your mind out of the gutter
well i think that
their minds are made up in the bottom
right between team over jabba and five
minute carwana the pieces are traded it
looks very close to draws territory in
their game which is good news for
dingley wren as his game against alareza
faruja continues and dingley run entered
the round a half point ahead of carwana
and farouza and of course we have the
person playing for first place yon
napomshi he wants to wrap up the
tournament by getting a draw at least
against our new miss amigos announcer
richard report and hikaru nakamura when
we left we were on his game against
yanchez of duda in the top right and
yanchez just stole upon the center of
the board and
will hikaru literally care about that
well i mean it's the e4 pawn and we and
we're analyzing lines where
you sack that pawn but i don't think
he's got the right ingredients in place
to prove compensation that knight on e4
is very stable you can't exactly play f3
because of the fork on g3 and if you
dilly dally black's going to start
setting his own pawns in motion d65 has
already become
a realistic possibility so
i don't know if hikaru missed knight h7
underestimated it but whatever it is i
feel like nakamura needs to be very very
accurate in the next few moves if he
wants to obtain any compensation for
this pawn which he can
look at how quickly he's moving though
so this feels like a pawn sacrifice
rather than a blunder if we go back to
remind you of how this just happened
afternoon knight f8 trying to trade
white's best piece and white can trade
it for either this bishop or the knight
instead
hikaru backed up that knight to h4 and
the quick knight h7 followed by knight
to g5 won this central pawn now without
that pawn on the board the good news for
a car is you know this diagonal opens up
so his queen may be able to venture into
enemy territory and put pressure on this
king on f7 and d5 while in many
positions black may want to play that
with the e5 pawn being targeted and
potentially with tactics after it takes
take there could be just knight takes d5
here because when this knight moves to
take the knight on d5 the queen
just snatches the knight on e4 that's a
trade and that's not good news for this
king on f7
well on the other hand hikaru didn't
really have a choice after a knight h7
he had to give a pawn of course
it was probably a positional sacrifice
but what i don't like is that
those knights knight 94 knight of six
they can become uh very mobile so if you
even if you play a four my knight on g5
is going to be
a very active piece
right so f4 not really
no i mean like if you will manage yeah
so like i will have a very pretty
outpost on g5
right and i can also play okay king g8
true this rook can already go to as
you're saying and castle by hand
so
white has
hopes of compensation the question is is
it sufficient because hikaru when he
went knight h4 it feels like he
anticipated this position i don't think
he just blundered because his moves have
been very quick or that's that's what he
wants zuda to think
that he blundered and then he's like no
that was a sacrifice right
that's what you should always call your
blunders but you know i think um
i mentioned a couple of twerks it's it's
it's a sacrifice
it doesn't yeah it's still a sacrifice
jonathan rose in scottish gm one of my
favorite uh chess authors he's written a
few books on chess psychology and in one
of them he talks about what he calls
storytelling
and i found this so relatable he was
talking about a game he played against
victor victor koechner
and he blunders in exchange in the
opening but during the game you already
start spinning the yarn you start almost
telling yourself no no i saw that that
was a sacrifice
and
you know when you come out of the game
all of your friends ask you wait why
were you down in exchange oh i
sacrificed that i just mis-evaluated the
resulting position so sometimes the line
is actually blurred and if you tell
yourself enough times you believe it and
i actually think there is a
sort of a utility in that where during
the game you don't want to start
criticizing yourself and castrating
yourself for making a simple blunder you
want to roll with it right you've
already done it and i think hikaru is
incredibly good at adjusting to the
current set of circumstances so let's
follow carefully how he tries to garner
compensation for the pawn but i really
like jan christoph's last move he
finally moves his rook away from that
cursed g8 square to vacate that parking
spot for the king
and black just up a pawn the h5 pawn can
become a target later so let's go to the
game oh between java it's it's about
the game is about to end and we see them
repeating moves it is the third time the
knight has gone back and forth as the
king has done the same and it looks like
these players who are tied for third
actually fourth and fifth place before
the round began they have drawn their
game which is great news for hikaru
nakamura and dingley ren who entered the
day a half point ahead of these two so
fabiano still has never lost to timor
java but almira he never
despite his creative opening play he
never really had hopes of an advantage
in this game
no but he never stopped fighting i was
thinking that you're going for for this
he can
he can
tell himself that he well he tried it
all
yeah it's true he could take that home
with him but it's not the result he
wanted donya no and i agree with elmira
he he did what he could he played a an
opening that was a measured risk it was
not crazy
and
in retrospect it's always tempting to
ask why didn't he play you know king's
indian or why didn't he play this
opening well hindsight is perfect fabi
did what he could timor took his time
maybe could have gotten an advantage
maybe was half a bluff
but
as it stands two more found a way to
trade queens he was in a little bit of
danger he was very patient accurate and
a draw is a very fair result yeah and i
believe that both players probably not
unhappy with the result the game was
likely scary for timor java who did not
expect fabiano's three pawn sacrifices
so he gets out of here with a draw he
stays tied with five-minute wanna so
let's reset here for a moment if four
games take place every round we only
have three remaining thanks to that draw
so as we bring back the bird's eye view
and check out the game still in progress
we see that the bottom right we don't
look there anymore that game is
concluded and if you look at the top
right car is not nakamura's knight has
re-entered the g6 square so a very
confusing sequence in that game uh the
other two boards the status quo remains
with yonder palmistry in the top left
with the white pieces he's just holding
down the fourth rank making sure that
richard port can't push his pawns and
the bottom left we have that bishop on
h4 but dingley runs king starting to
walk towards the queen side and if that
king on d6 enters through the dark
squares maybe we'll start talking about
winning chances for the chinese number
one yes and we will show another
triumphant king march
we showed a game between
nigel short and young simon where the
king successfully
marched towards the h6 square but here
if the king comes to c3 and then black
pushes d4 plays rook d and d3 this is
almost a winning position
yes and we'll pull that game up as
dingle wren we have him on camera the
last one played rook to b1
by alireza ferrugia and as amir was
saying if this king can get to c3 where
it not just puts pressure on the c2 pawn
but helps escort this d-pawn up the
board that could be disastrous so after
king c5 the move c3 kind of has to be
played by
uh alireza and in doing so he keeps that
king out but at the same time if this
pawn gets to c5 now we can create a past
pawn
how but b4 let's not count out white's
chances either we keep looking at this
from both players perspectives white
pushed pawns to the king side so that
bishop on h4 had to lock itself in we're
looking at the queen side where
dingleroon had the advantage but if he
oversteps maybe it'll be alareza who
gets an outside pass pawn of his own and
we can't
lose sight of the fact that alireza is
up a pawn to begin with which means that
if both sides are getting extra
past pawns white will have one extra
pass pawn at some point we saw ding
failing to adjust to the objective
demands of the position last round
he has that on his back the fact that he
really really wants to win and you know
he's got to be careful not to let that
negatively impact him once again to my
eyes in this position d5 d4
looks scary for white because apart from
the king's invasion to c3 you also have
to watch out for the king invasion to e3
because once the f4 pawn drops then the
entire king side drops so d4 has to be
properly assessed by alireza and i think
he might be intending your move before
check
you might look at this and say wait a
second a b
c b and don't i get those coveted
connected passers on e4 and d4 well you
do but after king d5
there is i think a very astute defensive
resource rook d1 we talked about black
sacrificing a bishop on g5 but what
about white sacrificing a bishop on d3
and i guess the engine it frowns heavily
upon that move so maybe instead of rook
d1 is there a better way
to make that happen or is there a better
resource but i think we should show your
point that in this event of the
sacrifice this isn't why black has an
edge there must be some kind of uh move
order thing that allows black and edge
because if we get to a place like this
we can go rook d6 we can hunt pawns we
can push our jeep exactly what my idea
was i think i understood my mistake
black can start with rogue b8
and hit the weak spot and if you play b5
then
c5 oh my get that out of my face oh my
goodness i don't think i've ever seen
this many
clear past pawns in a super gm game this
is i mean it's over because white's
pawns are going nowhere even though
there's a g and a b and an a passer but
d3 c4 all the pawns going forward and
white's position is looking pretty
hopeless at that point so
yeah the peace sacrifice is what white
may consider in some lines it doesn't
quite work so in
this line that we're looking at
d4 b4 check takes takes this is the kind
of pawn race where either side could
lose others i could win this is
certainly a position playing for three
results on mira
i agree with this uh maybe we should
prepare the d4 push and play rook b8
first
okay
what do you think first would be here
so just to
keep an eye on this b4 square put
pressure on b3 it looks reasonable ah
but then you have a chance to play
bishop h5 and bishop g6
good point oh
going after this f5 pawn as well so if
d4 is played then white can even take
and after king takes d4 maybe this
bishop f7 move it's not out of the
question
that white's pawn is about to run to the
other side so well it gets ridiculously
sharp i mean king e3
and then
even some sort of king takes f4 g7 e3
oh my gosh and it's wild position yeah
no this is we see what the evaluation is
laughs at me but you get what i'm saying
and but i wanted to repeat really
quickly before i let you talk the point
about alireza not expecting a position
like this when he went into this end
game he might still be reeling from the
fact that he even has to calculate any
of these lines i mean this is totally
not with his plan if you wanted a
position like this you would have played
something with some more teeth so i
think the psychological edge here is on
ding's side
and uh this game could go in one of a
million directions and we see in this
final position of this
kind of ridiculous line in analysis that
white is better but the players not only
to calculate this far which
it looks like it's about you know eight
moves down the line or whatever it is
since the game and then they have to
assess it properly so it's very
difficult to even see it in your mind's
eye and then find the correct answer to
the question of who is in fact
benefiting from the sequence so if they
got here you gave it as a puzzle they're
like yeah white's winning i'll just you
know stop your pawn before it gets to e2
and then i'm gonna get my queen so i'm
very happy king f3 yeah there's this
brilliant move rookie one actually
oh
you give up the rook for the greater
good of eliminating black bishop
immobilizing the pawn and then promotion
is unstoppable sorry continue but just
thought that was instructed but that's
exactly it because the only
winning approach at this point for white
might be rook to e1 because rook b2 to
stop the e2 push allows bishop f6
hitting that rook and hitting the pawn
at the same time so look at this so you
have to get here it looks very scary
because black's king is so
advanced the pawn is about to push and
mcqueen looks like it might just be a
draw and then to see rookie won not when
you get here you have to have calculated
this 10 moves beforehand
wow
so this is uh how difficult high-level
chess is and for dingley ren he's still
trying to figure out can i get this king
c5 move in do i need to play something
different if my king goes to the queen
side am i gonna have to one wonder and
worry about the king side over here it's
not like black gets five free moves to
come into c3 and white's not gonna do
anything of course white can choose to
play with c3 or alternately on the king
side and can we start
can we make one more attempt
and play c5 here
so c5 trying to get the pawns going that
looks like a perfectly reasonable we can
look into it so c5 from black here and
so many pawns in this rook d1
ah you're trying to take
[Music]
g5 potentially i'm not in the mood to
analyze that but
or even bishop takes g5 he gets wild
okay we
can play d4 here
yeah even though i've given a few
squares yeah and it might be hard to
make progress
yeah just shuffling pieces back and
forth because neither side can really do
much of anything that sometimes how
these positions go
even though it looks like white is happy
with the pass spawn and black is happy
with these pawns here
may not be able to make any progress
indeed so dingler did start with rook to
b8 he doesn't want to commit to his king
march just yet and
well c3 still possible for white but now
i switch and i play c5 or the king c5
and that's a huge difference so we often
talk about what it means to have
subtleties in chess and nuance is this
is a big difference the king isn't
already on the square so c3 trying to go
b4 now i have the b4 square covered and
if you make a rook d1 move to stop d4
you drop your pawn on b3 and if you try
to close the lane then i can already
think about this d4 push and if you
start swapping pawns here thank you very
much i have two past pawns and just like
white sacrifice in exchange don't be
fooled when black does the same so that
these pawns can march to the other side
and compared to the other variation
there is one more subtlety is that your
king is closer to the f5 pound so you
can from d6 uh i can uh protect the pawn
by playing king e6 so if bishop h5 i'm
always in time i can play king a6 right
no this is a great point and and from
that perspective dings move is it's
incredibly flexible he's keeping alireza
guessing
and again i don't like to over analyze
body language but just seems
uncomfortable
he seems like you might be thinking like
am i actually in danger of losing this
game which was supposed to be unlosable
after my opening
so
this is danger time for alireza he's got
nine more moves or eight more moves to
make until time control he doesn't have
forever we're gonna keep a very close
eye
on how this game
continues to unfold i thought that
you're going to say is it actually me
playing this who is playing this
position with white
yeah it's it's going to be a tough one
ding seems to hold most of the winning
chances here but
we'll leave ali raza to his devices
we'll let him think we'll zoom out for a
second there are transformations in a
couple of the games but in particular
i've got my eye on report
against nepo because there's been a
major pawn structure transformation
on that board
and
that's good news for yon for richard
reports like all right now i probably
have to just sit and wait until the draw
happens because black's double pawns are
now isolated with that e-pawn there's
potential to spring for your passer here
the bishop on e4 is marvelously placed
but you can't land any sort of checkmate
threat and white
from all intents and purposes is up a
pawn because we see a three-on-two
advantage over here on the queen side
and eventually when these pawns start
going you can create a pass pawn black
doesn't have the same opportunity let me
ask a dumb question okay what if i just
goes rook h4 rook f4 okay how on earth
are you ever going to make progress here
you're not
and you can do rook h5 or gage 4 rook f4
or you can just throw it back and forth
every square is defended d3 d2
upon majority on the queen side you
don't even have to push in fact if you
push c4 too early you might give up the
d4 square
if nepo had to win this game he would
have undoubtedly taken up the challenge
and played a4 as it stands i'm fully
expecting something along the lines of
rook h4 workout for
amira you think we're just gonna get
some kind of repetition like this
sadly sadly but
let me try and find something okay and
you always do that which i appreciate a
lot you're like let me dig in let me see
if there's something outside the box
that we can come up with
okay rugged h4
okay so black's turn
rook g6 h4 okay work got four
rook g6
okay rock h4
okay king of six now broke out four
kingdom five or cage four
at some point
yeah but i'll play king d2 e3 you're not
careful yes that was the the only
problem with this maneuver that's i
cannot control keep controlling the d
file and uh well and prepare for that
prepare for at the same time
and we have a comment from zipley here
if report goes down in a blaze of glory
trying to checkmate nepo it's a good end
to the tournament chas michael michaels
would probably agree with you uh so
we'll see i don't think that there's
much for richard report to try as we
just showed the rook can slide back and
forth for a report yeah
i would caution chess fans against
pushing back if richard repeats moves
because you have to understand that
like
you know you can't will yourself to win
the game if richard does something
foolish here and loses that would be a
completely unreasonable decision and it
would be completely unreasonable to
expect him to do that so john's played a
good game played a solid game
and i'm fully expecting a repetition
before i move 40. what do they say right
fool me once shame on you for me twice
shame on me so he already
was fooled once into playing on in a
position he shouldn't have and i don't
think he's going to do this john can
smell it
oh as you know me i found something oh
okay all right found something all right
let's do this let's do this almirah has
a variation that may allow richard to
play on what is it well there's this
bishop transfer i want to play bishop g2
bishop h3 bishop g4 and then play h5
but i'll wait for you to do that all
mirror and then i'll play h4 check
after bishop g4 okay so we'll even allow
it to happen there should be two let's
see let's go back
back into g1
okay you're playing bishop
bishop
and it's pointless
yeah that's not not abiding by the rules
king h5 saves the g4 pawn but it loses
the bishop because of the pin here so
this is actually nasty and if you go
back you just lose a pawn the bishop
takes g4 so so my idea was to play
bishop g4 when you rook is on h4 but you
stop doing this
okay i'll put my rook on age four so
rook h4 and now bishop g4 is amira's
idea and my rook is trapped over here
well okay okay and then they deal with
it yeah no i you you found a position
where white could lose so
it's good to think in these ways but i
think that this rook is not going to go
back to h4 even though we did say rook
h4 workout four rugged for workout force
you were counting on the pre-move now
that you're playing some blitz chess
it's like you as black you should try to
negotiate and say like if you don't play
if you don't move back and forth you
know then i'll play bishop gg bishop h3
it reminds me of a story i've told on
stream before
about uh mikhail tsal playing a game
against the yugoslavian gm and bishop c2
we'll get to that in just a second petar
trefunovich who is a inferior player so
trifunovich gets a much better position
tall offers him a draw
and trafunovich famously said i'll take
this draw if you can promise me
that you'll give me a draw in the next
three times that we play
tall was in such desperate straights
that he accepted and if you look at
their games in the database sure enough
tall stuck by his word and the next
three of their games ended in a draw so
in other words you just told the whole
world that tal and wasn't going to
interfere with it but they cheated by
the way bishop c2 by yan rookie 7 i
think he might play bishop d1 uh
implicitly offering a draw you know
normally i like to shoot us back to the
chest but in this case you just told the
story that uh but this is a well
publicized story no i know i'm not
saying you spilled the beans but you
know that goes against the
code of ethics even though we know
players do this all i don't like the way
you're behaving right now
i'm just saying that you know you just
you tell us a little bit of collusion
right
you did nothing you weren't alive i
don't know why you're taking this person
personally i thought you were taking
what are you talking about uh well that
is a funny story nonetheless and these
players here well they're gonna probably
repeat moves as you're saying bishop d1
the rook can go back to d7 and uh black
by the way had to bring the rook to east
oh he had he gave that look to report
that all right let's let's uh wrap this
let's wrap this baby up he had to do it
and yawn
shirt not tucked in he's ready to party
and why
[Music]
rook d7 is first because
otherwise he will play king king d2 can
get through this well king d2 can be met
with rook d7 jack but then the king can
move to e2
um let's start with my plan but i have a
slight improvement over the variation i
want to play bishop g2
and prepare
bishop g4 with h5 first so bishop h3
okay
now i'm going to bring my bishop this
way okay and h5 sure they are repeating
by the way so we should learn to play
bishop before of course therapeutic
moves it looks like yonder palms
to become the challenger for the world
chess championship for a second time in
a row
rich report did his best but his best to
beat janna palms who has lost zero games
in these candidates i guess it's just
not enough for any player in the field
and yan i wonder how he'll finally
express himself because he's been so
calm so collected trying so hard not to
let his emotions betray him will we see
a smile oh and there it is the clocks
are stopped the 20 22 feet of candidates
are won
by yon na pamishi a respectful smile and
there we see it finally allows them yeah
you could see him breathing for the
first time in like two weeks and he must
be ecstatic
i mean to win the candidates for the
second time in a row with a round to
spare tomorrow's round is going to be
all fun for him he has nothing on the
line he can play his heart out and
tonight is going to be a night of fancy
dinners
might allow himself a little champagne
as he finishes his tea
all of the emotion is going to come
pouring out of yarn today so that was a
good pun i'm such a cocktail too with
champagne
[Laughter]
maybe janna will invent it it'll be
called the nepal machine instead of his
oh nice instead of a pure tea get a long
island iced tea and just mix it up but
yonder pamashi uh he is one of just a
handful of people who have won the uh
who've won the second challenge to the
world championship title so uh
some of them have won their world chess
championship match on the second
challenge we know that uh smith's
boris spassky and gary kasparov were
three names who won their world chess
champion title on the second attempt and
for kasparov the first attempt was uh
stopped because that match went on
forever
but there he is that's yonder palm she
that's your 2022 feed a candidate
champion that is your challenger for the
world chess championship for a second
time in a row
and i really hope that magnus carlsen
the world champion will clarify the
situation it's very important for the
players to know
well and for the whole world you know to
know if he's going to play the match
yes right that's the big question
looming over this tournament looming
over the chess world will magnus carlsen
take part in the world chess
championship or will he relinquish his
title and then jon napomshi against the
second place finisher here in the
candidates the winner of that will
become the new world champion well i
don't have champagne but i do have
coffee so this is a tayan for for an
excellent performance and you can
nitpick that performance and say that he
got lucky against rapport in their first
game
and he got lucky that hikaru didn't
capitalize on a big advantage
and he got lucky that alireza
came to the game in a very bad frame of
mind
but let's not forget this is a 14 round
tournament against seven
of the best players in the world you
don't win a tournament like this
with a two-point margin by getting lucky
all the time so jan this is going to go
down as one of his best if not the best
tournament performances
we know that the great players when they
have their great performances they make
it look easy they make it seem like they
didn't even do anything that special
just played normal chess and they won
all their games
and that i think is the genius of jan's
performance in this tournament the fact
that he really did make it look easy and
he made that cliche sound like the best
possible description of jan's
performance in this tournament i think
it's a good point when people start
talking about how all the opponents
blundered and this and that at the end
of the day yonder poncho lost zero games
he may lose around 14. he did that last
time but he's already won the tournament
so who cares at that point so we see the
congratulations streaming in thank you
to everybody in the twitch community who
are giving your congratulations to yon
napomshi i'm sure he'll be excited to
know that many of his supporters and
fans out there but jan lost zero games
and no other player in this tournament
can say that everybody else losing
multiple games so for for yon what an
impressive performance not only an
impressive performance but also he has
so much experience now that he has
actually played the world championship
match
he has a lot of opening preparation uh
still in reserve i suppose and he can
use it and all the energy
yeah no he uh he certainly can so uh for
jan de palmashi his second challenge we
mentioned just before that three players
did win their world chess championship
title on the second uh go around so
young would like to join them in that
illustrious list as we mentioned
smithslav spassky and kasparov but
the other players
still have something to fight for so
yonda pomshi is one participant in the
next world chess championship match it
should be on against magnus we don't
know if that's the case if we take
magnus at his word he's not playing if
we take everybody else who's talking
about it then magnus is playing so who
do we trust the person himself or
everybody else speculating and saying
magnus must keep his title and i think
the chess world does hope that magnus
plays
absolutely we hope that magnus plays for
many many reasons and i'm jumping the
gun here as we have a look at the format
the rules are that the winner of the
candidates janupamnishi is slated to
challenge magnus for the world chess
championship if magnus sticks by his
word and declines ma yan and the second
place finisher will compete for the
world chess championship but
i'm jumping the gun here okay but i
think that the narrative of the previous
world championship
is fundamentally wrong by a lot of
people yan was doing incredibly well up
until that six six game right up until
that 120 move six game loss he had a
almost a winning position i think in one
of the early games
if yon can carry over his new emotional
maturity
his opening preparation his calmness i
think that we might actually see a
fascinating second world championship
match i wouldn't just shovel dirt on jan
and say yeah he won the candidates but
he's got no chance against magnus we
don't know that and i think that that
might sway magnus to try to reassert his
dominance for a second time and almira
we heard jan in the studio talk about
and if every term were the candidates
why do you play so well here my
preparation and if you think about it
he's been preparing very hard since
2020. other players they you know after
the last candidate they're like okay i
don't have a world championship match
they prepare for their individual games
but not to the same magnitude as
preparing for a world championship so to
daniel's point maybe yonder palmici with
three years in a row of intense
preparation in the great form we've seen
him in both candidates tournaments and
even in that last world championship up
to the point where he lost game six
maybe john de palma she has a chance
even if he's playing magnus carlson he
certainly has a chance and let's remind
our audience that the previous
candidates lasted for more than a year
so the players were forced to prepare
even though even that that was such a
long break but what do you do you still
uh work on your opening preparation uh
you watch the games even if you play the
few tournaments online you have only one
goal in mind so uh this
uh how do you call it this luggage you
know of opening novelties i think it
hasn't been used yet and uh he's
certainly going to
um
well to use them in the world's
championship branch and i think yanapop
she silenced all of his critics because
so many people have talked to it he's a
streaky player he does well to start the
tournament but he falls apart in the
second half but if we think about his
second half of this event he survived
his toughest challenge with the closest
competitor against fabiano carwana in
the black side where he was out prepared
he did have a position that was in
fabiano's favor he managed to draw that
game and then what has he done he's just
been stable right he killed game one of
the second half round eight against
dingley red he's played just nice chess
when ali raised a farouza went for him
he's like you know i'm going to come for
the king well you best not miss alireza
frugia missed yanapom she won that game
so
how can anybody say that yana palm she's
just this first half player streaky
player when in this tournament he showed
that from start to finish he's been
number one and people say as we check
out
his incredible second half of the
tournament a win a win more when first
half i apologize
that first round win it got people on
notice he beat ding with black so many
people said yeah but ding played
terribly he's still jet lagged okay he
drew caruana on the drop up then he beat
farouza yeah but farouza he's an
experience draw with nakamura then he
beat duda what do you say now yeah but
he's only won his games with white first
of all no he hasn't round one he won
with black
then he beat rapport
people were criticizing his choice of
the petrov in the world championship and
he silenced those critics as well as we
switched to the second half he beat
furuja on the black side of a petrov he
showed that he knew that opening
backwards and forwards and he could
survive in that opening even when he was
out prepared as he was against fabiana
caruana in round nine so from whatever
angle you want to criticize him yan as
you said has silenced all of his critics
with this tour de force performance in
the 2022 candidates he keeps saying he
loves zero games this is an incredible
field of players and we see look at this
young napoli getting interviewed by dina
bilancaya fans swarming yon because they
want to hear from the next world
championship challenger and i'm sure yan
he's going to smile you see photos being
taken the
chess.com spanish commentary right off
the side but everyone wants to hear from
the new and
once again
world chess champion challenger so
we're going to stay here on this just to
take and look at that a round of
applause you'd love to see that these
fans are coming each and every day
some of them do have jobs so they can't
make it in every single round but there
are fans that are in the playing hall
giving their support look at jan you can
tell it means a lot to him oh he's so
touched and i wanted to say that
probably the toughest opponent that he
had in this field was himself
yeah he survived this challenge as well
and his interviews right and as he's
doing one right now
he was consistent like you could tell he
was forcing himself to remove all of his
emotions chess is an objective game
right you need to calculate you to look
the position in front of you and that's
what yon was trying to do even in his
interviews so the game wasn't just
taking the place over a board with 64
squares for yada pameshi everywhere he
went every single moment of every single
day he was trying to be stoic he was
trying to keep the emotions in check and
he said on his rest day what is he going
to do i'm just going to be in bed i'm
going to get rest i'm going to focus on
the chest and we've seen when yon napalm
she is focused when he is on his a-game
he's borderline unstoppable by anyone
not named magnus carlson and we often i
think people often fail to consider the
universality of his style which is
really what makes him terrifying
he had performances of every kind in
this tournament
you want tactical performances his first
round against ding
you want positional defensive
performances where he punished bad play
boom his win against fruja how about a
defense nakamura caruana right any one
individual game you might say well that
was a fluke but taken together yan
demonstrated mastery in every single
part of the game from preparation in the
opening to attacking in the middle game
to capitalizing on advantages to
defending bad positions in time pressure
we got a little bit of everything and
that is what jan ultimately has to carry
forward if he is to play this second
world championship match against magnus
this total and complete universality and
as you said emotional strength and
elmira there's a lot of talk about when
do chess players peak right we see
players jump out to 200 as a teenager
like ali rates of farouja we see other
players they have our slower starters
and then reach that 2750 2800
threshold at some point yonder pomshy
he's kind of been around for a while but
he was in that 2720 environment for a
while he wasn't a serious threat to the
world championship but now we've seen a
consecutive candidate so is there an
argument to be made that yonda pomshi
with these two great candidates
tournaments that we haven't even seen
his absolute peak yet
well he certainly reached his peak
rating i think during this tournament
but i also think that jan has such a
curiosity in him that he can not only be
satisfied by the game of chess even
though he sees such a strong player so i
think this
this might have
drawn his attention at some point in his
career to well to some other fields
but here we can see that he's completely
focused and he
he really wants to win the world
championship and it's paying off two
consecutive candidates and just so you
know everybody we are going to try to
get yana pomshi in the studio so
hopefully he comes here we know he's a
busy guy we know he's being swarmed he's
probably signing all the autographs
because the chess players they do really
appreciate the fans that are here but
they also appreciate the chess so we're
going to go back into the games that are
still in progress we see some trades
happening in the game between hikaru
nakamura and yan chistop duda so let's
head right on over there where yanchez
of duda he won a pawn in this game and
now hikaru he's
look at him i mean he is speaking of
focused he is ready to play this game
out and black with seven pawns white
with six but white's pieces they're on
very nice squares all throughout the
board pressure everywhere there's bishop
on b2 as well maybe there's a future for
f4 so i like black's material donya but
i like the prospects that white has
playing hikaru is like a game of
whack-a-mole right he attacks the king's
side you you bang that down all of a
sudden he switches back to the queen
side he plays c4 you stop that now he
switched to the center and he has a very
clear plan uh in attacking the d6 spawn
so doubling on the d-file is one option
there is always the temptations we've
discussed several times of also playing
f4 i'm not totally sure about that that
is a very weakening move so
ikaru with a big decision to make where
is he going to seek the continuation of
his counterplay in terms of attacking d6
you could also reposition the bishop
from b2 to a3 so there's a question of
move order there's a question of which
region of the board he wants to focus on
right now but i think he's doing a great
job
all things considered of
producing uh you know serious and
tangible compensation he's got duda
pretty cramped here
yeah mirror it looks like for duda he
might need to bring this bishop move the
queen every bishop to c7 but that
doesn't look all that appealing uh
blacks you know pawn structure in the
center it can be targeted in a number of
ways so
i guess what i'm kind of asking is
despite the extra material would you
prefer to have the white pieces or do
you think that dude is happy on the
black side you want me to admit that i
was wrong no that's not it at all
i'm not certain myself because you know
you offer me a pawn and i don't see any
concrete problems yet i take the
material but then i don't see a plan for
black and that's making me start to like
a car's position actually i like this
plan and what i wanted to explain is
that let's say you play queen b6 i will
play rook d1 and you will play yes
bishop
c7
now that your bishop is not protecting
the knight on f6 and it's far away from
the king side maybe i have a chance to
play f4 here like let's say i will bring
my king right to a place safe square
maybe h1
then i can play f4 that's a really good
point because the e pawn can no longer
move otherwise your king side is
shattered and so black feels overloaded
in every direction right the d6 pawn
needs tending to but as you're pointing
out f4 which we've held back from
playing now is definitely possible and
scary for the black king so
i guess despite the evaluation bar
slightly favoring black it seems easier
for a car to play and i also can
transfer my look
[Music]
a3 rook g3 hikari used well
another maneuver in his previous game he
played rook a3 with g3 against ding
yeah so this comes to my mind which is
why i think
the the likeliest move is queen f7
rather than queen b6 i don't know if
dude will
you know he wants to keep the queen
irrelevant but but the problem this move
is that d6 is now
uh you know not as well defended and
after rook after you on bishop c7 bishop
a3 is a very important tactical detail
might say no problem rogue d8 but
because what's doubled on the default
that paves the way for knight takes c5
and black's entire position collapses so
as you're showing here so if we rewind
to the position before d before rook d8
which is erroneous black probably needs
to play d5 here but at the very least
you can play knight takes c5 or you
could try something a little bit more
astute like bishop b2 and you know
you're like forcing black center pawns
to move and
there's a lot of holes and white's
pieces are there we go bishop f6 cd and
duda's not gonna like something like
this
it just feels like he's much less
comfortable even when he was objectively
better
how good is that knight on g6 the h4 h5
maneuver and then bring the knight back
to h4 it is criticized by the engines
and we talk about this frequently like
if you just look at the engines you made
knight h4 what a blunder what a terrible
move but it wasn't about the move so
much as the idea where hikaru willingly
gave up a pawn where most players would
say no way i'm not doing that because he
felt that the resulting position would
be one that is easier more comfortable
for him to play now that doesn't mean
that yan schuster won't find the
accurate moves and they already are at
move 30. so yanchez up with 31 minutes
for 10 moves that is a quite a
reasonable amount of time but some of
these decisions
are ones that are committal if you start
pushing pawns in the center you can't
take that back so i think that's why
duda is going to calculate right now so
he's not forced to
calculate when it's too late i wanted to
show a small idea
behind queen f7 let's say you managed to
protect the
g6 film okay we'll show this seven
we'll make
a small move
like a3 doesn't matter okay sure a4 so
king h7 with the idea of playing knight
h5 that's how you fight this knight g6
that is extremely clever so i'm gonna
make the move rook to d3 and then
almiro's plan is knight takes h5 because
now you have two pieces aimed at the
knights of queens xh5 not a free piece
queen takes g6 that's actually
a real plan for black and you have to
watch out for that if you're a hecaro
yeah that's a lovely idea one piece of
chess terminology that stuck with me is
a second order threat i think that's
what king h7 is it's a
move
that is itself a threat because it
threatens something that can't be
stopped like once king h7 happens you
can basically not stop knight takes him
i mean you might have to go g4 and
second order threads can be very easy to
underestimate because you're like i
could wait for that move and then i'll
deal with it
so that puts a time limit on
white's play white has to
get on with business and pile up on d6
asap
to uh distract black's attention from
king h7 this will create a lot of
intrigue in this middle game
yeah you don't allow black to just you
know sit on his foundation here you want
to
force upon a d5 or something like that
that gives white some clear threats so
uh for hikaru nakamura just goes to show
that he has no time to waste he can't
just uh try to maneuver and for yon
chistop the knight just came to d7 and
it opens up the bishop his knight can
reroute to maybe a square like c5 and
we'll see how this one continues but
we do have a very very very special
guest in the studio so we will take a
pause from looking at the chest and we
have grand master yonda pomshy who may
be better known now as the challenger to
the next world championship how do you
feel
okay the traditional answer i don't know
yeah
well you keep saying yeah next game next
game now you don't have to worry about
the next game
no i surely have two because uh no but
like last year in the ekaterinburg it
was quite
i mean quite disappointing you had to
lose like this to ding and uh
somehow i like i didn't have like some
real celebration here so i was like so
so happy after holding this game against
maxime but i mean holding in a winning
position probably at some point we white
holding a draw yeah and seeing like
grishok is doing so good against any
but then
i just immediately started preparing for
the next game and
got surprised in the opening and lost
and was like very very sad
and uh
yeah tomorrow i'll try hard not to let
this you know repeat so i assume you
won't allow yourself a full-scale
celebration until the tournament's over
yeah i think this would be like
more or less professional
well it seems like throughout the
tournament you've been trying to contain
your emotions in a box what was that
first feeling after you made the draw
well
i was too happy like okay all these
pieces went off
went off from the board yeah like
especially queens like then rooks then
pawns then okay if i saw this fortress
yeah orcish for
i don't know
rookish four okay four bishops to bishop
d1 so shouldn't be it shouldn't be a
problem
uh
but yeah somehow i felt like
if if there would be a chance it would
be you know let's say the final game of
the tournament i i wouldn't be you
uh
know i wouldn't resist here but
uh i guess yeah overall of course i'm
very exhausted
after richard played played the rouser
was that something that was on your
preparation radar and when he played it
uh what was your what was your reaction
to his opening choice
well uh my reaction was it's not berlin
i had i had an idea or two there yeah in
berlin i mean
uh somehow this temporary sacrifice you
know
maybe you're familiar with novelty i
watched the card
yeah yeah i had quite something in the
pocket yeah but uh yeah but
to speak more you know more seriously
uh i think he plays
i would say like five or six different
lines and i think he plays three
different lines even inside the
sicilians so he plays this two knights
and d6
uh he plays rouser and uh he plays also
i don't know some kind of pose and time
on off and
[Music]
i mean okay i could
expect everything so of course i had
like
i had to repeat more or less okay all
these lines and maybe browser is i mean
somehow against uh
the amount of you now take c6 and play
queen d3 get the same game yes we are
very happy
and against rouser the position is
overall quite good for white but it's
never uh yeah it's never a draw yes so
it was one of the
one of the lines we expected and of
course
uh
i think it was maybe one online sincere
and he didn't play yet in this
tournament yeah so it was i mean surely
it was expected but uh okay i knew this
free line is very solid and uh i mean i
had this
i think i catch a couple of games like
this already yeah okay maybe
maybe also in blitz but
yeah
of course like
if you want to win badly wise you go for
f4 every time yeah against trouser but
okay i freeze like a very solid line
so this was like somehow my prep
i mean
i think uh
white like has very nice plans like 92
94 sometimes yeah like king b1
and uh
i mean somehow this bishop d7 line is
tricky but uh
if white wants to you know to be solid
in the center and the night is solid yes
it's
somehow you don't allow some big madness
on the board
so
i wasn't quite sure what should i do
after bishop before a free bishop e5 by
the way but
i felt that somehow it should be good
because i mean okay like bishop takes c3
is clearly um
i mean i shouldn't worry about this too
much okay like two bishops
i mean of course i wanted like uh
you know another day i would probably
maybe try g4 g5 yeah because it's
somehow
very very obvious ideas but i mean okay
he has like rook c8 bishop e4 so i'm not
sure it's
i mean even after castle i'm not so sure
it's so good after e597 also i closed
the center so my bishops don't work
anymore so he goes bishop b5 or bishop
before again
well so then i saw okay i can like
bishop e5 bishop of six take stakes
takes this one streamer says yes takes
takes
yeah fake stakes takes and then okay and
then take stakes and okay then it's good
yeah no and at this point it seemed like
you know everything was uh you know
solid from your perspective and we
actually caught the moment when you went
to do an interview with dina and
everybody who was watching live
applauded you and congratulated you so i
mean how grateful for are you for the
fans that come out each and every day
wanting your autograph wanting photos
and celebrating you
um
very much
i i believe like comparing for example
to the previous candidates which was in
more strict copy times
uh there were like
no audience at all there was no no
audience
uh understandably and uh i think the
first tournament which with more or less
you know normal uh i don't know normal
uh normal way of uh
i don't know letting people in yeah so
it was bucharest but in bucharest i did
quite quite poorly so no one uploaded to
me
yeah so yeah it's bad just wonderful
feeling and you stream yourself
sometimes right chess is becoming more
and more popular i mean you know what
has that been like for you because
you've been playing chess at a high
level for such a long time but it's very
clear that more and more people are
showing up are watching and seeing you
be the superstar that you are
you mean uh streaming or what well you
have streams so you know
many more fans that's right all right
last time
i made a stream it was
i think it was like half a year ago okay
so no of course during the pandemic
times it was some kind of uh you know
you had to
you had to have some schedule not to not
not to go mad yeah just uh to to have a
goal yeah okay tomorrow tomorrow i will
stream yeah tomorrow i have okay let's
say title tuesday and sony
and uh
all these tournaments but uh i somehow
understood at one moment that it's like
it's
it's just kind of a work yeah it's not
like it
if it's hobby then okay then you just
waste some time
uh basically it's okay you have some fun
but it's no nothing born but for example
i
thought it's like completely i mean
impossible so to at least from me to
do at the same time streaming like let's
say like car or so like every day
and um you know doing some some serious
chest work yes so i'm just
i don't have so much energy actually
yeah so i i had to choose
uh because okay i had so much of
experience yeah like big time like i
don't know 10 years ago so i was trying
to combine
uh let's say esports and uh and chess
and
this quite badly
in both yeah
one more question
from me jan uh what
you know having
being as experienced as you are now
having won the candidates twice
what sort of advice would you share to
young grandmasters and maybe even
someone like ali raza furuja who of
course struggled mightily in this
tournament who so i share now this
advice and next year perhaps you know
next time
we play or we play okay he hired you a
few days ago i know
uh and uh and then they beat me yeah
no
but seriously at some point i thought
okay what was going on and uh
i thought that maybe maybe maybe it's
because of okay i started so well but in
the attic tournament i was you know more
trying to play chess upon like playing
for win so maybe that's quite important
because
i mean for example uh
dink who like had like this super streak
of three wins in a row
and then he said okay but he was playing
for him in this position and it was very
hard to play and that's why okay
i mean
it happened okay happens what happened
uh but uh i think it was
you know somehow the you know the
difference yeah so while he was playing
uh
i mean playing playing chess yeah so he
was like worse maybe not worse but uh
okay for example fabiano pushed too hard
to win against him for example he was
e67 was obvious uh with such an exposed
king okay it never promotes
certainly i mean like can never be worse
but still he existed and okay he
ended up laundering something in the
time trouble because he was extremely
tired okay all these long games
and
also another another somehow was like a
factor that i i think i never had like
six hour game here yes so it was like
more or less every time it was decided
uh
after
i mean even even before the first time
control yeah so it was like
the position was uh already quite quite
quite plain yeah so it was like some
repetition or some
some name maybe that's the trick yeah so
i was lucky enough not to play for a win
here yeah so i just played some normal i
mean okay normal openings uh some usual
openings so i i never was forced like to
push too hard okay obviously this this
all became possible because i started so
earlier like i mean beating like the
maybe the man the main
favorite of the tournament with uh with
black pieces i mean despite i don't know
despite the jet lag despite he didn't
really try to have time to prepare
because okay he he never knew he would
he will play here
until the very last moment and so on i
mean uh yeah maybe maybe it was the big
[Music]
i know the big candidate for me just to
play normally so i have a two-part
question for you
so can you confirm right here and now
that you will play in the 2023 world
chess championship
uh sir you're organizing kids yeah
why are you asking yeah well well i mean
if you'll be planning to if i'll be
giving a chance yeah okay and so second
part of that question who do you want to
play in the world chess championship
uh
[Music]
as i say
literally i don't care
no but so of course it would be quite
challenging to play magnus again yeah
and
well i guess has that do you think that
impacted yourself during term did you
actually just
you literally didn't care and you were
just playing for first no matter what
uh no of course i was playing for a
second yeah
i knew i knew okay i knew okay i should
like take an eye so uh ferrous and uh
won't do that brilliantly yes so then
okay then i fight for second place and
then i somehow okay qualify
uh
i mean it's i think these thoughts could
be quite
you know destructible yeah so you just
start to i don't know
dividing the cake too earlier so it's
it's it shouldn't be like this yeah i
mean it's it's very it's very strict
it's very you know it's very tough
tournament and you know you
um
basically you make one mistake and
everything goes
goes the wrong way like i mean for
example against icarus
e4 from him somehow so i just didn't
take a look at petrov and then he played
d4 and i thought okay let's maybe
deviate from some main lines and then
okay i mixed up everything and then i
was like
out of completely normal position i was
lost in two moves so that's that's a
good example and everything could uh
could go different way yeah so
if you
start like thinking calculating okay how
many points and so on and so on
i mean that's probably what you're
forced to do when you're like trying to
catch up someone but so that's uh that's
also the tough part of the tournament
yeah well we do have a few questions
from the chat sure many of your
supporters uh you know would like to ask
so john do you think that this
tournament showed you at your peak chess
or is there anything you think you could
have done better
no i mean i'm surely shouldn't like
blame myself for playing here some
extremely poor chess but uh i can't say
i managed to
like call some extremely high level
through all the games it was like
some games for like
really good
uh
and but i i can't say it was like some
some game which i like played without
like any necrosis from first move to the
last move yes so
in general there is always room to
improve
but um i feel like uh
uh i mean
maybe comparing to dementia
i maybe uh beat up a lot of a little bit
too much just knowledge yeah
more than a as i say more than i could
chew yeah
and it was i mean it it was really
difficult yeah so i needed to
i don't know rebuild my opening
preparatory maybe some
uh
make some correction about my playing
style and so on so it was
[Music]
it was quite difficult and basically i
just had not enough time back then
so and also i think i
had some very poor timing of my
preparation so it never stops until like
maybe like a few days before the match
and uh somehow i found out that in the
end
i didn't have you know any uh
you know uh
any clue why would i play yesterday okay
i had just completely come on what was
going on like for like four months uh
without any risk okay i was working
and yeah at some at some point okay my
brain just
uh refuted to work anymore well that's
the perfect segue to our next question
yo kitchenaider how does winning a chess
compare to winning in dota
um
okay normally takes longer
[Laughter]
yeah
[Music]
you need just half an hour yeah
especially in classical chess
it takes a while well didn't take too
long in some of your games here and we
have just one last one for you here
bringing that up in a second so thank
you very much everyone who is uh
who's getting involved here we go with
this again richard report on our uh show
he he did it so uh can you can you but
what's uh
what's the backstory what's the trick
what's this no so every show there's uh
something with danny where he goes miss
amigos miss amigos yeah exactly see we
got you to say it there we go
well you know you're going to be
surrounded by friends you're amigo so
john congratulations thanks so much for
joining us and sounds like you may still
need to prepare for the 14th final round
so we'll let you go
i should i don't want but i have to
well this is your 2022 feed a candid
winner yonder palm sheet thank you to
yon and we will let you go now so really
congratulations thank you luck on the
last round thanks hannah
wow wow wow you see the standings in
front of you round nine round nine round
thirteen still in progress jan de
palmasi with nine points out of 13 games
and that is tied with five minute
carwana he had nine out of 14 games
several years ago so yonder palm street
not just winning this event but doing in
historic fashion zero losses as you see
on the right-hand side of the screen and
you heard jokes from him yan he seems
like now he can let it out he remains
serious about the tournament he doesn't
want to end on a loss but it's good to
see him smiling and letting everybody
know that he is indeed happy
that's it's not an exaggeration to say
that he doesn't want to lose in the last
round he really really doesn't these
players are professionals every game to
them is critical and jan wants to end
the tournament in style i think that's a
very admirable approach but we could see
him betraying some smiles you could
sense the relaxation he knows that the
victory
is under his belt and he can enjoy his
game tomorrow you can't but feel so
happy for him he's played such an
amazing tournament to win the candidates
with one round despair i can't emphasize
how crazy that is yeah and there's still
a fight for second place and uh hikaru
nakamura dingley ran they're looking to
get that one as we just saw
i might have an explanation you have an
explanation yes and you catherine burke
i was there
in madrid i was there oh i couldn't go
to dubai yeah and he didn't win
wow so when you were there jan wins i
mean i should have asked you on that
question wasn't on my list but now for
uh you know the future i will ask him is
amir skripchenko your good luck charm
[Laughter]
well hikaru nakamura he's going to need
all the good luck charms he can find
because he's locked in an intense battle
against
uh
to get gotcha
we will have a special guest for you
after this break but we are going to go
to break the special guest is no longer
yana pamshi it is somebody else but we
will be back shortly for more from round
13 here at the 2022 feed a candidates
this is going to be a real-time
breakdown of danny wrenches games all
time on chess.com uh that's cool
oh
in the last month i am playing 83.12.
i'm less accurate than them in every
stage yeah man that that stains a little
bit okay do the more game review okay
yeah thanks a lot okay so tuesday sucks
i gotta stop playing cats on twitter oh
it's because it's final tuesday
[Laughter]
look how many blunders there were back
in december 2020 and now december 2021
1600 don't look at this number
look at look at this number best let's
go to
uh tactics
mates
i'll probably need to work on these ones
yep
every single rook fork that has
presented itself to me i have found no
one has a higher percentage of rook
forks than i do
that's correct
these are literally the night forks that
you i missed knight d6 it you saw it
just now what is wrong with me
i could have done here and then taken
this pawn and i'm winning because my
pawns get held together that's probably
the coolest part about this feature like
these positions against hats
rook there for rookie too
and he plugged his maiden one
oh my goodness i'm awful
timor rajab surprised dingler in with
the unusual but effective knight to a6
right out of the opening ding tried to
press for an advantage avoiding drawing
lines and castling and accepting
significant risk to do so
rajib found multiple subtle but
effective moves to increase the pressure
he himself particularly liked rook to b6
um but in my opinion i don't know after
um the best move from me i think was
rugby six
because rugby six at least gives some
kind of tricks and also
his time was going down and so on and
those pressure is on him not on me so
yeah it seems that i'm playing uh better
in this tournament against the players
who are leading
after ding played the weakening pawn
move f3 rajab targeted the extremely
soft e3 pawn and broke through just a
few moves later with the brilliant rook
takes e3
and what else is a very powerful force
is rook takes e3 which is on the board
no hesitation
taking rajabov's rook would have led to
a killing king hunt beautiful checkmates
loomed king f1 bishop c5 king upon rook
takes f3 and you have a bowden's mate on
top of everything else this would be
made without the rook the queen and the
knight
ding declined the rook sacrifice and
tried to fight on a pawn down but his
king was too weak and his pieces too
scattered he was forced to resign just
five moves later
[Music]
want to play us online or learn how to
improve join us at the number one chess
destination in the world chess.com with
thousands of people playing at any
moment you'll quickly find a game with
someone at your level whether you're a
beginner or a grandmaster chess.com
makes learning fun and easy sharpen your
tactics with puzzles and enhance your
strategy with our lessons by top masters
learn from your own games with our easy
to use analysis tool chess.com has
everything you need to take your game to
the next level signing up is free and
easy join chess.com today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and as we see ali raza farouja and
dingley wren have split the point so
dingley wren moves a half point ahead of
ikaro nakamura in second place now we're
live and you are the secret guest
talking to yourself as usual okay
special guest and look we have aneesh
gear and his son daniel
this is our very special guest daniel
you can wait you can wave daniel
say hi
to us
they're all there though they're they're
saying hi to you
he was asking why you have so many
screens and contributions i think you
can like
cut the budget a little bit because too
many screens
basically they are not really used for
much purpose like these two show the
same positions to be honest i don't see
like in that as well well how do you
think it gets to the big screen ah does
it go through the mountain like that
okay
ah you see very smart he says that there
is no night here but here it is so the
video logo is edited artificially oh
well you know he plays this little find
five differences
like he plays this game with five
differences you know you have to select
and like the picture on the screen and
the background is like slightly
different
so he's giving away the secrets
[Laughter]
also he's going to be asking like why is
there chess.com logo and sort of
adjustable logo like what's been wrong
there oh oh well we won't get into that
right now but uh we might have to switch
daniels if that's okay yeah yeah yeah oh
he's trying to hide from this camera
like there are many cameras
bye bye thank you bye
thank
[Laughter]
all you we're going to bring another
daniel in he loves to stream no he
laughs he always wanted to join my
stream i didn't stream for a few days
he's like when i'm going to stream that
let me go stream this is going to be my
stream well aneesh welcome to the chair
everybody this is super grand master
anish giri who has came to madrid uh you
won a pretty decent blitz tournament
yesterday uh it was not a plan i was
promised uh sort of like a little work
holiday whatever
and uh then they told me there was a
blizz tournament and i thought what's
the easiest way to
like get out of that yeah and i said
like yeah but you know magnus is also
there and uh he's not playing so like um
and like
why would i play you know like not like
we are equal but still like i just
thought you know if magnus this is a
good excuse
and uh
but then they told me yesterday like
magus was playing so see you you know at
seven o'clock there and i was like
okay fine so my excuse was not there so
i ended up playing a tournament but it
was fun well you won so of course it was
fun yeah magnus yeah and i was like i'm
the thing is sometimes i do things like
too quickly like without thinking them
through and when i saw you i was so
excited to see you yesterday in the park
i was like oh come there's going to be
this tournament and as i stated i was
thinking like oh it's going to be even
stronger now i'm probably going to lose
to you as well and i'm going to win my
tournament but i already said that so i
was like yeah see you there it was too
late once you alert me of a blitz
tournament i'll i'll travel 500 miles to
make it
yeah i'm supposed to have dinner with
him but then it got delayed because of
that so i wanted to hang out with the
cool people
i guess anish you know we have one game
remaining in this round first of all you
know yacht and napashi big storyline he
has won the ken second time in a row so
as we get into the chess i guess i got
to ask you are you the least bit
surprised by yan winning the candidates
especially with such a monster score
uh first the blunders looks to bishop d6
yeah that's a nice one because i i see
the bar swinging and i was i wonder what
team is the other it should be six
internet so it's gonna be very nice but
uh let's just get that out of the way
because people are very curious about
that
rook c2 looks good but you're saying
that d6 yeah bishop d6 also like all
kinds of resources were missed there oh
the queen is under attack so you take
mike when i take yours yeah a lot of
queens a lot of uh
things were missed but in terms of jan's
play for sure like a fantastic result
the second second candidate in a row
that he's dominating the previous one as
well he finished with one round to spare
yeah and that's really an incredible
achievement and he feels like that and
he said that he takes it more seriously
he's focusing he's preparing all the
time oh yeah but you know that that's
kind of i mean it's not a moment now to
start uh
you know start arguing with jan who's
like showed an insane level
but that story that you know normally i
don't try hard and when i try hard i
crush that's a typical story but okay
you know like
like someone who tried hard all the time
i can tell you like
like it's not so simple it's not only
about you trying hard you also need
circumstances to work your way and they
did for him but um yeah for sure he is
great and especially uh there's been a
shift in last two years in his play in a
sense that he started to work so much
more on chess and now he's one of the
best prepared players in the world well
before he was banking solely on his
practical skills
after he won his first round gaming it's
ding
did you sense that he had very serious
chances of winning the tournament i said
one thing and that came true i said that
if he's not going to lose
um
a game until it's like really late like
round last one around before
uh my son's really into your setup
and i mean he likes cameras and all that
but he's like okay this is some cameras
some high-tech stuff
but which is a little distracting but
yeah basically uh i thought that
the thing that can go wrong for young is
that he lose let's say a game in around
six ish and then he can tilt because he
has like nothing personal but he just
has history of so he's never lost an
important game six before
oh like yeah i didn't even say it on
purpose but yeah like he has a history
of tilting i don't know if
he would overcome it now maybe but maybe
not but i thought if he'd not gonna lose
a game
he is probably going to win the
tournament because like racking up wins
when he is in shape that's not something
he uh he hasn't done before so he's
known for that and it kind of came true
he generally is very good like in one
one wave one breath you know he's not
really the player who like plays well
then that wave gets broken
and then like by a loss and then like
the second wave starts he's not really
that i mean
magnus and fabi they like they do that
sometimes like they
uh but jan is more like one huge wave
and it either goes that direction or it
goes that direction
and so yeah this one it just went like
that and when young is in shape is
either the best player in the world or a
close second well you say best part of
the world of close second he's playing a
world championship match the best player
in the world magnus carlson you know i
don't want to you have to give away
private thoughts or if you have personal
conversation with him but what do you
think no i don't didn't have that
personal uh
conversations uh and also i don't think
like uh he values me more than a random
journalist so he'll be like i'm not
gonna tell anyone but anish and come
here
so the thing is here's the deal actually
[Laughter]
i'm thinking
to bs a little bit and then play and the
idea is i'm going to get more money beat
my press could be really nice no yeah
but no no i i don't have any insight
magnus
doesn't tell it to anyone i guess
but i think he has the right to like
decide until the deadline it's always
nice um to just drag it out you know how
it is when you guys getting your
chest.com contracts for commentary
you're like yeah danny i'm gonna sign it
what's the deadline then like wednesday
yeah i'm gonna sign a wednesday you
never rush these things you wait till
the
just to see maybe just offer a better
deal
his decision to
suggest that he might not play is open
up second place in this term which is
the first time for the candidates so as
you see here dingley wren he's in clear
second for the time being a car is still
playing yeah ding is finished by the way
he's you drew right digler and drew is
game so he's in clear second for now for
now yeah but it's if hikaru draws he's
also a second and they play each other
what magnus has done in any case is he
has uh brought life back into this
tournament because had he not had that
the whole thing with not playing the
world championship we would by now have
lost all the intrigue right and there
would be nothing to talk about but now
that the second place might be up for
grabs it might bring something suddenly
the race is still on in the tournament
and we're really excited following today
and tomorrow who's your favorite for
second place
uh favorite in a sense why once or who i
think what do you think you cannot say
who you want right both
so i believe
if they
draw both the games then it's uh hikaru
that so if all the games for now finish
in the draw then hikaru takes on the tie
break right i believe so yeah so that's
that makes it probably mathematical
favorite right now because like it's the
most likely outcome in in any sense but
uh his position now looks after bishop
v6 looks kind of nice duda started to
lose a thread he's been doing it before
in this event so he might even win today
but even if not like tomorrow draws a
favorite and then i mean i don't know
what happens if tamur or fabiano uh win
the last round because i think that's
also there and then it creates different
dynamics but i didn't look into but it's
all possible i i think that yahikara
would be kind of i would feel that
hikaru is the one who played the
tournament in the most steady way from
all other players he's had lesser highs
like he has never been like clear second
in the event
but he's also didn't do anything
outrageous he's been like very steady
you know like one game one recap one
game one recap going to park
another recap upload another game like
so like very steady this the same
routine no ups and downs bishop v6 was
missed bishop d6 he he sees he makes it
so like very steady play
hikaru is better typical draws that's
correct yeah this is uh this is
a situation so
hagar will get black tomorrow but a
question for you anish is because this
is like the first time where second
place actually matters they didn't
a playoff in the rules so if there's a
tie for a second then someone just gets
second place and then they get if this
of course if magnus doesn't play then
they get to play yan so hikaru ding
everyone who we had interviewed said
that there should be a playoff what do
you think
not necessarily because actually
tomorrow is very fine what you get
tomorrow if you carry draws this game
you get a showdown between ding and
hikaru
and uh ding has the white pieces yes and
he knows that okay uh if a draw he
doesn't
it doesn't qualify so dink gets a chance
which is like you get white against
cigar if you win you get your second
place uh while hikaru also has like
hikaru if you draw so basically
what i'm saying is that essentially um
the situation is clear and both players
have a chance it's in in their hands so
it's like an armageddon game exactly and
i i think they could already see this
fabric tomorrow is the type that
tiebreak that you want them to play but
this is exactly what fitted change right
because the fight for first place if
there was a tie like we had with
karjakin and karwana that was a tie
break right because kayak in the better
time yeah but now you have that tiebreak
before the tournament finishes basically
tomorrow is uh the me like tomorrow is
that deciding game between ding and
hikaru where
if ding wins he gets it if he carol
holds he doesn't if even if hikaru wins
today if ding wins tomorrow he will take
that second place so uh ding has a
chance the car has a chance and they
have to they have sorted out tomorrow
and if they draw and rejava wins he gets
second place and
i think chess is so easy to have a
playoff for right you just go over reset
the pieces and go play it's not so easy
you know sometimes they're like draws
and draws and draws like one one yeah
and it goes on and then finally you know
like you can say it's tricky because you
say oh playoff is fair
here sometimes such playoffs where like
it's so close and finally it's decided
by some stupid armageddon blunder or
somebody
wouldn't know about those would you i
played i played my fair share of
armageddons and had my fair share of
blunders i can tell you that these
thai breaks like it sounds fair on paper
but like finally it's all can come down
to certain circumstances okay how about
format decisions so the candidates now
it's a dull run robin before it's been a
knockout some of the players rajab
saying it should be a knockout and well
part of the reason why is if someone's
having a bad tournament they impact
other people whereas if you have a bad
term in knockout you just remove you
know you get eliminated and that's that
so what's your take i think every player
uh you should never
question on any decision i think you
should never ask players on the time
control and these formats well they
think that they do now but in a way
every player subconsciously has a bias
towards
intuitive like i feel like yeah it would
be kind of nice you know i feel like to
have no increment like and i don't know
why but actually then i think like yeah
because actually i did well in events
without the increment and i play of
course better without increment than i
don't know grishok and jeb off and so on
so because they are more often in time
trouble so every player has that bias
and taimur of course he has other
reasoning that he tells you but
subconsciously the bias is that he's won
the world cup where which was a knockout
event yeah and of course subconsciously
he doesn't even think of it maybe but
that world cup victory speaks in him and
makes him
suggest that to
i can even predict you which player will
want which format based on their past
experiences they are all biased
including myself so yeah what are you
buyers for
uh
yeah i haven't won the world cup
actually uh either i've maybe come the
closest in the candidates because last
candidates i was close
so i'm kind of fine with the tournament
um
yeah it's better because i like the fact
that when you lose a game you have a bad
day you have a chance to come back i'm
also i believe like less likely to tilt
i'm also less likely to go on a huge
streak like i don't recall when it
happened ever but um
i'm less likely to tilt so when i have
bad games usually i'm like
i don't have a tendency to keep losing
many more in a row or something unlike
let's say uh some other players so
for me tournament is fine as well i
think this tournament's been i just the
fact that okay somehow jan manages to
win twice with a round to spare that
just that just tells more about jan it
shouldn't be like it should be very
close normally just i don't know why
like he shows such dominance he's not
supposed to he's supposed to be like the
best players are there supposedly like
fabi is there ding is there they're
supposed to be really good and they are
but somehow he just wins it for the
margin and one of the big reasons why
was fabi's second half collapse
uh do you think
there is one particular reason that you
identified behind his collapse and if
you had to name the biggest reason would
you say it's more fatigue based or
psychology based or chess something
within his play that you noticed yeah
it's not fatigue at all i think
fabi puts in so much effort always
that um the whole stamina thing is out
of the question i think that that's a
good aspect i think the mistake he made
and the one that he might regret really
a lot
potentially is that
he somehow focused so much on the first
place
that as soon as he lost the chances for
that
he kind of
yeah he kind of felt the torment is over
but he might really regret that because
even when he lost the fight for the
first place he was in a position in a
good position to be second and had he
maintained his composure like deep
inside of course he could maintain
composure on the outside and he tries i
know myself i've had been in these shoes
like you try and you feel like you do
your best but deep inside you're you
feel it's all over and uh
and i think that that's gonna that might
cost him very badly because i think he
was still in a position to finish second
and if somehow magnus does really not
show up he's going to be thinking like
what was i doing actually why am i not
second and not playing a match i mean to
counter that do you think though that he
may find that a match without magnus is
almost meaningless
obviously you want to become the world
champion but do you really want to
specialize would you revenge would you
want to become a world champion if you
didn't beat magnus
uh
but rather yes than not sure but if you
were in that situation would you i mean
i'm really happy with my like uh
yesterday blitz tournament and stuff but
like
i would also be really happy like no i
mean it's better to
like of course it's better to beat
magnus it's like better to have dinner
with a dessert but it's also good to
have like mcdonald's if you're starving
it's like you know like
it's better something than nothing it's
better to have that match and also keep
in mind okay you have the match without
magnus if you win you're some kind of
world champion okay fine
but uh of course very likely the magnus
will want to play you then at some point
and then you'll get that match with
magnus plus you've got all the cash that
you want in that cycle
plus you've got that world championship
title that's anyway goes into the books
one way or the other
and um you know it's like the world
championship title has as much value as
your own level of play like um somehow
we've got some more champions like from
knockout events like panamario
uh i believe and kasumchana from
khalifan uh also vichy was first yeah
knockout champion
i believe that interpal pilot also won
this tournament right but apollo flag
later proved with his play that he can
be dominant right
so
topalov still felt like one of the world
champions one of the legends right even
though he won it not in the
match so i i feel that if let's say
you're fabi imagine and then you win a
match without magnus and then you go on
to dominate the whole year winning all
the tournaments becoming world number
one for a short period of time even
then still people will acknowledge you
as a world champion able champion
also you could argue you know even like
kramnik vishey or tapalov
like you can say okay if kasparov hadn't
quit they would still be not all
champions nobody thinks that everybody
acknowledges them yeah there was vishy
there is vishy there is kramnik there is
topalov kasparov just quit we think it's
okay but you can also say use logic that
no no kasparov would still be now the
best player until magnus you know but
it's just kind of we are now in the
moment where magnus dominates so we are
focused on that but if you take a bigger
picture and what people will think in 10
years it will be maybe a bit different
beat kasparov that's probably special
kramer is a special case but then anand
is abundant to qualify better arguments
yeah like vishi let's say when kasparov
was around uh
he won that knockout but let's say he
never beat kasparov had to head in in
the match
but okay he won so many titles that he
is more than legitimate he's one of the
biggest if not the biggest chess legends
full-time
but what i'm saying is uh yeah a world
championship match championship title
without magnus is also worth a lot
especially if you if you later uh if
your career later collapses and you're
not in the top 10 the way um somehow
ponomarif's career turned out um then
okay like it slightly
gets overshadowed
um and nobody really knows why
pottermore didn't go on to become one of
the top players because he was very
promising as a 18-year old champion
but yeah basically it's in your own
hands to make your destiny after you win
that match and still you would i don't
know what kind of matches it would be
but i guess some kind of good price
point and so on they were like i mean
just history there are many interesting
instances like for example the kramnik
that you said will be kasparov but he of
course lost the qualification match to
sheriff that's a fascinating story also
the story between kamsky you know that
story
kasparov kramnik i heard that um it
there was also some
talks about kasparov playing anand
instead
and
kamsky to paulov
yeah and there was some kind of
potential
yeah
sometimes some of the matches were
created and um topalov also was maybe
supposed to play a job in some there was
a such talk i heard some rumors let's
say and you know there are rumors until
they are kind of happening like this
kasparov kramer thing happened so
sometimes you can like there is of
course now we are again in the period
where everything is like logical and
following the order but there were
periods when there was chaos and it was
fine and kramnik is more than legitimate
anyway and also there's like boxing and
all with all kinds of federation so it's
like we shouldn't be like too much maybe
maybe you shouldn't be too much inside
our own box and like unlimited with our
thinking
and there was a whole caspar short thing
i have two related questions you can
answer neither
or both uh the first is do you think
there is someone in the candidates field
or elsewhere other than an issuer who
magnus feels particularly uncomfortable
playing
no no lately yeah i mean lately of
definitely not me for sure what was the
second question the second was uh this
is a bit cynical but magnus's tweet
about not playing anybody other than al
reza do you think his choice of
oligarchs specifically might have been
at least partially motivated by the fact
that he wanted to put additional
pressure on ali raza because maybe he
was worried about facing him in a world
championship match or do you think
that's way overthinking i'm thinking
okay first of all i think the best
opponent against magnus right now would
be um
an in-shape ding
an in-shape wesley saw an in-shape fabi
i should have mentioned probably before
those by the way uh
and nepal
but without losing somehow
i mean yeah it's not funny right
literally it could have happened
if you had not lost game six yes right
that would be still a tense um so that
that's there uh what i think is with
magnus like i think he is beyond like
our mindset uh we are like
trying to
achieve
certain things
and um he has already achieved his like
legacy and all this kind of stuff and
he maybe really is evolved
his mentality has evolved like he
doesn't just want to win the
match he actually wanted she wants a
challenge right because for us becoming
world champion is a challenge but for
him he's beyond that so his thinking is
different he's not as miserable he's
like oh let me mess up his you know let
me mess up we are miserable
but he's like beyond that he's more like
he would not he would want to play
alireza at his best he would want to
play the strongest opponent because he
has already like
he's like he's you know yeah beyond that
uh he's thinking he's beyond that uh and
understandable because uh he's achieved
what so his mindset is different and i
think that whole putting pressure there
is i think it happened maybe ss bike
like as a byproduct of that right it was
nothing nothing intention and i think he
genuinely thinks that because he also
likes just history a lot i think and he
knows you know it was stein it's lasker
you know blanca and all that and then it
was the fisher carp of kasparov and if
you look at that timeline
of course it's always
like usually it's a guy from the next
generation with a different style
and like um karpov kasparov is a good
example and i think subconsciously he
sees himself alireza potential already
in his mind yeah the image of allies
that he built for himself not the others
that we have right now maybe but he sees
a future alireza as sort of a caspar to
his own karpov maybe in a way even
stylistically subconsciously maybe and
he he feels that
subconsciously like if there is someone
who could logically be his successor
that would be that kind of just part of
this i think that like subconsciously so
you i would imagine that this
that's the reason he genuinely thinks
that this is like the best challenge so
he's trying to write history in a way
and you know i know she'll let you go in
a second but about the chess right
hikaru nakamura he's the biggest chess
content creator so many fans out there
watching and play this game
it was looking not good for him before
now we have a few moves to time uh
control and see w
used in the chat
[Laughter]
like what is about the flower to give
all the stuff is there now it's looking
good i already told you like
dude i he's let the game slip
whoa
whoa i was thinking about this the
entire time we were talking by the way
i don't know what conclusion i came to
um knight d3 d7
i was thinking about that yeah k8
rook d3 bishop
d8
okay oh no don't take 97966 that's easy
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
your date is very stupid so you have to
allow promotion you have to allow so you
go to rotate a2 okay rook they say 2 d8
or e4 well e4 if e4 was the move i was
calculating mostly but e4 was moving i
was calculating i think okay
rook d6 or something
um yeah and i was calculating that uh
i didn't know what it is
dude i didn't take the rook by the way
oh my gosh dude it went backwards he
went knight to d7 it looks like he
didn't even consider it he trusted
hiccaro
oh but now he's just bishop a5 and yeah
just take this one and just penetrate
with the rook
and then knight c7 check you've got the
frustrated but duda is totally gone um
in this game like he doesn't believe in
himself at all that's the feeling you
get
you know when like so he had that open
move 33 right so move 33.
bishop a3
to analyze that yes mr b3 so there is
this before move right yeah
why why not by the way like i mean like
i see the comp says it's good but like
why it's a human also why what could you
miss here i may didn't want to lock up
the queen side and thought this position
would become worse but he's opponent i
agree all right i'm just you ask me why
i'm trying to go so he goes d5
he misses of course he blunders
a bunch of things first of all bishop
decisions d6 he blended bishop d6 and
now he already thinks he's worse and he
completely tilts
he just tilts and he also trusts hikar
of course on d6 he trusts him on that
yeah knight back to d7 he had a little
time he put zero
but that doesn't matter that much by the
way so all the sunflowers in the chat
are nice but
it will come down to tomorrow's game
between ding and hikaru anyway so it
doesn't matter so much for your car what
he does today in a way
even if he wins he still has tomorrow
too but if timor wins we were talking
about that so now it okay that's out of
the way at least for him yeah but
yeah some scenarios of course it's
better to win than to draw that's always
the case yes
um i learned it the hard way but
basically the uh
situation is fundamentally the same
tomorrow is his aim is to hold because
it's not easy
especially with the shape he's been the
second half not including the game
against your job though that time dick
was in the mastering against it went
badly but you know not always yeah now
dink will learn from that game um
and play less
less kind of
direct chess i think he will play it
more slow yeah so if i was your car i
would think of some katlin setups to
rehearse for sure well we're going to
let you go uh it was an honor to have
you but more importantly your son uh on
camera my second also woke up now yeah
we should go here but the last thing
before you go can you say miss amigos
for the fans
yeah that was the best pronunciation of
anybody who said it so far yeah
yeah
the camera to your right you got set
into it
there we go
all right well we had a niche gear here
in the studio we'll let him go thank you
as zakar and nakamura takes on jan
schuster dude so thanks anish and have a
good rest of your time in madrid thank
you good see you i'll see you in tonight
good seeing you thanks again
oh well that was always fun
good to have chess's best tweeter
hanging out in the studio hikaru
nakamura the biggest content creator for
chess on twitch he is trying to take
this one home and his fans would want
nothing more than to see him take down
yanchustapduda who has six minutes
remaining for just a few moves but he's
been making several mistakes first comes
alive bishop v6 then comes believing in
nikaru's d6 pawn push and we had
initiate talking to us that yanchez
stuff he might just be on tilt on mira
well let me see let me have a look at
the position because uh that was such an
interesting interview and the moments
that you spent with the anushka now that
i've seen him uh pushing the stroller i
can say that i've seen it all
uh yes this seems like
hikaru is
it it is shocking to me that dude is
going for this line absolutely shocking
bishop before rook c367 what the heck
yeah the rook is just infiltrating looks
completely lost i mean the engine gives
some chances but
but how did we get there because i
missed you like so uh
they're approaching time patrol so we'll
just uh leave it for the moment but uh
we had
right here big moment where duda could
have played b4 closing off this bishop
from its attack on d6 and that's a very
good move instead he plays d5 likely
missing something in this variation
in the bishop d6 because if the queen
were to just move somewhere let's say
queen f3 then this pawn can go up to b
but even here like d e i mean seriously
rook d this just looks even this looks
completely unclear yeah this bishop is
trapped so maybe he was just going for
the piece but you're right this does not
look clear rook d7 e7 i mean
it's totally anyone's game white's king
is a lot safer
but okay
he goes for this hikaru
you know gives him a pretty pretty big
chance there by sacking the exchange it
turns out to be a great decision by
hikaru and then he doesn't take this
pawn so
and knight f6 equal he he could have
taken this pawn played knight f6 i mean
it's easy
by the evaluation
but these pawns are falling and there
could be a passer for white and e5 is
loose so the evaluation bar tells us
something but that doesn't actually get
us into the mind of the players and what
they may be fearful of so uh that was an
opportunity but knight c5 and then going
right back to d7 there's no way
that jan schistov wanted to allow this
pawn to go to d6 so if this was the
future that the position held for you of
course he should have taken on d5 at
this moment because right here there's
there's no way you want this pawn
two squares away from promotion
i don't know what to say because i'm
normally
i try to be as reserved as possible on
my criticism of flares because as
commentators we have the great privilege
of sitting on our comfortable chairs
we've got the eval bar in front of us
but i mean i think anish was holding
himself back to not even spend a minute
on knight takes d3 and it's not one of
those things where
you can play knight d7 and okay the
position is equal it's very clear that
black is much worse after knight d7
right you're basically
conceding the fact conceding any chances
of winning the game but let leave that
alone
you're accepting a miserable position
for the rest of the game
and why do you do that so quickly and
why do you give up hope so fast it's
crazy to me you must think that this
position is lost but we do have the
benefit of the evaluation bar we had a
niche here so that's another ben yeah
that's basically an e-belt bar super
grandmaster these geary two evaluators
the point is that this rook comes to aid
and even if you get this queen here and
black takes and white takes back i mean
this is not an easy position to assess
because this king could definitely get
in trouble with the knight on g6 here
how great is this past pawn i want to
play a4 and after we trade this is
looking very good with a rook in front
and a rook behind
but maybe there's you know attacking
ideas if this bishop takes an e5 it
stops the pawn and threatens the g7
square and his rook is going to land on
d7 as well so you could see
as we get to
the
position that we have on the analysis
board this could have scared due to the
points like i'm going to lose this
position because my king isn't very safe
so i can understand it now that i've
played it out but you should spend some
time you're absolutely corrected if you
were so worried
about this you should still calculate it
because the game position is that
terrible like there's no active play for
black uh due to spending his time here
he is this palm blockaded but not when
this rook simply slides up the board
this looks really bad for duda this
could be potentially over in like four
moves
yes and uh well i didn't know that there
was another drawer so if he car wins
this game he would be on the clear
section clear second place whoa yeah
that's huge
and you know anish was saying it doesn't
really matter how hikaru does because
ding will have to beat him regardless so
that was his point but for somebody like
team over jabov or five-minute carwana
if hikar wins this game they're
eliminated from second place contention
it will be a showdown dingley ren
versicar nakamura for second place and
then we won't have to worry about this
discussion that we've had about tie
breaks what if you're tied for second
because it won't be possible
mathematically speaking it'll be ding or
hikaru and those are the only two
players who can possibly find their way
into a world chess championship match if
magnus were to decline so young chest of
duda he won the world cup he is the
number one player from poland but this
has not been his tournament and this
certainly has not been his game even
though it looked like it was going to be
yeah i mean
to me
i mean of course for rujo we've talked
about him
many times but duda might be the biggest
disappointment of this tournament
because this is someone who's beaten
magnus in a match beat magnus in
individual games
has phenomenal opening preparation he's
young he's tactically alert
he has good time management normally but
he's been a complete
shell of his former self this tournament
and it seems like he got into his head
really early
the body language you know the clear
negative self-talk
all of that has affected him
tremendously and
it stayed with him for the whole
you know for the last seven or eight
rounds and it seems to be impact him
impacting him once again as this game
nears the time control one move to make
students 54 seconds but this isn't a
gimme it's not like my opponent's going
to capture my piece and i recapture i
make it to the time patrol i get to go
to the bathroom all is good he's gonna
have a difficult choice and hikaru he's
so experienced at blitz chess at bullet
chest that he knows instead of just
trying to flag my opponent there's only
one move to make let's find the best
move because the best way to flag your
opponent is not to move quickly but to
make the best possible move that says
you have five different options and i'm
just gonna beat you over the board no
matter what after the time patrol so
amira something that
aneesh said about yana pamashi that as
long as jan doesn't lose
he's
maybe a top two player in the world and
we've seen him win the candidates twice
in a row for yanchez of duda maybe it's
the same he drew his first five games
and then he lost that game to yon
napomnishi and then it seemed like after
that he wasn't really in the tournament
until he beat fabian of caruana so maybe
losses affect him more than other
players well actually that's the topic
we
we
don't uh tackle
about very often how the players cope
with the defeats because especially the
chess tournaments they have their own
specifics compared to the other sports
because even if you lose you still have
to
well to analyze your mistakes and to
play the next day whether somewhere else
you will be having a mental coach who
will
uh will try to prepare you for the next
tournament they will you will have
enough time
uh in order to um well to grieve first
of all
and to well to be a stronger player
so i think that the players have to
pay a lot of attention uh well to this
problem yeah and sports psychologists
are hired for a reason to deal with
adversity in the profession and some of
these chess players maybe they do work
with people but it does seem like jan
chistov after he lost that first game of
his in the tournament then he started
losing a bunch and
he beat 500 karwana that was a huge
result for the standings fabiano as
anish was saying as hikar himself said
maybe he took it like he had to win
first place and nothing else mattered
but
you know duda kind of helped remove
fabiano from the competition and he
still though has seemed shaky right like
he's
had these games against alareza frugia
looked like he was well on his way to
victory and then he's miscalculating
things that's not typical of the yan
chest of duda that we know danya not
even close to typical i mean these
aren't oversights on move six
you know you missed some computer move
but these are
you know grander oversights even this
game it's not even bishop d6 that he
missed there was like four different
moves that's not an exaggeration that
leads to an unclear position against
alireza there were multiple blunders
and you know pretty obvious ones at that
so
something's just really really off in
this tournament and
you know it
is sometimes you don't even know what
the matter is sometimes you feel fine
and you know you seem to be doing
everything the same way as you do in
previous tournament and yet the result
is completely different so i don't want
to overstate it here and i don't want to
pretend like it's all about psychology
and it's all about your mindset a lot of
it is based on skill and the way that
you actually play
but this confluence of factors has
really made jkd
um
a non-factor in this tournament and kara
nakamura on the other side i mean you
can just look at him right he is
searching the board for a win right now
he knows that this game is his for the
taking and we've had him in the studio
bunch he was criticized for not trying
to take down yonda palmashi but look
what's happening it was the perfect
result for him a quick game before the
rest day it allowed him to go to el
rotaro park and play some blitz against
fans which you know he we know he enjoys
that hikaru nakamura has been a
different person since he started
streaming and people were saying it's
the end of his chess career he can't
play classical chess but as we've seen
here and as anish said he believes that
hikaru nakamura would deserve second
place based on the stability uh from his
play in this tournament so hikaru he's
seizing the moment he uh he did take
chances early in this game he sacrificed
a pawn but we did realize he had
compensation for it and now as he slides
his rook over to the c file yanchustav
duda has to deal with all sorts of
threats including a move like rook c7
exchange sacrifice here just to get this
pawn one step further 43 seconds
counting down for yanchez of duda he
does not look ready to make a move
because his position after the time
which will might just fall apart in fact
i think rook c7 is a pretty deadly
threat
well if we can establish the parallel
between yandere pomnish and hikaru
nakamura is that both players have a
very high quality average move yeah you
simply don't make that many mistakes
that's true and oh my gosh dude it down
to 20 seconds there should be six and
that was the idea of bishop d8 but
that does not properly respond to this
massive threat of rook c7 which is what
i think
hikaru nakamura will play checking that
move 40 has indeed been made always
something you need to do and plenty of
time but i don't know if nakamura will
take too long because having played rook
c3 you're basically
you know
you're almost you almost have to play
with c7 you can't double back now well
if you find a better move to start with
maybe there's rookie 7's not going
anywhere but it is good to double check
your line so yakaru is i mean he's a
brilliant calculator we've all seen his
videos takes takes takes and all the
arrows and you know that's often seen as
funny but in all seriousness
everybody in the world magnus carlsen
through the last you know chess player
on the planet they know how phenomenal
hikaro nakamura is calculating but he's
doing the right thing here right he is
not wasting his chance because he knows
that whether he makes this move in two
minutes or 20 minutes or even he's going
to have over an hour on the clock so he
will have so much time to calculate that
you just don't want to spoil it so
hikaru he's going to think he is going
to
you know
try and win this game is the last game
remaining in the round to remind
everybody we've seen three draws that
clinched first place for yon napomishi
hikara nakamura trying to leap frog
dingley ran the standings after dingler
and drew with the black pieces alleyways
of perugia so this is a really really
important game
if in fact
magnus carlsen does not play in the
world chess championships the battle for
second place is real
dingley wren
his game ended the draw we actually
didn't get to see that so maybe we
should analyze how farouja and dink
ended that game because we spent a lot
of time during the round then we had
some interviews so let's go to the game
between alireza farouza and dingley ren
just to see how the game actually ended
and we left off around here who c3 was
played
and after c5
bishop b5 so this is
i mean
in fact this ended in less than 10 moves
is almost a bit surprising
yeah and the reason it did is because
ding decided that this was as good of a
moment as any to push that deep on and
an idea we had discussed in a previous
position
essentially saved alireza because
without this black's pawns
essentially finished the game so rook d1
is a critical move and a good job by
alireza to not panic and calculate
accurately at the right moment and the
idea of course is to force d3 and to
sacrifice a bishop on that square
eliminating black's connected passers
getting three pawns for the piece and a
dynamically balanced position that soon
petered out into a repetition
okay no i just wanted to ask because if
he would have played king c6 here
because you know the problem is that you
cannot play bishop b1 and activate your
bishop
in any case because there is rookie
three no no no just after the sacrifice
okay yep yes king c6
oh sorry for king size exactly but then
after c4 you can still have the like the
opportunity to play bishop e1
have a damn euro i guess you will play
rogue g5
just quickly note that the hikaru
nakamura yanchez of duda game is on the
top left of your screen that's the live
position where we just go through the
final moves of the game between farouza
and dingley ren sorry amir what were you
saying no no i was looking at the
variation of d5 for b3 rook f5
oh my goodness these pawns are scary
good luck evaluating this
oh zeros of course of course always is
now for the players this is
really freaky to have i would
i mean i understand completely why
dinglery brought his king to the other
side because giving up three connected
passers seems like too much so he was
king to e6 still the same plan by
alireza and then the king went to g6 so
stabilizing in front of this pawn rook
c5 rook takes b3 and now we saw
a repetition by the check so i think
some people would wonder why can't i
just take this pawn over here on a5 and
the point is that rook g3 check is so
annoying you have to bring your king
over and this rook comes to f3 to attack
this pawn to f4 and if you don't make
the draw now by following the king with
the checks you'll lose the game because
it once f4 falls so does g5 and white
doesn't have enough remaining pawns for
the bishop
[Music]
oh gosh go here and
check mate that ends the game
so your king would have to go back and
don't go king f7 because in the rook
comes to f6 and wins this pawn and then
white gets to play for a win without any
problems so you look g7 process of
elimination couldn't go to h7 either
because this check would have won the
bishop and then you give this check and
the king if it starts trying to run away
maybe i push my pawn as well and i have
like all these pawns that can go up the
board so black
taking the draw made a lot of sense and
the half point was split which is great
news for the man you see on the screen
in front of hikaru nakamura i mean the
results today have perfectly gone his
way if in fact he is able to
win this game and
he's thinking with his ear as he's been
known to do oh that looked like a nod of
approval and he's hesitated about he's
moved his king eight or nine times now
he's moving his king he's but he's done
that motion like
literally eight times
so he wants a blinking h2 the point is
he wants to induce rook takes f2
and then play rook c7 he he feels that
that move order is more accurate there
it is and it is
oh my gosh
king h2
he just gets out of any checks gets off
the diagonal
oh my god i mean when he smells blood
it's like
it's like a lock you know you just don't
feel
it's like a pilot in control of an
airplane and there's no turbulence it's
just like smooth you know you can sense
that that he feels that he's got it in
the bag and for a lot of players that
makes them nervous right you feel like
you're winning you start getting nervous
for a car you feel like it fuels him it
makes him search even harder even more
carefully for the best conversion
and
once due to play knight d7 hikaru
like a shark
that smelled blood a thousand miles away
he knows this game is in the bag if you
can play it accurately for the next
couple of moves and what a choice what a
move i think we can explain a little bit
because after we'll bring up an analysis
board so we can show you uh the reason
behind his decision making after rook
takes f2 you still have this move rook
to c7 and after bishop takes because you
don't really want to move your knight
and you can play rook f7 but then white
keeps this rook
hanging out on the seventh rank pressure
against this knight knight can't move
because the bishop the bishop moves this
pawn is also under attack so it feels
like with knight e7 about to disconnect
the rook from the knight on d7 black's
position is about to fall apart and if
you take this rook
after pawn takes here this knight moves
and then this rook can land simply on d8
and there's never an opportunity to
bring your rook over to a8 to help with
the second rook because europe can only
go to f8 where it gets captured by one
of white's pieces so knight b6 the rook
comes to d8 and in another position in
another life you could play rook to a8
as maybe a potential way to try and save
the game so and here king f7 knight
takes c5 check
yes in fact knight takes e5
forces the king away from this rook so
you win that so
these little things i mean i'm sure in
this position hikaru could have just
played rook c7 first but
chess players
they want to be perfect they often you
say oh hey car what a great game you
played and he'll be it wasn't that great
i i think i gave my opponent more
chances than they deserve they're always
focused on these little moments because
in order to be your absolute best you
have to make sure that you fix those
little errors because in this game it
might not matter but the next game it
will
and king h2 is just a mic drop beautiful
move it's it's a mic drop move there's
one more detail i wanted to show go for
forward after rook after york c7 takes
after
dc you could say ah well let me go
knight f6 so that the rook on e8 is
protected and the most accurate here for
white is rook d8
and you might say oh rook c2 and black
stops the pawn
but you can never ignore the king
position and that knight on g6 it's been
the hero of the game all game long and
it's only fitting that that knight
delivers the crowding
crushing blow after take takes if you
want to win the brilliancy prize you
promote first and then you
pick up that rook extra piece and a win
for white
the knight
went back to h4 after getting into g6
went back to g6 causing black all sorts
of problems and yanchez of duda's
problems continue here at the candidates
i mean he is struggling mightily and in
this game i think that he knows that
hikaru nakamura is going to take home
the full point because rook c7 it you
mentioned being a pilot without
turbulence that's autopilot like rook c7
almost pre-movable
i guess you have to rook a7 for black
what a sadness then rook a7
the sad thing to your point is that
white has
white is not in a hurry well you can
improve his position you can play f3
rook dc1 at somewhere dc1 and rook c8 is
going to come there's too many weak
squares and too many entry points so
black cannot keep all of them covered
[Music]
how passive he is
just i mean black
can't really do anything
no just this is resignable essentially
this type of position so i think duda
is he gonna go rook takes up could he
resign here i mean this is that's how
miserable it is that's just king h2 what
a move i mean
again it's
it's such a lovely move it's something
that
is lost upon even myself sometimes when
i'm quickly scrolling through games and
it's like the position is completely
winning it's like all right whatever
you're winning anyway but like those
moments kh2 is a movie that doesn't come
to my mind naturally i think that's why
i appreciate it so much i'm so focused
on this pawn here and this rook c7 idea
but just to have the patience to play
king h2 hikaru nakamura showing why he
is a superstar not just because he's
popular online but because of his play
over the board in classical chess
yeah i mean the name that i that i come
up with in such cases is type two
prophylaxis
type one prophylaxis is when you defend
against something directly so if you
retract in h2
some people if you just go back one move
half move some people might be tempted
to go rook off one rook f3 and say they
become enslaved to the to the threat and
they say well i need to defend the pawn
but type 2 prophylaxis is a lot classier
and a lot more effective in many cases
you take the sting out of the move why
is rook takes f2 dangerous it's because
it creates the threat of discovered
check and by
taking that threat away you free
yourself up and that's what makes rook
c7 possible if your king was on g1 here
rook c7 would walk into raka for chuck
or some other discovery by taking the
sting out of that move you are totally
rendering black's play in black's pieces
meaningless and ineffective and it
produces the most aesthetic effect to me
when the threat is seemingly ignored but
actually it's far from ignored
and it produces this kind of reaction
from beyonce of duda i mean look again
how many times have we seen it have we
seen this
in the candidates it hurts to watch
right this is a young player a superstar
from poland he has been he's received
awards of the highest honor because he
has brought chess not just into the
public sphere in his name country he's
won the world cup he won the supe uh the
event in poland the grand chester event
in poland rapid and blitz event but here
he's left shaking his head because you
know he can't get out of madrid soon
enough his rating is going to suffer
from this event i think maybe his
confidence could suffer although amira
we know his interview where he said he
believes that he can become world
champion one day ever since he's a kid
well but this also helped us understand
that uh players um
how difficult it is to play the
candidates so it
could affect you psychologically
and this was maybe a simple realization
of how difficult it is to play at such a
high level
and to win
even a game in this tournament
so
maybe this is all what is it about yeah
and for ali there is a farouza who's so
young who everyone talks about people
just automatically assume okay he had a
bad first event he'll get it next time
for yanchez love duda i don't think
people have the same expectations from
he's very young he's in his mid-20s he
won the world cup we can talk about all
of his greatest games but i think people
when they see israel here they say they
just immediately dismiss him as he can
never be world champion and that's not
fair to the player we know uh yantristov
duda can be he's the one who ended
magnus carlson's 125 game unbeaten
streak and he's had great results in
recent years and as i mentioned he won
he was awarded the golden cross of merit
in his native poland so at just 24 years
old his brightest chess could be in
front of him but i don't think people
extend the same kind of excuses or the
same kind of explanation for a player
like yanchista as they do for holly
raise of frugia but imagine the amount
of work also that players have
done and
everything that they have prepared in
order to play the candidates and i think
young sister duda worked also so much
he beat magnus in the world cup and then
he comes and he plays this tournament
and game after game he is not being able
like to show his true potential
right
and then people chalk it up no that is
his maximum right we talk about
potential they say these are the results
but we know as long time chess players
and lovers and students of the game and
that student every single day that we
know that when younches of duda is at
his best it's much better than the
performance he's shown here in madrid
well this may be very primitive logic
and i know it doesn't tell the whole
story but i i'm always a firm believer
in the fact that if you can give magnus
trouble whoever you are
that means in an ideal world at your
best form you have what it takes to
become world champion and
in streaming before the tournament i did
mention that i think duda you know
people are sleeping on duda he's a dark
horse and if he starts the tournament
well he's got a serious chance a chance
that people are underestimating i ended
up being wrong but i stand by what i
said i still think that duda at his best
is a lot scarier than a lot of people
realize
um
but in this tournament things got
catastrophically wrong
and in this game i i really can't
believe what i just saw in the last 15
moves i mean he was much better before
there's no way he loses the game
and if he plays accurately he probably
wins it
and total total self-destruction not to
take anything away from hikar nakamura
who keeps his foot on the gas pedal
found one creative idea after another
well-deserved victory but both things
can be true at the same time right and i
think hikaru will be the first to admit
that mike is very honest and we'll bring
up an analysis board just to talk about
this critical moment once more uh
because when that pawn on d6 was under
attack
yanchez uh after bishop a3 yanchez menu
d5 opening the position up whereas he
could have kept things closed with b4
forcing this bishop back and then he has
all sorts of moves knight c5 is a very
normal option a4 can be played in the
near future so
the move b4 i believe if jan schistop
was watching somebody else play his
response would be in
three milliseconds yeah b4 of course
just keep things closed how can you make
another move right
and i'm sure that was his intuition in
his own game but with the kind of the
weight of the game on your shoulders the
repercussions are entirely yours so he
plays move d5 and the repercussions of
this move are particularly bad for black
so it's really just a uh a bad moment
for jan chistov who had the upper hand
had he played b4 so
you know so much can be said about his
playing the tournament but in this game
it's really this moment that got him out
of hand and
denikar nakamura as you said played well
and then yanchez believed him one night
back to d7 and this is where mistakes
come in pairs and
now just of duda in the live position
he's in big trouble so we're gonna leave
jan chistoff to
consider his options
uh he's gonna think for a while because
he doesn't want to resign even if he's
feeling dejected so
it's gonna be a
and you know another not fun day for
young stuff dude but it will be a fun
day because today is sunday which means
that chess.com global championship the
open qualifiers they're every saturday
and sunday so get verified today the
prize fund is one million dollars and
you will have your chance to play
alongside the world's best players for a
title so be a part of chess history by
entering chess.com's largest
event here with the global championship
the non-title open qualifiers run every
sunday through the end of july don't
wait go to go.chest.com
cgc and 2022 and sign up but for now
it's not about the global championship
the player from poland sits he thinks
and he ponders his next move so we will
leave him to it we'll return shortly for
continued coverage by chess.com of round
13 of the 2022 feed day candidates
chess is great for the brain but it's
also fun to play and chess kid makes it
easy to have fun whether your child is a
total beginner or a prodigy they can hop
on and find a well-matched opponent from
around the world at any time chess kid
is the safe parent approved way for your
child to play chess online
chess kid is educational to kids it
feels just like playing but chess is a
great way to learn patience strategy and
critical thinking
chess kid features a comprehensive
training program that guides kids to
level up on their way to mastery this
curriculum is designed to work with
common core standards and global
educational guidelines there are more
than 50 000 chess puzzles and a whole
library of entertaining videos that
teach strategies tactics openings and
end games specifically for kids
chess kid is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds chess kid helps you organize
your students and monitor their progress
each child receives a weekly report card
that shows how many lessons puzzles and
games were completed you can also
organize kids into clubs and send them
messages
chess kid is the online home of
scholastic chess for thousands of kids
parents schools and coaches signing up
is free and easy so what are you waiting
for
[Music]
we always say we are a family the people
who come here
say that it is like being home
everyone is very comfortable here
super engaged
okay
[Music]
everyone wants to know what are the
commentators do on their day off
grandmaster robert hess
attempting
the unbelievable
oh did not stick the landing gonna lose
a fractional point for that
robert
better luck on the broadcast
[Music]
how many brilliant moves have you played
when do you play your best chess
how many games have you won by castling
in the end game
how many opponents have you played from
new zealand
and most importantly of all how many
botes gambits has alexandra botez played
find the answers to all of these
questions and many many more at
chess.com
insights
our new tool that lets you dive deep
into all of the fun and instructive data
behind your chest try it today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we see inside the beautiful palacio
de centonia the artwork just lovely the
players
they are
playing their games in this absolutely
wonderful building every single day they
get to walk around enjoy the sculptures
the statues the paintings and we get to
enjoy the audience we have every single
day international master almeris
kripchenko grandmaster daniel neroditsky
i'm grand master robert hess and to
remind those of you who have not been
here not paying attention or just forgot
that yonda pamashi has locked up the
2022 feed a candidate tournament he drew
his game today and he has won the
tournament so we know for a fact that
yonder palm she will be in the world
chess championship match yeah what an
incredible performance whichever way you
look at it to clinch it with a round to
spare and to do it very confidently even
today's game you drew from a position of
strength and as i was saying earlier
he demonstrated every skill in the book
look at those stats five wins eight
draws and most importantly
no losses and amir you said it from the
very beginning for yon napomneshi
he was talking about not losing you were
saying that you agreed completely and
everyone else has minimum two losses
while jan has zero
well and how painful those losses are
during the tournament i was thinking
like every time i'm thinking about the
defeat it's like a small death because
you're like you're literally dying on
the board so jan didn't have to deal
with those problems during the
tournament and uh i think it's one of
the
key um items to his success that's right
and you know anish was talking about
hikaru nakamura and his fight for second
place because second place could be very
important if magnus does not play for
the world championship hikara with three
wins two losses to this point with seven
draws he's looking to get his fourth win
of the tournament and some moves just
came in quickly after hikaru pushes his
pawn to f3 to save that piece
dude retreats his rook to a7 not a fun
move to play its sole purpose to stop
the white rook coming to c7 so
the rook's going to settle for c6 yeah
the rook can just go to c6 threatening
moves like knight takes e5
this knight is needed to defend the
bishop if this rook slides over to
defend this bishop then that amongst
other things opens up the a file the
bishop can just go over here to win this
pawn directly
black can only hang on for so long
yeah it's interesting that icaru
you know sort of held himself back from
making a move which i think is rook c6
um rook dc1 also looks very good
intending
rook c8 keeping the options open i mean
it's just a completely winning position
you just want to go for checkmate yeah
i agree there's a knight on g6 protected
by pawn h5 you usually should look for
checkmate in the position of this nature
okay here he goes and i i feel like he's
about to grab the rook on d1 oh you
think he's gonna play rook c1 here i
can't tell
you know from this angle which rook he's
about to grab so then be like danny and
pretend like you know his exact hand
motion all right so this is hikaru pose
number 17
uh therefore it's rook dc one yup okay
fool proof calculations and is daniel
watching us right now oh danny he would
be proud of me i'm his protege
yeah or you could say oh it looked like
the way his hand was going to grab the
piece he wasn't grabbed from the top
which means a rook slide up the board
right wrong
sliding through well you know i i did i
did thing where we see him but then his
side against rook c6
rook c6 is just i mean
very straightforward so i
rook c1 how could you complain about
that but you're spoiled for choice here
and
hicara knows that jan chistoff probably
doesn't want to look at the position but
he is digging deep he is trying to stay
in this game and hikaru he knows how big
this moment is because he came in for
the interview after his game against
janna pomache which he drew and said
if second place means something i want
to have a chance at it and if he wins
this game he's not just gonna have a
chance he has uh the inside draw he will
have more points than dingley wren he
will be in clear second for the first
time all tournament and that could mean
if magnus doesn't end up playing that we
have hikaru nakamura in a world
championship match
and
hikaru as you said realizes the gravity
of that and i i loved anish anish's
description of his game against gary
assuming he wins this game which is
essentially an armageddon because
there's an
armageddon
format built into it and no actually it
looks like rick c6 is the movie i
thought so that he's intending yeah why
didn't you say something yeah because i
wanted you to
impersonate danny of the same first name
so yeah rook c6
is
one
that's a quizzical look by him right
i wonder if he's saying like is this too
good to be true is there something crazy
that i'm missing but it's impossible
that he's missing something just look at
black's pieces
and how quickly this happened to
yanchustaf duda he didn't play b4
earlier when he could have he then
brought the knight to attack a rook but
didn't take the rook just moved his
knight back as the car looks away and
calculates uh as he stares at the
ceiling he knows that this game is in
the bag you just can tell by a car he's
still working still calculating but he
doesn't want to have this game be like
his win over carwana well remember he
had to win that game a few times
completely winning position five no
shocked him with his h3 pawn push and
then hikaro had to find a way out and
into a winning position so that's the
last thing you want when you have
this overwhelming advantage so hey karu
he is not going to move until he is 100
certain that it's a good choice
yeah he's switching poses there
i was wondering uh if hikaru would have
played rook c7 rook a7 was uh due to
some tensions anyway
uh interesting so just to try to trade
rooks on the seventh rank probably yeah
that even if
this rook went instead instead of king
h2 you know
if rook f2 that would be a transposition
but the focus is seven then abdullah
would have played okay seven anyway so
rook c7 you're saying maybe rook a7 just
to get this piece off the board
but i'm guessing you can even just take
here and then go back to the seatbelt
with this rook it's just
ugh
i think rook c7 probably was winning but
maybe hikara was worried about that's
actually why dude kept his rook on a2
bishop takes and then knight b6
and again the key is to meet rogue d8
with rook aiden he car's the kind of
player who just doesn't want to
you know you don't want to get your
hands dirty here you don't want to
unbalance the position unless you
absolutely need to even if there is a
win here
so
hikaru is trying to win this game with
minimal
chances of you know a second fabiano
moment as you said happening that's
right so
we see rook c6
threat knight takes e5 uh this bishop
would love to sit on d4 protect the e5
pawn closing the d-file but as soon as
the bishop leaves this rook can just
slide up the board to c7 amongst other
good moves and
the problems are everlasting it's just
there's nothing that young schuster can
do and probably the worst part is he's
not even up material for his troubles
it's even pawns black's pawn structure
is worse white has a pass pawn
the knight on g6 is amazing and will
help threaten all sorts of checkmates so
for
yon shistov it's just one problem after
another and yeah you can look at look at
him i think he just kind of slapped his
elbow and his
there's nothing here for him
i mean that's why i found knight d7 so
unbelievable because
it would be one thing if icaru had
sacrificed a piece and you know yon
kristof thought well if i can
consolidate my material advantage then
i'll be winning but because material was
equal he knew what he was signing up for
there's nothing that has changed
structurally in the last seven moves i
mean he car has made a bunch of super
accurate moves
but
this can't come as too big of a surprise
for jan krista maybe it is the case that
he just underestimated the speed at
which shikaru would impose this complete
and utter domination over him but
resignation is becoming increasingly
likely even on this move
yeah i mean
do you even need to say anything when
you have that angle
and if we play bishop d8 back
in this position just to resist
a little bit longer
rook c8 maybe roxy pinning everything
looks
good as well roxy one rook c7 is also a
huge threat here
but knight b6 rugby 97 you simply take
on b5 yeah i can just start making
everything vacuum up the puns and then
this one's next and that's the problem
for yon schuster's position is maybe he
can stop one threat but he's not up
material so as soon as he loses one pawn
now he's down he's down a piece and then
the second one is hanging these are
double isolated e pawns
oh my goodness i feel like yukari would
win this even if you had one minute on
the clock
without increment
just you know 17 moves making one minute
it feels like white's play is so easy
here and for yanchez he knows that the
position
is worse than bad and he also doesn't
seem like he really wants to make
another move nope trying to will himself
to do so
and well it's going to be
a really big result for
hikaru
because he
has if with a win he will be able to
take control of his own destiny go into
clear second place and we actually have
an interview that dingley rent did with
dina bellancaya before he knew how he
kara's match was playing out
ding appreciate you joining how
frustrated were you when you saw this
scotch four nights on the board
yeah he played the opening very quickly
and
i when i saw nice history
i guess my he might go for a draw and
actually
yeah he followed the game played by
nepal
but i
uh
i divided from this game and i tried to
play something new
and yeah h5 was risky but
i think
after
sacrifice upon
i should i should be it shouldn't be
worse
but
in the end it became very tricky and
it seems neither side have the
way to
impression until he plays c3 to actually
allow me to have the past pound and he
sacrificed a bishop
instead of c3 maybe he can also play
bishop h5
and maybe ask i have to wait
and i don't see any progress made by
both sides
to be honest our commentators were
praising a lot the way how you played
the endgame and indeed you managed to
create a lot of chances to outplay your
opponent so to be out of nothing um
were you expecting the bishop sacrifice
at the end
yeah
when he played c3
maybe a bishop of sacrifice became the
idea of hit
otherwise if we take on d4
it might be very dangerous for him but
after sacrifice bishop on d3 it's a
clear jew
do you have any particular last
words to say perform
so far let's say compared to
to the candidates of the previous
edition
well he played as good as last time
last edition
and also this time lied
he saved
two words possession with black pieces
and then all he plays
well and sound
and
yeah
all right ding thank you so much
thank you so much
we heard from dingley wren who currently
sits alone in second place at least
until this game of the card nakamura
finishes but no matter the result
dingley wren controls his destiny he
gets the white pieces against ikaro
nakamura and with three wins already in
the back half of the tournament he's
gonna look to make it for almira
well but for the moment he has never
done it
well he never won a game against hikaru
and i think that hikaru
uh
will be so inspired after today's game
that he will be literally flying
well donya no wins for dingley run
against hikaru but this is a different
icaru seems to be a great form hikaru
but dingley wren he knows what he has to
do so he's going to go all in he's going
to go all in but
and he's going to try to learn from his
very painful experience with timur
i think the opening tomorrow
as yet another incredibly accurate move
is blitzed out by hikaru eliminating
black's only good defensive piece
but he's going to learn from his lesson
he can't force it and the opening is
going to be the most important stage of
the game tomorrow i think if dean can
get a comp all he really needs is a
complex position he cannot expect to get
a big advantage
given hikaru's amazing preparation so
ding has to strive for a position in
which his king is safe
a position that caters to his strengths
and if he can do that i think he's got
chances to win the game but hikaru's
play has been supreme in the second half
of the tournament this
entire tournament really the first time
those two played hikaru nakamura had 25
moves of preparation dingley ran played
perfectly in response and was able to
make a draw with the black pieces and
speaking of perfect play as daniel just
mentioned hikaru has made his move he
played the move bishop from b4 to d2
here against yanchez up dude as zakar
wants to win this game and go to seven
up points but bishop d2 i mean just
perfect move by hikara and the reason
why as we bring up some analysis here is
the bishop goes to d4 hikaru wants to
follow that bishop to c3 now the bishop
can't really move elsewhere because you
lose this pawn right here on e5 and if
you trade bishops then you're never
going to control the c7 square e5 silver
means a problem and actually you can
pre-move rook c7 because there's no way
black can stop it
yeah and again that knight on g6 just
towering over the whole position as my
first coach would say like the position
would be unclear without the knight
without one of the rooks with equal
material
there's not much to to talk about
but why can't you play bishop c3
immediately what is the difference
between bishop t22 and bishop c3
so playing it first
you probably can yeah but there's no
threat of knight takes e5 at least for
the moment because of bishop so you'd
have to move your king out of the way
first and bishop d2
there's a funny line like bishop d2 if
black plays bishop d4
then you play bishop c3 right black and
played bishop e3 but now you've gotten
that position up at tempo and you can
play king h3
and
then e5 is e5 falls and
you know the whole position collapses
and just another example of how in this
particular game
the single tempo probably isn't so
meaningful but the players they still
want to be as accurate as possible so
hikaru nakamura plays bishop b2 as soon
as he sits down back in the board we
expect him to bring this bishop to c3
offering the exchange of bishops and
then his rook will
land on c7 when the time is right if you
start with rook c7 this bishop can come
back to b6 white is still
winning this position because you can
trade rooks put your rook on c1 and go
forward from there or even play bishop
c3 right for this pawn so hikaru he is
spoiled for choice but he doesn't want
to give
even a semblance of counterplay to
yanchistov and there he goes bishop c3
and you know what i really like
about the way car is playing this also
for our sake he's not taking too long
you know he car was very confident but
he takes his time
he checks stuff he double checks stuff
but he doesn't go overboard and i think
that's what also makes him so scary to
play he plays certain moves fast and
very very rarely to see blunder because
he's played too quickly that almost
never happens so it's just impressive to
watch it's a well-oiled machine
and his time management is just one of
so many skills that makes him such a
difficult opponent for virtually
everybody and
if when hikaro wins this game he's gonna
have seven half points out of 13 rounds
that's an incredible score that'll be
plus two and in most other candidates
that would be a fight for first but it
just goes to show how amazing yonda
pomshi has been his performance is
historic nine points in 13 games and
as you were mentioning earlier donya you
could call some of the game's luck some
individual moments this or that but his
overall tournament performance should be
louder i mean though it was
unbelievable from jan napomji that even
when fabinho car wanted five points out
of seven games that normally is first
place yana pomshi had more points hikaru
nakamura about to have seven nap at
13. a great showing against this caliber
of opposition
not even close to first place so jan
deserves
the most amount of credit and then some
and for yon shistav duda you know he's
sitting here shaking his head thinking
about what could have been because in
round one he was kind of gifted the best
possible position you could ask for in
the first 10 moves against richard
report he was not able to win that he
still was playing good chess but maybe
that was almost a foreshadowing a sign
of things to come that what he needed to
be accurate to keep his advantage or to
hold on
this tournament is so tough that if you
don't find those moments you're not
going to get a second chance and also an
interesting fact you know that yam
nippon she
if we take his results before this
tournament he was scoring only 50
percent against the field that's why
actually you know he was not uh given uh
uh that many chances uh
before the tournament to win it
but let's have a look now
i think that he's telling everyone look
at me now because i the first one wasn't
a fluke and no more can people say jan
won that
2020 2021 candidates because the
tournament stopped he wouldn't have won
if it hadn't stopped that was the story
line that was the undercurrent before
the world chess championship and now 14
rounds in a row a grueling format
playing against superstar chess players
and he said i'm going to leave you
behind in the dust
anger and you know
the the desire for revenge is a great
motivator and
jan's obviously very uh
a great guy like he
i think there's many things that fuel
him and motivate him but all of the talk
after his world championship against
magnus this has got to feel so good for
him just proving everyone who jumps to
conclusions on the basis of a tiny
sample size proving those people wrong
and you know once he won that first game
i think he already could smell that he
could prove those people wrong so it
motivated him throughout the tournament
and it's got to be just a grand feeling
for jan to prove a this first
candidate's tournament was in a fluke
and b that his match against magnus
wasn't the yanupanishi
that
is at his best and wasn't the
yanupamishi that he wants the people to
know and remember
and aneesh said that you know once yonda
palm she loses a game it's a very
different yawn
compared to when he's on a streak so
his highs are as high as anybody
on the planet honestly
you know magnus carlsen
with
tremendous amount of respect to him you
couldn't expect him to come in here and
go 9 out of 13 against this field he
would very likely win the tournament he
is the best player on the planet no
arguments there but nobody can expect
any any player to come in and go
with this kind of score i mean five and
a half of the seven
against the field to start that's
unheard of it was actually the first
time this has ever happened
well and
if he draws tomorrow i think that will
be uh the best result ever in the
candidates achieved in the candidates
tournament they will so
just so much much to talk about with
respect to jan de palmashi and
i guess the one question we should have
about this particular game is yanchez if
they're even going to make another move
his body language suggests that he wants
yeah but then he makes a move yeah he
seems like he's going to resign for like
eight minutes but look at the chair
there's no jacket on the chair which
means he car is wearing it might be
yeah we know what that means hikaru puts
the jacket on the game is over so young
chissed up he could stare at the board
he could stare across the chair but now
that a car is wearing that jacket he
knows what time it is
it's time for duda to resign i mean
there's
there's simply nothing left to do
and icaru has left the board he's bored
he's left the board because he is bored
he knows the game is over and
he's waiting for dude to resign walking
around the playing hall
it's never no i wanted to say that he
already has his headphones on you know
he is running into his he's got his car
keys in his pocket yeah that's his hotel
room and he's streaming
it is a really great feeling though i
mean you know on the opposite side of
heartbreak often is
this great feeling of playing a game
where you overpower your opponent and
that should bode well for his chances
tomorrow against dingley ren he has the
black pieces he needs to hold a draw but
the type of chess hikaru has played
in this tournament he had the first
round against five minute carwana just a
good game by fabiano you can criticize
zakar's decision to castle sure but a
really nice game by fabiano his loss to
hijab of i think a great opening
decision by rajab and then hikaru didn't
quite recognize how much trouble he
might be in after the pawn was lost in
the a file but
those two games were not great but not
terrible right he hasn't had these
terrible moments and you know as we see
on screen now he beat fabian in the
second half he beat farouza and he
hasn't officially won against duda but
you might as well pencil that in because
dude is about to resign so yeah yanchez
stuff he plays bishop e3 but uh he knows
that this one is about to conclude but i
was going to say
that for hikaru i mean he has really
played excellent chess where you don't
look at a single game of his and respond
with what was he thinking there i mean
there obviously were moments that have
no chess player can play perfectly but i
think the
overarching theme of his tournament has
been strong stable play
and also what a great feeling uh
is that you're playing for so many
people who are watching you
it's
hikaru's community is
growing fastly you know and he's not
alone
and every time we
leave the palacio de centonia there are
so many fans there waiting to swarm the
players to get autographs and photos and
most of them are for that man there
hikaru nakamura and he's been very
generous with his time and with the fans
and he after his short draw on
friday against the underpass he didn't
have enough chess he went to the park
and played against anybody who wanted to
take him on so can't resist the good old
fashioned park session exactly right
none of us can you know especially
growing up in new york you uh you love
to play people in the park right that's
uh what he grew up on so did we talk
about a
who also played in the park yeah we
talked about she made the opening move
and she beat magnus carlson in just 19
moves yesterday in the park that was
awesome to see so anytime judah plays we
know she's retired but we're always
happy when she comes out of her
retirement to take on certain world
champions
but hikaru he's established his
dominance over online chess and one
thing he's mentioned in the
in interviews that cannot be
underestimated is that he
the reason his fan base and his viewers
give him confidence isn't just because
they celebrate when hikaru succeeds
which is most of the time
but that they support him
unconditionally and that they enjoy
watching him for who he is not just
watching hikaru when he wins and i think
that
is a feeling of great relief it's a
feeling that tells you
i can do badly in any individual game
and i'm still going to have i'm still
going to come home to a group of people
hundreds of thousands of people that
support me uh whether i win or lose and
that really has elevated ikar's play to
the next level and just you can just see
the confidence in the way he's moving
the types of moves that he's making the
way he plays in bad positions even in
this game it seems like he's winning
even when he's losing yeah he sacrificed
a pawn
early on
and he had compensation for it no one
would deny that but he shouldn't have
been better and something went wrong
with jan chistop's calculation with
decision making in a critical moment
that allowed hikari to get the upper
hand but hikaru knew that
he was coming today to win this game i
think it wasn't really a question for
him of how he saw this game going but
now he's in a position where he's going
to win upon he's going to maybe promote
and he is in fact going to get that
victory that he covets so much and we
have to ask him if it was a sacrifice
whether it was a sacrifice or a knight
h7 you mean yeah
and you know he's going to be honest so
that's that's the good thing about
talking to caro he wouldn't sugarcoat it
even if he missed it yeah
and i mean this is really hard to see um
i i don't enjoy looking at yanchez duda
feeling this way such a fantastic player
you don't qualify for the candidates by
accident you don't beat magnus carlsen
in the world cup by accident you don't
end
magnus's winning streak actually
unbeaten streak by accident you don't
win the grand chest or rapping and blitz
mistakenly you don't almost take down
the world blitz but losing a tiebreak
game to maxine barcher legrov mistakenly
this is
a fantastic player a superstar but
somebody
if janna palms is going to run away with
it somebody's going to have to be in the
bottom of the standings and alireza
fruga yonshi stuff due to first timers
here in the candidates unfortunately
they're the ones who find themselves
struggling the most
yeah
and
resignation will come literally any
second i expected it a couple of moves
ago but
you know he's just coming to terms with
the fact that
he's demonstrated
very disappointing form at the worst
possible moment and i completely on the
same page with you
you know some people they experienced
some shot in friday but i'm not one of
them this is just painful to see
you know it's painful on behalf of his
fans and he's got a lot of them
and that is the nature of chess like
that is the nature of a game
uh in which you're fighting every single
second on and off the board there's
great joy great pleasure euphoria
and then there is tremendous pain you
can't have one without the other and in
any given tournament like this
you have players who experience both
types of emotions both types of emotions
have reason to exist both will always
exist as long as chess is the beautiful
game that we all know and love
and he's swiveling in his chair and he
is ready to resign so
uh
you know he's probably thinking not just
about this game what could have been
previous games as well
and
you know as a chess player
i feel for him right he's played some
very good moments throughout this
tournament even in this game he was
playing
excellently to secure an extra pawn and
then uh you know continue with the
advantage and as a human being it just
it just stinks you know someone has to
be at the bottom of the standings just
like someone has to be at the top but
you you know we've seen the bright side
of young stuff dude we showed a clip
when he won a speech his championship
match and his mom came in and you know
gave him a huge hug so
you know we we
know the happy moments um but for young
stuff it's happening in the biggest
stage in chess like the most important
turn of his career and we just hope that
after this tournament is done he's one
more round left that he can
take some time and then rebound and
there's not much time before the
olympiad and he leads the polish team
yes
that's why i was talking about uh how
difficult it is for chess players to
realize like what else should i do in
this situation i've been working on
chess
non-stop eight to ten hours a day maybe
since i was a kid
and this is still not enough
and that
undoubtedly feels terrible for people
when they realize that you know
sometimes
even if you put all the work in all the
energy that magnus carlsen still exists
and he is the best player on the planet
until someone can
prove otherwise oh my god they're both
swiveling but for different reasons the
car's bored
he's just all right let's let's go to
dinner i want my paella he's waiting for
the resignation he's slinking in his
chair his jacket's on his ring
we know that ring he's won a you know
just five u.s chess championships so
hikaru
he has a
youtube recap to make so he's probably
thinking about how he's going to start
that show
yes he is
and
you mentioned something earlier that i
just want to reiterate which is that
of course cicara makes mistakes like
everybody in this field makes mistakes
and you can count the number of mistakes
but it's really the type of mistakes
that are most important to focus on and
hikaru i think maybe of anybody
with the exception of jan this
tournament but in general i think
hikaru's blitz success
can be observed in through the lens of
his classical games as well take the
complex and critical moments i think he
makes the fewest mistakes of anybody in
critical moments moments where
there is a big difference between the
top engine move and the second engine
move i think that's the most formal
definition of a critical moment one of
them occurred when duda didn't play b4
right b4 led to a big advantage for
black d5 led to equality how did the car
respond cd bishop d6 rattled off six or
seven top moves in a row and another
player who we say the same thing about
him dingley wren who before this event
was perhaps seen as the biggest
challenger
to magnus carlson throne he usually is
super precise but maybe the moment got
the better of him against team over java
and that's a game he'll
presumably regret for a long time
because of the white pieces against
rajab he played one of the worst games
of his life i mean he just lost all
sense of objectivity he was playing for
a win and you can't force a win out of
thin air not in this tournament not
against his field and really against
most grandmasters you can't and
i guess it could be because of the
events that ding was playing beforehand
he was playing in these small round robs
in china one of the events the highest
rated player wasn't quite 2600 he's just
beating everybody left and right so
practice is important but also practice
against the level of opposition that
you're about to face is even more
important and so ding
he was a last-second
invitee to this tournament didn't get
the months of preparation and didn't get
the practice that the other players did
and the move has been made in that in
this game
it hasn't updated quite yet but i think
it was a pawn move
was it b4 and we have a great camera
angle there and there we go it is b4
okay and how does that help
at all bishop takes before and back to
c3 you can take this one you can take
this one
i guess bishop takes before he wants
bishop d4 maybe
and then what you're saying i can't go
bishop back to c3 not that that's
like
a remotely a problem you can play half
four for example and undermine the
bishop and win another fun and nicara
wasting absolutely no time
grabbing that pawn
now this is
i mean this is there's no
i would like to crawl into hikaru's head
for a day
and i think he's now i have an answer i
was gonna say i thought he stopped the
clock but no he continues
back to c3 rook to v8 just go right back
to c3 and
win this pawn i mean it's really time to
resign here because another thing is
bishop c3 rook takes b
rook takes b3 there's just mate yeah
or or
i guess you can take on d7 too
well there's always rook takes e7 if the
rook leaves the back rank there's rook
c8 going for that checkmate that you
mentioned but i want to show this tactic
here because the knight fork on a f8 the
king comes back you take this rook his
bishop is captured there's a problem and
it's this past pawn here so just take
this pawn white's up upon has a passer
has all sorts of back rank checkmates
against this king
the
deal is done
yeah
which is actually very forcing you could
yeah and then you go back back around
and
orchestrate the mating procedure
and again ikaru takes time very wisely
he doesn't take too long but
you know
he only gets
one chance and the nature of
chess is that
there is no such thing as a guarantee
there really isn't and the people who
don't understand that
they they learn it at some point the
hard way and the experienced players
have already learned that lesson
way too many times and there's bishop c3
and resistance is completely pointless
another nice move but
in
chess you only have one result right
your result is your result so whether
hitcar
does this in two minutes from now or 15
minutes from now the point is he needs
to get the result that's all that
matters at this stage so uh he put his
jacket on which you know means the game
is over and both players know that the
result is not in doubt but as
dianchestav duda makes just a couple
moves here and there trying to
find some hope
we know that hikaru he's a tactical
wizard he's just going to find the
way to win this game i mean rook c8
there's rook backwards well there's a
very nice win roxy rook b8 and then rook
i actually think hicaru
he likes the forcing line so rook takes
b8
knight take speed and d7
is very pretty
just to show why you take this
the rook takes and once again and we've
seen that before of course
with a fork winning this piece and
winning the game up a full minor
yeah so that's
the first item on the menu and the
second item on the menu is just the
immediate rook takes d7
followed by as you showed knight f8
takes d7 takes e5
back to g6 i like me
it leaves no questions right
yeah this line here is
for sure good for white but then you
have to
you know play a few more moves to win
the game but if you win a full piece
right then yanchez just gives up so i
like rook takes b8 followed by d7 i
start rookie first and after rook ba
only move
we're going to change mate and then this
takes and d7 it's really nice line
yeah
i'm quite confident actually that this
is what he will go for
and
hopefully
the agony will end here
for jkd once he once he goes down this
line
i mean it's
just a full piece up
and then the entire
storyline for tomorrow will be he car
with the black pieces against you know
dingley wren who needs to win and
dingley ren's second half has been great
right in the first half he wasn't doing
so well he lost the first game drew the
next six but the second half he became a
different player but hikaru you know he
also has seemed like a different player
in the second half because he scored
important victories he's been able to
rebound from losses when they happen so
in beating fabiano karwana
at the start of the second half and now
taking down
yanchez of duda
it feels like acaro you know
he's just
playing some of the best chess that
we've seen from him and it's coming at
the right time
it really is and i wouldn't i also
wouldn't sleep on nepo's game tomorrow
he's given the opportunity would be
happy to to make a quick draw i would
imagine
but
if he's played like he's played with as
much on the line as there has been
imagine how he might play with nothing
to lose at all with the pressure taken
completely off so i'm expecting actually
a very combative game and if you're a
real chess fan you know you watch
tournaments to see the beauty
as well as
the sport of resolve the sport of
elements so there's a little bit of both
tomorrow there's the battle for second
place between ding and ikaru there's
also the question of how jan and pamisha
will end
this historic performance because trust
me he does not want to end it with a
whimper
and igaro
okay let's let's go let's end this rook
c8 yeah he wants to move that rook and
there he
is yeah there it is
i told you to go rick see it he and this
is like very elegant because as you said
it it leaves absolutely no doubt
yeah rook b8 is forced otherwise you
checkmated and then
you can just take it play d7 and that's
probably when jan schuster will resign
so
you know just up walking back to the
board here slowly he doesn't want to
look at this position
he wants to prolong the time
spent away from the board
rook b8
only move and a car is going to both
players know where the direction in
which this is going and i think they
both know exactly the moment that
yanchez is going to resign
and here comes d7
last move of the game yep
and double checking you see caro just to
make sure that f8 is not defended and
there he goes pushing the pawn
and duda will stop the clock here
yeah he's about to
and hikaru nakamura he's a determined
man just look at this angle honestly
this sums up hikaru's tournament his
personality and his hunger for second
place because there it is the result is
in the books christopher resigns hikaru
nakamura is in clear second place at the
candidates and what a result that is for
hikaru it may not have been the
smoothest game that he's ever played but
that doesn't matter because
he'll think about what how he can
improve his chess at a later time and
date but for now in today's date he is
in clear second place in defeated
candidates
yeah
just a major disappointment for duda who
has committed so many uncharacteristic
mistakes but the good news for him is
the tournament will finally be over
tomorrow he'll have some down time to
review exactly what went wrong before
um a very important event in the
olympiad and i think he'll be looking
forward to the olympiad as an
opportunity to redeem himself to show
the world
what january is capable of
when he's playing his best and when he's
in the right frame of mind and here are
the standings after 13 rounds with one
round to go and it's been all
napomnishin and everyone not named hikar
nakamura and dingley ren they're out of
contention for second place that may not
seem to be the case except for the fact
that dingley ren plays against hikaru
nakamura so it's the showdown that
everyone wants on mira yes so we have
the thriller for our last round and i
wanted to to point out that there was an
interesting moment during yandere
publishing interview where he said that
during the pandemics when you ask him
about streaming he realized first of all
how much work it is but
the professional chess players are also
faced with the dilemma should i do it
professionally or should i continue my
training in order to pursue some other
goals and it seems that hikaru has it
all
you know he is now on the second place
of the candidates tournament
and he is doing what he loves every day
yeah and i think he loves winning
classical chess games that's maybe one
of the top things that he enjoys and
he's been doing a great job four wins
two loss at this point and you mentioned
our interview with jan napoli here in
the studio he also caught up with dina
bill and kaya so we'd like to hear his
thoughts and the congratulations that he
received from all the fans
jan you're officially the challenger
congratulations
thanks thanks
[Applause]
jan do you feel more
excitement or
relief i don't feel anything like i feel
like i'm extremely tired so it's
i mean it's in insanely difficult
tournament
and uh
i mean despite like the score it was
like it was never easy it was like as i
said it was like up and down it was like
uh basically every game
okay almost every game i could uh could
have some potential danger yeah so i
could
i could never you know like feel safe
but uh maybe until
i felt like okay two points you know two
to two rounds to go it would be uh
gave me a good chance
perhaps couple of words about today's
game how surprised we are with uh
richard strauss and sicilian
uh
well you
of course
the line i wanted to to see at the board
was berlin here
so i i wouldn't mind you know like a
repetition of my previous game but
yeah research plays so many different
lines and rowser is one of them
so
well i knew like this f3 system is very
solid yeah but i like i wasn't sure
i mean okay this
i mean h6 bishop before uh d5 there is a
big uh
you know it's pretty much you know when
you need when you only need to draw you
want to take on d5 many times yeah and
then okay but then maybe
he wants to trade queens yeah and so on
so queenie one was i mean i wasn't sure
like queen one if he goes like through
some bishop before
a a3 bishop a5 here so maybe this would
be like very much unclear but yeah after
bishop c3 basically i think white has a
very nice position and i mean okay i
just so when i saw i can like uh
trade away all the pieces yeah trade
away queens and so on and get this end
game okay this end game
is kind of position you yeah
you can only you can only you know lose
on purpose rewired yes so i was like
pretty much happy when okay all this all
this was over
what do you think about your own
performance here at these candidates in
madrid compared to the previous one well
it's much better so so far i you know i
think in your case i managed to win five
somehow in two years here so here i also
managed to win five but here i didn't
lose second i mean not yet at least yeah
so hopefully tomorrow also i won't spoil
my my own party and maybe i'm trista
will be also you know kind to me but i
think especially like first couple of
rounds then it was like very difficult
for me to to get into the tournament
uh despite uh
it was quite
i don't know how to say it it was quite
quite a fortunate game of course against
dillian uh
i think i mixed up things badly in the
opening
i only could recall the idea but i think
i
i did everything wrong and also the
second game against fabiano was
very shaky and then okay after this okay
come draw against timur and after its
day somehow i felt you know more
uh more confidence okay that basically
i'm not doing that badly
now that you officially won you're the
challenger is there something you would
like to tell to magnus
i mean maybe stop playing this h4a for
nonsense yeah
perfect answer thank you so much ian and
once again congratulations thank you
[Applause]
wow wow wow wow that was an amazing
interview it's so nice to see the fans
applaud you live in person
well it's
first of all we're playing in such a
magnificent venue it feels uh that
you're playing in a theater so the
audience is
a very important element you know when
you have like certain characters uh plot
so
finally well players got what they
deserve
and the winner it's a rare occurrence
because chess games are often you know
played in silence everyone has to be
quiet but to receive that kind of
applause it i mean we could see on yon's
face it meant so much to him
yeah i mean you know nobody was
begrudging him the smile and one of the
great things about chess fans in general
not everybody of course is that
you know everybody likes certain players
but i think most chess fans are willing
to appreciate and reward a great
tournament even if
jan is not necessarily their favorite
player even if they were rooting for
ding for example or timur
they're still able to
appreciate and laud somebody who
deserves to win a tournament and i don't
think anybody is arguing that jan
is not the incredibly deserving winner
of the 2022 candidates yeah and he's
also quite humble about how the first
round went where you know dingley wren
he's like he out played me at the
opening and then something went terribly
wrong for the chinese number one so uh
we talk about what ifs a lot and
especially with someone like gianna
palmashi who
is historically a streaky player and
each girl was in the studio saying that
you know for yon he's not always stable
like but he has the ups and downs so if
in fact that game hadn't gone his way it
could have been different tournaments
but that's neither here nor there almira
he
won this tournament with a round of
spare and has lost zero games along the
way this happened in another universe
you know
i think that was such a beautiful moment
this tenth innovation
so i
well
i hope that we will see well a few
exciting games tomorrow
yeah we certainly will and just to
remind everybody yana pomshi he won his
game but hikaru nakamura sitting in
clear second place
four wins
two losses seven draws to his name and
for the first time in the entire event
he sits alone in second so as they say
better late than never it's the perfect
time to be sitting in second place and
it's the perfect time for everyone who's
watching to be tuning in because we have
the man of the hour hikaru how you
feeling after that game yeah i mean it
was a strange game um as i was saying
before i thought i was probably much
better out of the opening i suspect the
computer is going to say it's like plus
one or something but
i just couldn't find a plan and then i
started drifting um
which moment did you feel like you
started i mean i thought i thought
i mean i thought this whole position
after queenie two has just got to be
like really really good for white but i
couldn't figure it out somehow um okay
so
around when you want so first h4 has
been a pretty good move for you in this
tournament yeah i mean but the thing is
i i was confused because i was expecting
king f7 and then
uh yon just started playing knight c4
rook c6 delayed forever and i just
thought okay why not just play for a
concept um i thought it was quite strong
actually but
yeah it's all all normal just keep going
um
yeah 97
97 yep you want c4 uh-huh uh-huh
yeah i mean this is yeah night h7
so the first thing was this was all
planned presumably this poncho
i mean when i played h4 h5 my whole
concept was to move the knight from c3
and just do some setup i didn't actually
see this idea with knight h7 i thought
tonight might go back to f8 but i miss
this whole knight h7 g5 but you know
when i was looking at c4 i'm just like
okay i'll just play it anyway i mean
this looks so good for white but
oh maybe i'm wrong actually interesting
huh
so it's actually not great um so i
actually mis-evaluated this whole
position because i thought that after
bishop b2 and knight g6 it just looks
very very strong for white but maybe
it's not
yeah so at the board you were feeling
really confident about your position at
this point yeah i mean i just looking at
the knight looking at the piece played
no pawn breaks in the center i figure at
some point something's gonna happen with
f4 or something even like rook d1 and
bishop a3 later
huh okay so the computer actually
doesn't like it though that's
interesting
yeah i just i just felt like i mean
maybe earlier i don't do this but this
one i'm like okay i don't see any reason
it's bad i intuitively i think i'm
better so there's no reason not to just
play this gambit um where i give up on
e4 but
okay that's fairly surprising then so
maybe maybe i just actually
um i mis-evaluated everything that's
going on here um so i thought i was just
playing like a brilliant computer with
this knight on g6 um
do you know there are a lot of positions
nowadays for the computers i'll just
sack pawns and it's like feel like a
great night or you've got a great bishop
you're just better if not winning long
term so it's a little surprising
actually but yeah i i just couldn't find
a plan after king g8 and uh i thought
rook d1 was right and then knight g4 i
think is just a stupid move on move 23.
um
king g8 here and you said knight g4 was
bad yeah i don't know if it's maybe it's
okay i don't know
so i i guess to kind of unpack this for
everybody because the engine can just
tell us what the evaluation is you know
did you first come into today thinking
that
may not had to win but that's what you
were really pushing for i mean i wasn't
sure i thought yan would would have some
sense and play the petrol but then he
didn't play the petrov so
uh all bets are off when he chooses to
play the night or if i mean i was i
didn't really understand his choice so
once he did that then i was going to
play of course and i would say once i
played this knight f3 and he didn't play
bishop or actually after bishop e7 h3 on
move eight when he started thinking that
i'm like okay at least we're gonna play
a game um
and and yeah i mean i just i thought i
just felt like i had to be much better
but maybe it was just me being too
optimistic um
i don't know like because normally i'm
the other way normally when i i think
the more you have more material it's
it's actually better for that side but i
was just very optimistic um
and yeah i think when i played somewhere
like this nitro 4 again like because i
thought i had something and then i used
this time i couldn't find a clear way to
like play f4 or anything concrete and um
i mean i thought i thought bishop d8 was
a good move and i just i couldn't figure
it out here yeah i mean it says it's
pretty level right about even but daniel
yes yeah you know
yeah we thought the the moment when b5
bishop a3 happened was really critical
because jan played d5 did that surprise
you at all were you expecting a quick b4
well it was like it was like the ollie
it was like the ali reza game like when
i took on f6 and i started thinking i'm
like wait a second he's gonna take the
pawn right when when john started
thinking he didn't play b4 right away
it's like wait a second he's probably
gonna play d5 and funny thing is the
first time that i thought he might play
i immediately saw it takes rook c2
bishop d6 um while he was thinking and
then after like another 10 minutes he
did it which i was just shocked by yeah
i mean i what do i do instead of bishop
a3 though because i mean already i'm
much worse right yeah no he's starting
concise yeah so very accurately yeah
that's what i'm saying somehow i thought
it was good and then after knight g4 and
rook d2 it just it all goes wrong
immediately yeah i mean i thought he
would play b4 and when he didn't i was
shocked and then once he played d5 i
mean that's just a bit of a lucky break
that i have bishop d6 here and
i mean i think it's probably still okay
for black but i mean he thought i think
he thought if i don't know can you go
back and move can i just see this
position if i don't have bishop d6 am i
still okay or c2
um yeah but if i don't have bishop d6 oh
i guess queen f3 is somehow okay it gets
wild in that line yeah but basically i
think the thing is he thought he thought
for so long to play d5 so he thought he
was much better and then as soon as i go
bishop d6 it's like wait what's happened
and so the shift there and the fact that
he's already he wasn't low on time but
he only had like 15 minutes mentally i
think it's it's very very upsetting and
he just couldn't keep it together here
um
and then how about at this moment when
you went d6 and he didn't take your rook
on d3 but
ah because yeah there's this long line
with rookie a which might be a draw
right yeah i saw this i saw this during
the game and i wasn't sure but i thought
it worse it's a draw yeah it takes yeah
i'm rookie two right okay 2d7 rook a8 d8
takes takes a4
um and then takes takes i guess and then
bishop c7 and i thought okay worst case
is the draw right yeah they made rook d7
first but similar similar yeah i just i
knew there had to be some way to draw
this at least i wasn't sure if there was
a win but i knew that i'm not gonna lose
this and so once i knew that i wasn't
gonna lose this i'm just like okay i'll
do it and and he played 97 right away
which i actually expected because i mean
oh really
yeah because i think like he was getting
low on time he's already very disgusted
with everything i mean he was doing as
usual you could tell right and the
number number of times in this term when
y'all's like shaking his head or put his
hand up in the air like that it's just
like it's i mean so so many times so i i
expected 97. i didn't think he would
take on d3x it was already so disgusting
i think he also didn't realize though
how bad it is after knight d7 i think if
he used a bit more time he might have
realized um because the problem is he's
just like positionally lost even even
with what he got in the game which is
probably the best with the bishop on b6
um yeah i think that a lot of people who
sit and watch you supergrip masters play
you know in the candidates they don't
they see the evil bar go up and down but
as we're talking about here like this
position looks very scary for black
because within the bishop coming around
there's all sorts of checkmate threats
so do you think that he assessed this
position he i assume he probably was
tackling somebody like this but he
assessed it as winning for white yeah i
don't think he used a lot of time and
again i think because of how upset he
was mentally because of what he had done
not playing before i think he just he
just couldn't recover um and so he
played the obvious movement he didn't
even use much time i think he was like
20 seconds yeah it was not a lot of time
so i wasn't i mean i expected it i
wasn't wasn't that surprised um
but yeah it's it's just lost
unfortunately because it's this great
night in this past pawn i mean even what
i did i don't think is best i suspect
there's a cleaner way to win no you
don't really like uh
played perfectly
yeah fair enough um
yeah it's just the problem is there's no
counter play i mean at least in the game
against faviano there was some chance
for fabian to complicate but here it's
just i can do nothing like in the game
just go f3 king h3 rook c1 just like
just take it very very slow and there's
there's just nothing he can really do so
i mean it was just yeah it's difficult
game for sure for young christians
so you've got ding tomorrow with black
it's a big game second place is on the
line how are you feeling going into that
game yeah i mean the tournament's been a
success regardless of tomorrow so um
yeah i mean we'll see it's been it's
been fun um
playing playing against these players i
mean i've been pretty competitive so i
can't complain uh overall but yeah to
have to have one today and sort of just
be able to um just give it my all
tomorrow withdrawals is obviously very
nice although i mean to be to be frank
again just like everyone else on the
planet uh i don't don't really think
second place is gonna gonna matter in
the bigger picture but nonetheless i'm
happy with my play so just one more game
and we'll see if i can uh if i can do
well and even if second place doesn't
ultimately result in a world
championship match coming into this
event right you did win the grand prix
to get here not so many games played
though so to prove yourself over 14
rounds consecutively against such strong
opposition um you know you've been here
before it's not your first rodeo you
were number two in the world at some
point over 2800 but it must feel good to
show yourself but also everyone that you
know the best isn't necessarily behind
you yeah i mean i think i said this i
said this on my stream many times i had
one goal coming to this tournament that
was basically play well and essentially
not sort of commit like self let's just
say cell palms i don't want any certain
words but basically i felt like when i
played in 2016 i didn't sleep while i
didn't play well i thought a lot of my
issues were because i i was just a
little bit too serious perhaps and put
too much pressure on myself um in this
event i had one goal which is just play
good chess and if i play good chess i'll
be happy and i think i've played pretty
good chess um throughout the event so
it's been it's been a success um
you know i i not not to speak poorly
about some of the players here but i do
think um you know the the game against
lavon that i won um that i won against
in the fourth round of that uh berlin
grand prix i mean
that game was
i mean i i that game i think to me is
worth more than any of my wins here if
i'm being quite quite frank um so i'm
very very proud of that win but
nonetheless um
yeah to play play 13 games so far and to
be holding my own it's just yeah it's
it's gravy basically so i'm i'm just
it's a success regardless of tomorrow
and i'm just yeah very happy overall
would you say that one of the things
that defines your success and maybe
contributes to some of the other players
disappointing experience is the fact
that you
almost enjoy the experience of playing
more
yeah i mean i i think i've said i've
said this before i know a lot of people
have kind of not listened to what i've
said because they assume i'm just making
stuff up on my stream but i mean the the
problem with this tournament um and in
terms of why you saw pretty much
everybody melt away is that it's the
only tournament where you can't really
play let's just say your style if you
get behind if there's someone running
away with it you have to start taking
risks you have to start really changing
it up and um and so because of that
there's a lot more pressure whereas like
for example if fabiano is on on plus two
and yawns on plus five and say let's
just say it's like a grand chester or
something still 14 rounds but you know
normal prizes no no special prize at the
end for the winner i mean fabiano
doesn't doesn't melt down the way that
he does here there's he just he keeps
playing his game maybe wins a game here
a game there you know picks up his 10
points feels very good about himself and
it's all great but you know in this
event where you have to take chance and
there's a lot of pressure on on
everybody um it's much different whereas
for me it's just it's fun and i am going
to miss it i have to say i mean
especially after today you know towards
the end of this you know i was thinking
like it's a little bit sad because it's
uh it's back to back to the real world
um
in a couple of days for me but it's it's
been great and i i think not having the
pressure just playing and enjoying it
playing without the pressure makes a
world of difference in the candidates
for sure and you've been on vacation
from streaming and somebody else who's
on a vacation nishkiri did you see him
in the playing hall and was that a
distraction for you yeah he popped in
for like five seconds uh i think that
was actually it was move 40 i think it
was a critical moment when he popped in
for five seconds yeah just uh and
there's something bizarre about seeing
anisha in there with uh with uh with his
son
just bizarre i mean time flies i guess
that's that's all all i can say it
wasn't it wasn't distracting it was just
it was just surprising to see because
i've actually i don't think he's ever
been in a tournament with his with his
son so it was it was a surprise but yeah
it's just time flies i guess you know
his son's now a sensation he sat in don
his chair he uh came on the broadcast so
oh okay okay we had a good time up in
the studio nice nice yeah i mean it's
it's surprising i mean to see i think
there are a lot of people who i thought
would have qualified for the cans who
didn't you know anish is one of them you
know wesley lavonne etc um
but you know it's it's tough to qualify
and and even for annie she had his
chance but he he couldn't he couldn't
get out of the group in that third grand
prix so it's just it's tough but i think
everyone who's been here they deserve to
be in this tournament
there's a reason they're here you know
timor everyone's busy saying he doesn't
belong and then you know picks up that
win against me picks up that win against
ding two very nice victories for him so
uh that's yeah that's what it is
yeah and well we're going to have some
featured chat questions for you here uh
you we know how much you have to get
involved with chat so
i just read the instructions ask how
often do you think of chat during your
games um
not so much i have to say i mean
normally i'm just focused on the game i
mean once the game is like kind of clear
like this game for example somewhere
around the time i played bishop d2
bishop c3 my mind was drifting towards
um towards like twitch and all that
stuff just thinking about it but not not
all that much during during the game
especially when it's critical but once
it's clear-cut whether whatever the
result is going to be once it's
clear-cut i do start thinking again
about interviews recaps all that jazz
yeah well our next question here another
great one coming in from the chat
is are you excited to keep on playing
over the board after this i think you
kind of answered that yeah i mean it's
we'll see um i mean i have my
tournaments pretty much lined up for the
next light year it looks like so um
we'll we'll see i mean i'll probably be
playing todd steele and probably norway
chess hopefully but um yeah i mean i
think i'll enjoy playing but i do have
to say i think that one thing i've
learned from this hiatus for sure is
that when you're playing all these
events like the grand chester week after
week for months on end i think it's very
hard to stay motivated to to enjoy the
game um you know i think like vichy is
also a good example of that where he
hadn't played in a long time and so i
think because of that when he played in
norway it was just very fresh he was
motivated and it was a lot of fun to
play and so i think i mean finding that
balance is important i'll still
obviously play over the board without a
doubt but um i mean i i do stream as
well so uh it'll be a mix
yep and we have one washing yeah it's
all you all right i'm excited can you
say this has been an ongoing trend can
he say yeah you gotta look into this one
here but i i don't understand what is
what is the joke about it i'll say it
but so at the start of the show dania
has not done danny this whole script and
he says miss amigos and then richard did
it aneesh has done it yan did it yeah i
mean yeah all right everyone out there
miss amigos
i think this is a part of a compilation
that will be put together yeah i mean
it's just been a fun thing and the chat
goes crazy every time you start of the
show okay when it gets to that part they
start just saying ah okay so it's one of
those memes that i i just haven't seen
you're no stranger to the chat going
crazy over yeah okay so it's just one of
those memes that i haven't seen so i've
been too busy with the tournament yeah
you've been you'll find out about it
yeah next time okay i guess i have just
one question for you and much has been
made of this um the knockout format
versus the double run robin so
i mean
anish came in here so to just give some
context and he said that everyone who
answers this question has some bias if
you feel like you do better in uh
knockouts you probably prefer that
format but you have taken a hiatus from
chess and you're doing well in this you
do well in knockouts so i guess the
question has to be is for the candidates
tournament do you prefer the ko system
the knockouts or this double run um
very tough i mean i think there are
their benefits to both obviously for me
i think i would prefer a knockout format
i think i'm better in matches generally
i think i'm very very solid with black
and i pick up a game here there with
white whereas i'm generally not going to
put up like a huge score the way yon did
for example um so i would obviously
personally prefer knockouts but
that being said i think there's some i
think there's something to be said for
the fact that it's a you know very long
term you play everybody two times and i
think objectively the the 14 rounds just
the the fact that you have to stay in
shape you can't really ever ever slip um
makes me think that the probably from
the double round robin you have a more
deserving winner objectively so i
probably think that overall i'd prefer
the the double round robin
even though for me personally not it's
better wow that's uh it's very selfless
to you
well i mean again i think that's the
thing for me it's not really these days
it's not really about what is going to
favor me the most you know i i could use
another example where i think that uh
just to talk about an event on trust.com
the rapid chess championship i mean i i
think the reason that i've qualified for
the knockout every single week is
because we play without increment um
and like if you look at this tournament
for example that's another big thing is
i think having the event with increment
versus without increment has changed
several several results throughout the
uh throughout the event so for me like
it's not about what's best for me i
think it's just about objectively what's
best for the event and um you know i
think uh yeah i think uh i think i like
the 14 rounds more but i do think that
um if you're gonna have the if you're
gonna have the candidates without
increment you have to have the other
events without increment or you have to
have all the events with increment and
this event with increment as well
because i think that i i will just say i
think for fabiano playing without
increment i mean hurt him immensely i
mean the the couple times he got really
long time without the increment he made
blunders and i think with increments for
fabian it would have been better so i
think you have to pick one or the other
on the time control as well
well thank you hikara we really
appreciate your insight congratulations
on the win today we'll let you go rest
and prepare for your last round tomorrow
great thank you guys have fun
all right that was takara nakamura off a
fine victory over yonshiro duda we see
that in round 14 the most important game
of the round is for second place we see
it third on the graphic dingley ren with
the white pieces hikaru nakamura with
black
almirah you know we can talk about all
the other matchups but we gotta talk
about dingley red versus nakamura first
what are your thoughts
well my thoughts are that's uh well i
really want to be hikaru nakamura for a
day
i've been struggling with
self-confidence uh well my whole life
and
like just watching this interview uh
makes me happy you know so i think that
hikaru well
well it's a game of chess he will try to
do his best once once again and i think
the pressure is on dingle
for sure it is and dania hickard just
said his repertoire with black is very
solid so dingley wren's repertoire with
white usually puts pressure on his
opponent what are you anticipating for
that game ding has to not overthink it
and and not try to do everything in
seven moves which i think is what he
tried to do against timor and ding also
has to prepare for a surprise
so his response to something new that
hikaru throws at him has to be measured
it has to be objective
and and he's got to be okay with an
equal position if that's
where they go after the opening i think
he he has to aim for something
complicated with mutual chances but i
agree with almira the car is in a good
spot emotionally mentally and deng has a
very very difficult task ahead of him to
beat hikaru on demand
especially kara in the form he's been in
and we see the other matchups jan de
palmasi he doesn't want to lose that
game he actually said as much that it
was painful for him to lose in the last
running stingley run at the previous
canon sermon he gets the black pieces
against yanchustav duda and duda is
having a very tough event amira do you
expect jan napomnishi just to uh play
something solid try to make a draw and
what do you think yanchistov dude his
mindsets at
um
i think
jan will
might use
against young sisters the petrol if ayan
will play e4 but
nevertheless if
young sister wants to put up a fight he
needs to
dig deeper in his opening repertoire and
to start with d4 tomorrow
but
i'm not sure he's very motivated
who is going to be very motivated and
look at those lifetime scores jin
clearance first of all never beat hikaru
and today has
uh only one win and
uh
three losses against yandeep amnesia
yeah it's not good for dingley random
team but he first time for everything
perhaps and he's gonna try to get that
done and richard reports speaking of
somebody who hasn't seemed overly
motivated donya he gets the white pieces
against rajabov
i think both these players
wouldn't mind a half point split
yeah i think that's it's safe to say but
i i think that rapport if today's
opening is any indicator of his mindset
he's gonna play until the end both until
the end of the game and until the end of
the tournament i don't think that he's
going to give himself a rest day rijaba
certainly wouldn't mind that but i think
we're going to see a fight
well everyone will be happy to see that
because report his style has been
awesome and the only other game you know
for tomorrow's alireza with the black
piece against fabiano fabiano probably
is counting on that game to mean
something here's the white pieces and a
three wins and zero losses lifetime
score against alareza but amir for
fabiano all the players who've come in
for injuries have said that for it must
be incredibly disappointing for caruana
after the great start that he had and
all the expectations he undoubtedly had
to try to get first place here
even if it's disappointing he can still
finish a tournament on like a positive
note
um
on the other side uh la ferrous well
didn't play a very good game today so
i'm still waiting for him just to play
well
simply good game of chess it's been a
while in this tournament
it has the tournament has been going on
for a long time and for some players
like all the raids of perugia and shoes
of duda they find themselves down there
on the standings and you're right
alareza would like to end on a positive
note and maybe give himself some
motivation towards this future events
and this round 13 it is over we know who
is going to win this tournament it is
yon napomshi he's already clinched it
it's in the bag with one round to spare
and as we can conclude the second to
last day of competition here in madrid
we leave you with the best moments from
round 13 at the candidates including yon
napomnishi's
draw and win of the tournament so we'll
see you all tomorrow same time same
place
i think that he's a bit nervous
very interesting unorthodox decision but
the intention of that decision is
crystal clear he does not want
uh jan tristoff to move that knight off
of g6
and he wants to win with the chestnut
comp pin on his jacket because i just
saw him move and that that looks like
the chest like i'm pinning happy yeah i
don't have one of those
then after rook takes v5 it's checkmate
knight c2 and rook d1 oh my goodness i
mean out of nowhere
again i don't like to overanalyze body
language but jung reza just seems
uncomfortable
he seems like you might be thinking
like am i actually in danger of losing
this game which was supposed to be
unlosable after my opening
black can start with rogue b8
and hit the weak spot and if you play b5
then
c5 oh my gosh that out of my face oh my
goodness i don't think i've ever seen
this many
clear past pawns in a super gm game this
is i mean it's over because white's
pawns are going nowhere but look at the
chair there's no jacket on the chair
yeah we know what that means hikaru puts
the jacket on the game is over so he
already
was fooled once
playing on in a position he shouldn't
have and i don't think he's gonna do
this john can smell it
therapeutic moves it looks like yonder
here we go to become the challenger for
the world chess championship for a
second time in a row the clocks are
stopped the 2022 fide candidates are won
by yon napamishi a respectful smile and
there we see it finally
yeah you could see him breathing for the
first time in like two weeks
there are fans that are in the playing
hall giving their support look at jan
you can tell it means a lot to him
jan you're officially the challenger
congratulations
thanks thanks
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
you